EVERYONE AND WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON WATER
PARKS AND WILDLIFE AND MIDWATER
GARCIA THE CHAIR COMPANY BY OUR
VICE CHAIR. WE ARE GOING TO GET
STARTED WITH THIS INFORMATION-
HEARING ON CALIFORNIA. AND THE
DROUGHT ARE WE READY TO GO WE
HAVE SOME GREAT- PANELISTS TO.
TALK A BIT ABOUT THIS VERY
PRESSING ISSUE. WELCOME
EVERYONE WHO HAS JOINED US I
GOT TO GO THROUGH A COUPLE THE
HOUSEKEEPING ISSUES FIRST AND
ALL THAT YOU ALL OF. YOUR THIS
QUITE OFTEN- IN EVERY COMMITTEE
BUT IT'S A- POINT THAT WE GO
OVER THIS. BEGIN BY SHARING
INFORMATION ABOUT THE STEPS
WE'RE TAKING TO PRESERVE THE
SAFETY OF EVERYONE HERE AND TO
ENSURE THE PUBLIC'S ACCESS. TO
THIS DISCUSSION. THE TO THE
ONGOING PANDEMIC WE ARE
LIMITING THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT CAN PHYSICALLY
BE PRESENT IN THE HEARING ROOM.
TO ENSURE MEMBERS OF THE MEDIA
AND PUBLIC HAVE ACCESS TO OUR
PROCEEDINGS TODAY WE ARE
INSURING. OUR MULTIPLE WAYS TO
OBSERVE AND PARTICIPATE IN THIS
HEARING. TESTIMONY CAN BE
PROVIDED IN PERSON VIA PHONE OR
VIDEO CONFERENCE IN ROOM ONE
TWENTY FIVE. IN THE CAPITAL.
EVERYONE IN THE CAPITAL MUST
WEAR MASKS THIS INCLUDES. US
HERE IN THE ROOM. AND WITNESSES
VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOM AS
WELL. YOU DON'T HAVE A MASS WE
CAN PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU.
LIKEWISE EVERYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM OR THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY LOCATIONS IS REQUIRED
TO PRACTICE SOCIAL DISTANCING.
FOR ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
PRESENT IN THE HEARING ROOM WE
ARE REQUIRE PHYSICAL THIS IS
SEEN PLEASE FOLLOW THE
DIRECTIONS. OF OUR SERGEANTS
AND POSTED GUIDANCE. REMEMBER
THE PUBLIC. IN THE ROOM IS ON
THE AGENDA TO TESTIFY OR WOULD
LIKE TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY
DURING THE PUBLIC COMMENT
PORTION OF THE AGENDA. I WILL
ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. I WOULD ASK THE PUBLIC
NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE YOU
CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM ONCE
YOU ARE DONE TESTIFYING OR
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT. PLEASE BE
SURE TO OBSERVE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING WHEN IN THE EVENING
THE CAPITAL. ADDITION TO BEING
ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE
HEARING ROOM. WE MAY HAVE SOME
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC MAKING
USE OF THE- WITNESS VIDEO.
CONFERENCING ROOMS. THE WITNESS
CONFERENCING ROOM FOR THIS
HEARING IS LOCATED IN ROOM ONE
TWENTY FIVE. THOSE WITNESSES
WILL APPEAR ON THE SCREEN IN
THE ROOM SO MEMBERS CAN WATCH
THEIR TESTIMONY LIVE. AND ASK
QUESTIONS OF THESE WITNESSES.
WILL ALSO BE USING MODERATE
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH WHICH
ANYONE CAN PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THE END. OF THE
AGENDA THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN AND THE PAIN IS. TWO
FOUR TWO SIX TWO THREE SEVEN
YOU CAN ALSO FND THIS NUMBER
ON THE ASSEMBLY WATER PARKS AND
WILDLIFE COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AS
WELL AS ON OUR TV SCREENS
PLEASE CALL WHEN YOU HAVE HEARD
FROM THE LAST WITNESS ON. OUR
AGENDA THE OPERATOR ON THE LINE
WILL GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW TO BE PLACED IN THE QUEUE.
YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR LIVE
STREAM BROADCAST. YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE SOUND ISSUES.
YOU'RE HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH
THE MODERATOR PHONE SERVICE YOU
CAN CALL. THE COMMITTEE AT NINE
ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO
NINE SIX. COMMITTEE STAFF WILL
BE THERE TO HELP YOU. NAVIGATE
TO THIS ISSUE. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS IF YOU'D LIKE TO ASK A
QUESTION PROVIDE A COMMENT
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND. TO GET
MY ATTENTION. AND YOUR
MICROPHONE SO THAT THE YOU ARE
READY TO SPEAK WHEN CALLED.
UPON BEFORE WE BEGIN I
ACKNOWLEDGE I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE ASSEMBLY
HAS EXPERIENCED A NUMBER OF
DISRUPTIONS TO THE COMMITTEE.
AND THE FLOOR PROCEEDINGS IN
THE LAST. SEVERAL MONTHS WE
WILL ENSURE ALL VOICES ARE
HEARD HOWEVER CONDUCT. THAT
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDES. THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
THE HEARING IS PROHIBITED SUCH
AS- CONDUCT REMOVING YOUR MASK
REFUSING TO PUT IT BACK ON.
TALKING TO MAKING LOUD NOISES
FROM THE AUDIENCE. A RAINOUT
BRIGHTENING OR ABUSIVE LANGUAGE
SPEAKING LONGER THAN THE TIME
ALLOTTED EXTENDED DISCUSSION OF
MATTERS NOT RELATED TO THE
SUBJECT OR ANY OTHER DISRUPTIVE
ACTS. INDIVIDUAL DISTRICTS ARE
HEARING PROCESS. WE WILL DIRECT
THEM TO STOP AND WARNED THEM.
CONTINUED THEY COULD BE REMOVED
FROM THE CAPITOL BUILDING. ALSO
DOCUMENT ON THE RECORD THE
INDIVIDUAL INVOLVED AND THE
NATURE OF THE DISRUPTIVE
CONDUCT THE CONDUCT DOES NOT
STOP I WILL REQUEST ASSISTANCE
FROM THE SERGEANTS. AND ESCORT
THEM OUT OF THE CAPITOL
BUILDING THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
COOPERATION. NOW THAT WE HAVE
GONE OVER THE LOGISTICS OF
TODAY'S HEARING I WANT TO
WELCOME OUR WITNESSES TO THE
HEARING AND THANK THEM FOR.
COMING BEFORE THE COMMITTEE TO
DISCUSS HOW CALIFRNIA SHOULD
RESPOND TO THE DROUGHT. WE ARE
IN THE MIDDLE OF OUR SECOND DRY
YEAR IN A ROW. AND ON TRACK TO
SEE OUR FOURTH DRIEST YEAR ON
RECORD. SILVA DEJA VU AND I'M
SURE YOU ALL WOULD AGREE. WE
JUST CAME OUT OF OUR LAST DROP
INTO THOSE SEVENTEEN.
CALIFORNIA'S MORE SEVERE. DROP
ON RECORD AND HERE WE ARE AGAIN.
WE ALL AGREE THAT WATER IS
ESSENTIAL FOR PUBLIC CAL TO
MEET BASIC NEEDS TO DRIVE OUR
ECONOMY TO SENATOR VERSE THAT
TO RESOURCES. WHEN DROUGHT
OCCURS EVERYONE AND EVERYTHING
IS ADVERSELY AFFECTED. THE TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE TO SIXTEEN
DROUGHT EXPOSED CHALLENGES. IN
MEETING OUR PROMISE TO ENSURE
ACCESS TO SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAD CRIPPLING
EFFECTS ON AGRICULTURAL SECTOR.
IT DRIED UP RIVERS AND THAT IN
TURN ADVERSELY IMPACTED OUR
COMMERCIAL FISHERIES AND
FINALLY EXACERBATED WILD. FIRE
SEASON IMPERATIVE THAT WE DO
EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN RESPOND
TO AND MITIGATE THESE DROUGHT
CONDITIONS. THERE'S TOO MUCH AT
STAKE NOT TO TAKE ACTION I WANT
TO THANK EVERYONE FOR
PARTICIPATING IN THIS IMPORTANT
DISCUSSION I WANT TO HEAR ABOUT
WHAT WE'VE LEARNED FROM THE
LAST DROUGHT. AND WHAT WE ARE
DOING RIGHT NOW WHAT WE NEED TO
DO THIS SUMMER NEXT YEAR AND
BEYOND TO BECOME MORE DROUGHT
RESILIENT. WE HAVE A HISTORIC
OPPORTUNITY WITH THE BUDGET
SURPLUS IMPENDING BOND
PROPOSALS. TO MAKE DOWN
PAYMENTS TO ALLEVIATE THE
IMPACTS OF FUTURE DROUGHTS
LET'S TAKE ADVANTAGE OF IT SO
THAT WE CAN EASE THE IMPACT OF
THE DROUGHT. ON ARGUMENT
COMMUNITIES FARMS FISHERIES AND
NATURAL RESOURCES WITH THAT.
I'D LIKE TO ASK OUR VICE CHAIR
TO SEE IF HE HAS ANY OPENING
REMARKS AND THEN WE'LL MAKE
INTRODUCTIONS TO OUR FIRST
PANEL. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I'M LOOKING FOR TO THE
DISCUSSION TODAY I KNOW THAT
WE'RE ALL CONCERNED ABOUT THE
DROUGHT CONDITIONS THROUGHOUT
OUR STATE. MUCH OF MY DISTRICT
IS ALREADY REELING AND READY TO.
HERE WHAT WHAT OUR SOLUTIONS
ARE GOING TO BE SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND I LOOK FOR TO THE
DISCUSSION. HELLO ASK IF ANY OF
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
WOULD LIKE TO SAY A FEW REMARKS
BEFORE WE JUMP IN. OKAY SEE
NONE. WE WILL INTRODUCE OUR
FIRST PANELIST AT THREE
DOLLARS. PRINCIPLE FISCAL
POLICY ANALYSIS. ANALYSTS FROM
THE ALLEY OF OFFICE AND SHE IS.
GOING TO BE. ON OUR SCREENS I
BELIEVE SO. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS RACHEL EHLERS
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. I WILL BE SPEAKING FROM
A HANDOUT BUT HOPEFULLY WE IS
WITHIN YOUR MEMBER PACKET
THAT'S CALLED HOW DID THE STATE
RESPOND TO THE LAST DROUGHT.
IT'S ALSO WANTS TO BE ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND IT'S ON.
OUR WEBSITE AT LEóN DOT CA DOT
GOV FOR THE PUBLIC. AND I THINK
MY TASK HERE IS TO PROVIDE A
BRIEF REVIEW OF HOW THE STATE
RESPONDED- DURING THE LAST
DROUGHT BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY THAT
CAN PROVIDE A LOT OF CONTEXT AS
WE HEAR. THAT THE CHAIR SAID DO
YOU HAVE- ALL OVER AGAIN WE
FIND OURSELVES IN FACING
SIMILAR CONDITIONS. SO IM PEI
ONE OF THAT HAND OUT YOU KNOW
DOUBTS ARE NOTHING NEW IN
CALIFORNIA- WE DID AND THEY
SAID BUT SIGNIFICANT DROUGHT
RECENTLY- IF IT LASTED FROM TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE THROUGH TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN ALTHOUGH SOME
MIGHT SAY IT ACTUALLY STARTED
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN. AND WE
JUST HAD ONE WHEN YOU'RE IN THE
MIDDLE IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
THAT THAT BROKE IT UP- BUT THAT
THAT DROUGHT WAS REALLY
SIGNIFICANT IN A LOT OF WAYS IT
WAS THAT BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
THE DRIEST FOUR YEAR STRETCH.
ON RECORD IN CALIFORNIA
CONSECUTIVE YEARS- IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN WAS THE THIRD
DRIEST YEAR ON RECORD. AND
THOSE THOSE DRY CONDITIONS A
LACK OF PRECIPITATION WE'RE
REALLY COMPOUNDED BY ALSO
HISTORICALLY HIGH TEMPERATURES-
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AND TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN WERE
RESPECTIVELY THE HIGHEST. TWO
YEARS HOTTEST TWO YEARS ON
RECORD IN CALIFORNIA. AND OF
COURSE WE KNOW THAT WHILE I'M
WARM TEMPERATURES EXACERBATING
DRY CONDITIONS THEY BOTH
INCREASED DEMAND FOR WATER FOR
IRRIGATION FOR AGRICULTURE. AS
WELL AS IN URBAN SETTINGS- AND
THEY ALSO DECREASE SNOWMELT
RUNOFF BECAUSE OF EVAPORATION
AND DRIER SOILS THAT SOAK UP
THAT WATER- SO RIGHT SO REALLY
YEAH- A DIFFICULT COMBINATION
OF HIGH TEMPERATURES AND- AND
LACK OF PRECIPITATION. SO THE
DROUGHT IMPACTED. SECTORS ALL
ACROSS CALIFORNIA IN MANY
DIFFERENT WAYS. URBAN
COMMUNITIES RURAL COMMUNITIES
AGRICULTURE AT A PARENT PAYMENT
I KNOW THAT YOUR THIRD PANEL
HAS RELEASED OTHER
REPRESENTATIVES WHO WILL GO
INTO THE IMPACTS FOR EACH OF
THOSE SECTORS SPECIFICALLY SO I
THINK I'LL SKIP OVER- TRYING
TO. TRYING TO DISCUSS THOSE AND.
STILL GET THOSE IN YOUR THIRD
PANEL. SO TO EACH YEAR OVER
HAND THAT. ADD THIS SUMMER. HOW
THE SPEED STAY SPEND MY TO
RESPOND TO THE LAST AS YOU CAN
SEE IT WAS A TOTAL OF FOUR
FOUR. DOLLARS IN STATE FUNDING
THAT SPREAD ACROSS FOUR
DIFFERENT YEARS. AND YOU CAN
SEE THAT THE BIGGEST CATEGORY
THERE WAS FOR WATER SUPPLY TWO
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS AND
THOSE ARE REALLY FOR A BIGGER
LONGER TERM PROJECTS INTENDED
TO INCREASE THE STATE'S
RESILIENCE FOR FUTURE DROUGHTS
THEY DIDN'T REALLY THOSE TYPE
FOR BIG LONG TERM PROJECTS
DON'T REALLY HELP. IN THE
MIDDLE OF A DROUGHT BECAUSE
THEY DO TAKE A LONG TIME TO
PERMITTED TO RETAIN FINANCING
TO- KIND OF GET CONSTRUCTION
AND GET UNDER WAY- SO THAT THAT
BIGGER CATEGORY HOPEFULLY WILL
HELP US. NOW SEVERAL YEARS
LATER AS WE'RE FACING ANOTHER
DROUGHT BUT REALLY HAVEN'T
PROBABLY DIDN'T PROVIDE TOO
MUCH RELIEF IN THE MIDST OF THE
LAST DROUGHT. ALL RIGHT NOW
THAT'S THAT'S DIFFERENT FROM
THE EMERGENCY RESPONSE
CATEGORIES YOU SEE HERE WHICH
REALLY WORK SPENDING TO TRY AND
ADDRESS MELIORATE- PRESSING
URGENT CONDITIONS THINGS LIKE.
WELLS GOING DRY EMERGENCY
DRINKING WATER NEEDS DEAD AND
DYING TREES THAT NEEDED TO BE
REMOVED- FIRE. FIRES BREAKING
OUT SO. THAT THEIR WORK AND IT
SHOULD BE TO DIRECTLY. TO BEING
WORSE BECAUSE OF THE DROUGHT.
AND THEN WHAT I CAN. A WHICH
YOU SEE THE SEND NEXT. AS WELL
I THINK I'VE CHECKED CATEGORIES
THEY BOTH CAN HELP REDUCE
DEMAND IN RESPONSE TO IMMEDIATE
PRESSING DROUGHT CONDITIONS.
BUT THEN ALSO HAVE ONGOING.
RESULTS AND ASSISTANCE IF
THINGS LIKE REMOVING- TURF AND
LAWN IN FRONT YARDS OR
REPLACING TOILETS OR SHOWER
HEADS WITH MORE EFFICIENT-
FIXTURES. THAT CAN HELP REDUCE
WATER DEMAND ON AN ONGOING
BASIS AND WE SEE THAT WE SEE
THAT- URBAN PER CAPITA WATER
USE NOW IT REMAINS LESS THAN IT
WAS IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
BEFORE THE LAST DROUGHT SO WE
SEE THAT THAT HAS HAD. I'M
GOING TO IMPLICATIONS. AND THEN
THE FINAL CATEGORY OF SPENDING
THEIR ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
PROBABLY COULD ALSO HAVE FALLEN
UNDER THE EMERGENCY RESPONSE
HEADER FRANKLY BECAUSE A LOT OF
THAT SPENDING THE MAJORITY THAT
SPENDING WAS REALLY IN RESPONSE
TO EMERGENCY CONDITIONS. THINGS
LIKE TRACKING FISH DOWNSTREAM
RESCUING FISH FROM HATCHERIES
ARE STREAMS WHERE- CONDITIONS
HAVE DEGRADED- THAT ADDRESSING
HUMAN WILDLIFE CONFLICT A
CONFLICT FROM WILDLIFE COMING
DOWN YOU KNOW HOW TO THE HILLS
IN SEARCH OF FOOD BECAUSE OF.
DRY CONDITIONS SO- THAT. WAS
ALSO KIND OF EMERGENCY RESPONSE.
IN LOOKING AT THESE EXPENDITURE
THE WATER RIGHT UP TOP WITH
THREE PRETTY. YOU FIND. YOU
RECALL THAT PROP ONE PASSED IN
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN SO IN THE
MIDST OF THE DROUGHT SO THOSE
BIG EXPENDITURES WERE PRIMARILY
CAPITAL PRIMARILY SUPPORTED BY
BONDS. WHERE IS IN CONTRAST
THESE OTHER EXPENDITURES WERE
PRIMARILY GENERAL FUND OF THE
TOTAL SPENDING GENERAL FUND
MADE UP ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED
MILLION ROUGHLY ABOUT 20% OF
THE TOTAL SPENDING. AND THEN
THERE WAS ALSO SOME SUPPORT
FROM SOME SPECIAL FUNDS WHEN
THE STATE WAS ABLE TO KIND OF
FIND THE NEXUS BETWEEN THE
REQUIREMENTS OF PARTICULAR
SPECIAL FUNDS. AND THE ACTIVITY
OF WANTED TO PERFORM- BUT BONDS
TO TYPICALLY ARE NOT WELL
SUITED FOR THAT KIND OF
EMERGENCY RESPONSE BECAUSE OF
THE OF THE DAY ARE THERE
TYPICALLY FOR CAPITAL PROJECTS.
SO THE NEXT PAGE PAGE THREE OF
MY HAND OUT REALLY. COVERS WHAT
I JUST SAID VERBALLY SO WE'LL
SKIP AHEAD TO PAGE FOUR. I'M
HERE YOU CAN SEE I WON'T GO
INTO THIS IN GREAT DETAIL BUT
JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT FOR YOU
THAT THE DROUGHT RESPONSE
REALLY INVOLVED A LOT OF STATE
AGENCY FOURTEEN DIFFERENT STATE
AGENCIES THESE REPRESENT THE-
DEPARTMENTS THAT RECEIVED A
SHARE OF THAT THREE POINT FOUR
BILLION SHOWN ON THE PREVIOUS
CHART. SO WHILE CERTAIN
AGENCIES LIKE THE ONES YOU'LL
HEAR FROM TODAY FISH AND
WILDLIFE D. W. R. AND THAT
STATE WATER BOARD PLAYED REALLY
BIG ROLES. IMPORTANT HERE TO
SEE THAT OTHER STATE
DEPARTMENTS ALSO PLAYED A ROLE
AND RECEIVED FUNDING IN DROUGHT
RESPONSE. SO I'M- REALLY
HIGHLIGHTS THE NEED FOR
COORDINATION OF COME BACK TO
THAT AGAIN IN A MOMENT I ALSO
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT FOR YOU THAT
SOME OF THESE DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS WERE FUNDED FOR
PRETTY SIMILAR EFFORTS YOU CAN
SEE D. W. R. O. YES AND THE
WATER BOARD WERE ALL RECEIVED
FUNDING FOR ADDRESSING
EMERGENCY DRINKING WATER. NEEDS
IN SIMILARLY CALIFORNIA WE ASK
BOTH RECEIVED FUNDING FOR
REMOVING DEAD TREES- SO FUNDING
SPREAD ACROSS A WIDE. A WIDE.
SWATH OF STATE GOVERNMENT HERE.
TURNING TO PAGE. OF THE HANDOUT.
BUT IT WASN'T JUST SPENDING
MORE THAN JUST MONEY THERE ARE
ALSO SOME SIGNIFICANT POLICY
CHANGES ENACTED BY THE STATE
AND RESPONDING TO THE DROUGHT-
SOME OF THOSE WERE- KIND OF AN
EMERGENCY SHORT TERM BASIS
EITHER THROUGH. EXECUTIVE ORDER
I'M REGENCY REGULATIONS OR THE
EXISTING REGULATORY AUTHORITY
HAVE DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS.
THESE INCLUDED WATER STATEWIDE
WATER CONSERVATION REQUIREMENTS
FOR URBAN COMMUNITIES- THE
WATER BOARD TEMPORARILY RELAXED
FLOWING WATER QUALITY STANDARDS
WITHIN THE DELTA CANNOT ORDERED
AN ENFORCED. THAT LAST WATER BE
DIVERTED FROM THE STATE'S
RIVERS AND STREAMS. A FISHING
GAME COMMISSION CLOSED SEVEN
RIVERS AND STREAMS TO FISHING
IN ORDER TO PROTECT FISH IN LOW
WATER FLOW AREAS. AND THEN THE
STATE ALSO A WAVE SOME STATE
REQUIREMENTS SUCH AS
CONTRACTING AND- SEACOR
REQUIREMENTS FOR IN ORDER TO
EXPEDITE. SOME DROUGHT RESPONSE
ACTIVITIES. BUT IN ADDITION
THOSE TERM ACTIVITIES THE STATE
ALSO AND PRIMARILY THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE SOME THROUGH
REGULATIONS BUT PRIMARILY
THROUGH LEGISLATION ADOPTED
SOME ONGOING- PERMANENT CHANGES
AS WELL AND ONE OF THE BIGGEST
WAS A PATH TO SUSTAINABLE
GROUNDWATER MANAGEMENT ACT
WHICH IN OF THIS COMMITTEE IS
VERY FAMILIAR WITH IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN. TO REGULATE
THE STATE'S USE OF GROUNDWATER.
THERE WAS ALSO LEGISLATION
ENACTED TO- AUTHORIZES STATE TO
CONSOLIDATE SMALL WATER SYSTEMS
THAT FAIL TO MEET DRINKING
WATER STANDARDS. BY NEW
STANDARDS FOR WATER EFFICIENCY
AND OUTDOOR LANDSCAPES AS WELL
AS- FOR CONSERVATION OF
PLANNING AND CITIES AND URBAN
COMMUNITIES. AND WHILE IT WAS
ADOPTED IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY
AFTER THE DROUGHT ENDED THIS
EVENING AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER FUND WHICH PROVIDES A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO ADDRESS
DRINKING WATER ISSUES. I THINK
IT'S FAIR TO SAY THAT WAS
REALLY MOTIVATED BY SOME OF THE
PROBLEMS THAT- ERE EXACERBATED
AND HIGHLIGHTED DURING THE
DROUGHT AS WELL THAT'S
OBVIOUSLY ABSENT SIGNIFICANT
ONGOING POLICY. CHANGES ACTED
BY THE LEGISLATURE. SEVEN TWO
TO THE- PAGE OF THE HANDOUT
LESSONS TO INFORM THE CURRENT
DROUGHT I KNOW THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT THE NEXT
ADMINISTRATION PANEL IS GOING
TO TALK ABOUT AS WELL. BUT
SENATE REALLY JUMPED OUT AT US
FROM THIS LOOK BACK AT WHAT WE
DID WITH THE STATUS STATE
RESPONDED LAST TIME. AND ONE OF
THE FIRST IS WHAT YOU ALL ARE
DOING ALREADY TODAY WHICH IS
HOW CAN E BE PROACTIVE RATHER
THAN REACTIVE. HOW CAN WE TAKE
ACTIONS EARLY OR EARLIER BEFORE
PROBLEMS WORSEN AND GET AHEAD
OF. WHAT WE THINK THE PROBLEMS
MIGHT BE AND WHAT WE SAW LAST
TIME RATHER THAN WAITING UNTIL
CONDITIONS GET REALLY DIRE. THE
SECOND POINT HERE ON THE
COORDINATION AND EFFICIENCY OF
STATE DEPARTMENTS BEING REALLY
IMPORTANT I THINK YOU'LL HEAR
ABOUT THIS IN THE NEXT PANEL AS
WELL. HOW CAN WE AVOID
DUPLICATION SHOULD WE BE
FUNDING THREE DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS TO ADDRESS DRINKING
WATER ISSUES. MAYBE BUT MAYBE
THAT CREATES SOME SOME-
BUREAUCRACY AND DUPLICATION
THAT IT MIGHT NOT BE NECESSARY
SO TAKING A LOOK AT HOW CAN WE
BE- AS AS A FIX EFFECTIVE AND
EFFICIENT AS POSSIBLE AS A
STATE GOVERNMENT. AND THE MAIN
BOX YOU KNOW MORE STAFF MORE
PERMANENT STAFF IF DROUGHT IS
THE NEW NORMAL TO TRY AND SET
UP SOME OF THE STRUCTURE SO
THAT WE ARE. BEING MORE
PROACTIVE AND PREPARED TO
ACQUIRE NEED ACROSS ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT AREAS OF STATE
GOVERNMENT THEY NEED TO BE
INVOLVED. THE THIRD POINT HERE
IS WHEN I MENTIONED- EARLIER
BUT REALLY THINKING. AS A
LEGISLATURE HOW YOU WANT TO
BALANCE YOUR LONG TERM RESPONSE
TO FUTURE JOBS WITH THOSE
PRESSING NEEDS AND THOSE LARGE
WATER SUPPLY. PROJECTS AND
INVESTMENTS WELL IMPORTANT AND
ESSENTIAL TO DROUGHT
PREPAREDNESS. AREN'T AS
EFFECTIVE IN IMMEDIATE DROUGHT
RESPONSIVE THINKING ABOUT WHAT
ARE YOUR GOALS. AND WHAT ARE
THE APPROPRIATE FUNDING SOURCES
AND- TAKES A PROJECT TO ADDRESS
THOSE GOALS WHETHER THEY ARE
SHORT TERM RESPONSE. OR AND-
LONG TERM RESPONSE. AND THAT
LEADS TO THE FOURTH POINT THERE
ABOUT THE HAVE. FUN SOURCES AND
THINKING ABOUT IF YOU WANT AND
WHAT WE SAW DURING THE LAST
ROUND WAS THAT FOR SOME OF
THOSE IMMEDIATE RESPONSES
EMERGENCY RESPONSES. BECAUSE OF
IT'S FLEXIBILITY GENERAL FUND
IS OFTEN THE BEST FOR. I HAVE
BEEN ON THE POINT I JUST
MENTION THIS ISN'T THE BUDGET.
BUT WANT TO BE SURE THAT ALL
THE MEMBERS HAVE ON THEIR RADAR
OUR OFFICE PUT OUT A REPORT A
COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO ON THE
STATE APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT.
WHICH IS A NEW FACTOR THAT'S
GOING TO BECOME A AN INCREASING
ISSUE IN BUDGETARY DECISIONS
AND WELL PLACED SOME
LIMITATIONS EVEN AS WE FACE A
HISTORIC SURPLUS. ON HOW THE
STATE CAMPAñA CAN SPEND SOME
OF THAT FUNDING. SO I WON'T GO
INTO DETAIL ON HERE UNLESS
THERE ARE QUESTIONS I'M HAPPY
TO ADDRESS BUT JUST SOMETHING
WE WANT TO BE SURE YOU ARE
THINKING ABOUT. I'M THERE ARE-
SOME TYPES OF EXPENDITURES THAT
ARE NOT SUBJECT TO THAT LIMIT-
AND THEN SOME THAT ARE SO AS
YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT HOW I
WOULD GO TO RESPOND EFFECTIVELY
AND HOW TO USE THE- STATE.
FUNDING THAT'S AVAILABLE. IS
THAT WILL BECOME A FACTOR. I AM
AN EXPERT HERE I'M GOING. WATER
CHALLENGES BECOME COMPOUNDED
DURING DROUGHTS I THINK THAT
WAS ONE OF THE BIG HIGHLIGHTS
FROM THE LAST DROUGHT. WE DO
HAVE ANY FUNDING SOURCE A NEW
PROGRAM TO ADDRESS DRINKING
WATER ISSUES BUT I THINK WE
SHOULD. ALL BE PREPARED IN THE
STATE SHOULD REALLY HAVE. AS
ONE OF ITS- PRIMARY FOCUS AREAS
OF FOCUS IN THE COMING MONTHS
AND YEARS THAT THAT THAT THAT
IS UNLIKELY TO BE ANOTHER. A
RESURGING PROBLEM IS THAT I'M
DRINKING WATER ISSUES. THAT
LEADS TO THE NEXT POINT THAT
RURAL AND VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES ARE PARTICULARLY
AFFECTED BY DROUGHT WE SAW THIS
DURING LAST DROUGHT. NOT
JUST FROM DRINKING WATER BUT
ALSO ECONOMIC IMPACTS- FROM
AGRICULTURAL SLOWDOWNS- IN
PRODUCTION FOR EXAMPLE AND WE
KNOW THAT LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR ALSO FACE
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACTS FROM
THE COBIT. NINETEEN PANDEMIC
AND SO ARE ALREADY STRUGGLING
SO AS WE THINK ABOUT HOW THE
STATE'S GOING TO RESPOND IN
WHERE TO TARGET ITS ASSISTANCE
THINKING ABOUT. WHAT
COMMUNITIES MIGHT NEED THOSE
ASSISTANCE THAT ASSISTANCE THE
MOST- R. AS THEY FACE
ADDITIONAL CHALLENGES- THE
SECOND TO LAST POINT HERE ON
FISH AND WILDLIFE JUST THE-
REMINDER THAT THE STATE HAS THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROTECT.
PUBLIC TRUST RESOURCES SUCH AS
FISH WILDLIFE AND WATERWAYS ON
BEHALF OF THE PUBLIC SO AS WE
THINK ABOUT OUR PRIORITIES AND
OUR JOB RESPONSE WE CAN HAVE TO
BALANCE HUMAN NEEDS AS WELL AS
ENVIRONMENTAL NEEDS. AND ONE OF
THOSE ENVIRONMENTAL. IMPACTS
THAT REALLY WAS HIGHLIGHTED
DURING THE LAST DROUGHT WASN'T
UNPRECEDENTED NUMBER OF DEAD
TREES WHICH THEN CONTRIBUTED TO
A MORE SEVERE AND INTENSE
WILDFIRES WHICH LIKELY. WILL
STATE SHOULD BE PREPARED TO
SEE. WHETHER WHETHER THIS
SUMMER- AND IN THE COMING YEARS
OF DROUGHT CONDITIONS CONTINUE.
SO I MISTER CHAIR THAT
CONCLUDES MY PRESENTATION I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
NOW AND ALSO HAPPY TO HANG
AROUND AND- ANSWERED QUESTIONS
AFTER THE ADMINISTRATION
PRESENTS IF THERE ARE ANY FOR
ME TO. WE WILL LOVE OPEN IT UP
FOR ANY QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. AT. ONE
THIRTY- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
RACIAL BUT MY QUESTION IS IN
REGARDS TO THE STATE HAS
RECEIVED APPROXIMATELY TWENTY
SIX BILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT UNDER THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN. WE ALL
KNOW THAT THERE'S ALWAYS
STRINGS ATTACHED TO IT WHEN IT
COMES FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. BUT WE KNOW THAT IT
CAN BE USED FOR WATER. WHAT IS
A TRADE OFF FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO UTILIZE THIS ONE TIME FUNDS
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
COMPARED TO A BOND ISSUE AND I
THINK WE'RE TALKED INTO THIS
COMMITTEE COUPLE TIMES THREE
POINT FIVE THREE POINT EIGHT
BILLION- SO HOW CAN YOU RESPOND
TO THAT FOR. THE OF THE
RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU YES WE ARE FORTUNATE TO
RECEIVE THE FEDERAL FUNDING-
THERE ARE AS YOU MENTIONED SOME
REQUIREMENTS AROUND IT ALTHOUGH
I WILL SAY THAT THIS THIS-
FUNDING IS MUCH MORE FLEXIBLE
THAN THAN. OTHER TYPES OF
FEDERAL FUNDING THEN WE USUALLY
RECEIVE SO IT CAN BE USED TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE IMPACTS OF
THE COCA NINETEEN PANDEMIC
THERE IS A NEXUS THERE WITH
WATER PARTICULARLY AROUND WATER
DEBT. AND SMALL WATER SYSTEMS
AND HOUSEHOLDS THAT HAVE FORMED
BEHIND THE WATER BOARD AN
ESTIMATE JANUARY THE TOTAL TO
AT LEAST A BILLION DOLLAR
STATEWIDE SO THAT WAS MONTHS
AGO SO THAT'S ONE AREA THAT YOU
COULD THINK ABOUT TARGETING
SOME OF THAT FEDERAL FUNDING
THAT WOULD PROBABLY BE MORE
APPROPRIATE TO USE THAT AS
COMPARED TO A BOND- OTHER AREAS.
IT CAN BE USED FOR WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE AS WELL- WHICH
OFTEN IS- ALSO A BOND
APPROPRIATE. SO SOME OF THE
DIFFERENCES OBVIOUSLY WITH THE
FEDERAL FUNDS WE DON'T HAVE
BUDGET SERVICE- SO. WE CAN USE
THE FUNDS WITHOUT HAVING TO. BE
CONCERNED ABOUT FUTURE COSTS ON
THE GENERAL FUND. AND IT IS
AVAILABLE KIND OF MORE READILY
NOW- BUT THEY THERE MAY BE SOME
REQUIREMENTS I THINK WE'RE
STILL WAITING FROM ADDITIONAL
GUIDANCE FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AROUND SPECIFICALLY
WHAT TYPES OF PROJECTS. AND
WATER PROJECTS. THE FUNDS CAN
BE AS FAR AS COMPARED TO A
BONDS THAT IF THE STATE WERE TO
CRAFT. COULD ROOM BE ADDRESS IN
SOME STATE SPECIFIC NEEDS THAT
THAT PERHAPS FEDERAL FUNDS
WOULDN'T BE ALLOWED. SO I THINK
I THINK THERE'S CERTAINLY
OVERLAP WHEN IT COMES TO WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE AND CAPITAL
PROJECTS BUT THERE. ALSO COULD
BE SOME DISTINCTION THERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN LOVE CAN
OF REFER TO THAT DOUBLE R.
LIMIT LATER ON FOR THE MONEY TO
RESOURCES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER SMITH. YEAH QUESTIONS. I
DO HAVE A QUESTION AND THAT'S
IN REGARDS TO- ISSUES THAT COME
UP REGULARLY OF BACKING UP
TODAY AND DIFFERENT HEARING
RELATED TO STORAGE AND- FUNDING
THAT'S BEEN PUT FORWARD. IN
PRIOR BONDS THAT CAN YOU GIVE
US AN OVERVIEW OF THE MONEY
THAT IS AVAILABLE FROM PREVIOUS
BONDS RELATED TO- WATER
INFRASTRUCTURES SPECIFICALLY IN
THE STORAGE. AREA. YES
PROPOSITION ONE WAS THE MOST
RECENT BOND THAT INCLUDED QUITE
A BIT OF FUNDING FOR STORAGE
TWO POINT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS- THE WAY THE BONTA
STRUCTURED IT DIDN'T ALLOCATED
FOR SPECIFIC PROJECTS BUT
RATHER DUMB IT'S A CONTINUOUSLY
PERFORATED DOESN'T EVEN GO
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE TO
IDENTIFY PROJECTS. IT'S CONVENE
WITH CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATED
TO THE WATER COMMISSION TO
DETERMINE HOW TO ALLOCATE THEM
DEAFENING ACROSS DIFFERENT
PROJECTS I THINK THEY CHOSE
ABOUT EIGHT DIFFERENT PROJECTS
FOR INITIAL ALLOCATIONS- ONE OF
THOSE PROJECTS THE TEMPERANCE
FLAT PROJECT HAS SINCE
WITHDRAWN FROM FROM THE PROGRAM
I THINK BECAUSE IT WASN'T ABLE
TO. IDENTIFY SUFFICIENT OTHER
FUNDING TO MATCH THE STATE
PLANS SO MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THERE IS SOME FUNDING THEIR
MOST MOST OF THOSE FUNDS HAS
BEEN- AT LEAST INITIALLY
ALLOCATED BY- THE WATER
COMMISSION FOR SPECIFIC STORAGE
PROJECTS BUT MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THERE IS SOMETHING I THINK
IT'S ROUGHLY A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN THAT
BALLPARK. HAT WAS INITIALLY
DEDICATED FOR TEMPERANCE FLAT
THAT NOW- HE'S WAITING FOR THE
WATER COMMISSION TO DEDICATE TO
IT TO A DIFFERENT PROJECT
EITHER ONE OF THE EFFORT TO ADD
TO THAT ONE ANY OTHER ONES
THEY'VE ALREADY. SET ASIDE
FUNDING FOR OR FOR A NEW
PROJECT. THERE WASN'T ANY
FUNDING IN PROPOSITION. SIXTY
IT SPECIFICALLY FOR WATER
STORAGE. IT WOULD YOU BE IN A-
TO ALLOW. YOU KNOW WHAT- IN
YOUR PERSPECTIVE- IS. THE HOLD
UP ON THESE PROJECTS AND YELLED
THE- PROS AND CONS OF NOT
MOVING THESE PROJECTS AND JUST
SITTING ON THIS ON THESE BONDS.
YEAH I MEAN IT PARTICULARLY IF
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT YOU KNOW
THE NEW DAM FOR RAISING THE DAM
AND THEY THOSE ARE VERY BIG
INVOLVED PROJECTS THAT TAKE A
LONG TIME SO- YOU KNOW IDEA I
AM NOT FAMILIAR ENOUGH WITH ANY
OF THEM TO- OPINAR COMMENT ON
WHETHER THERE ARE OTHER ISSUES
THAT HAVE COME OUT BESIDES JUST
THE- LONG TERM NATURE OF SOME
OF THE BIG PROJECTS- I THINK.
JUST ONE COMMENT TO MAKE IS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE CANNOT RE
ALLOCATE THAT MANY OR RE
APPROPRIATED FOR ANYTHING ELSE
BECAUSE OF HOW THE BOND A
TO VOTERS IT REALLY IS- IN. THE
WAY THE BOND WAS STRUCTURED UP
TO THE WATER COMMISSION TO TAKE
THE NEXT STEPS. THANK YOU AYE
YOU KNOW THOSE ARE QUESTIONS
THAT THAT COME UP QUITE OFTEN-
AS I MENTIONED EARLIER CAME UP
THIS MORNING. IN TERMS OF.
FUTURE INVESTMENTS THAT ARE
BEING PROPOSED WHETHER THEY BE
BE A BONDS. OR ONE TIME DOLLARS
AS WAS MENTIONED BY MY
COLLEAGUE- MISTER SMITH- ONE OF
THE FEDERAL FUNDS OR FOR THAT
MATTER STATE. SURPLUS DOLLARS
THAT COULD BE PUT. TOWARDS THIS
TYPE OF EFFORT. AND WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE DROUGHT RIGHT
WE WANT TO TALK ABOUT WHAT ARE
WE DOING ON THE SIDE OF STORAGE
IS NO. ESCHEN ABOUT IT KIND OF
HAND IN GLOVE DISCUSSION BUT-
THANK YOU FOR- RESPONDING TO
THOSE QUESTIONS. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS- YES MISTER BENNETT.
SHOULD DO WE HAVE MORE
PANELISTS- YES PRESENTING IT
WOULD ACTUALLY HAPPEN ANOTHER
WAS ONE QUESTION HERE AND THAT
IS THE COMMITTEE MIGHT WANT TO
CONSIDER WHETHER THE RESPONSE
IN THE TWENTY TWELVE TO TWENTY
SIXTEEN PERIOD WAS. I'M SORRY
WHETHER THE RESPONSE AT TWENTY
TWELVE TO TWENTY SIXTEEN
PERIOD- WAS SUFFICIENT OR DO WE
NEED TO DO SOMETHING DIFFERENT
WITH THIS NEW DROUGHT COMING
UP. I'D LIKE TO RESPOND TO
THAT- BUT I THINK IT WOULD LIKE
TO WAIT. YOU HAVE OF THE PALACE
IF YOU HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE
ONLY OFFICE WE HAVE TO TAKE
THAT. THANK YOU. OKAY WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR JOINING
US AND THAT WE APPRECIATE YOU
STICKING AROUND. IN THE CASE
THAT THERE ARE QUESTIONS THAT
COME UP AFTER DISCUSSIONS WITH
THE OTHER. PANELISTS SO AGAIN
THANK YOU. AND WE WILL- CHECK
BACK IN WITH YOU IF THAT.
HAPPENS WE'LL GO OUT TO BATTLE
TO. ABOUT TWO A. G. JONES. FROM
THE INTERSTATE RESOURCES
MANAGER SHE IS THE INTERSTATE
RESOURCES MANAGER AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES.
AND WE HAVE ERIC A DAHLE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR DIVISION OF WATER
RIGHTS STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD. DARREN FULL M.
S. DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
DIVISION OF DRINKING WATER
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD. AND CHAD GABLE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR ECOSYSTEM CONSERVATION
DIVISION DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE EACH ONE OF THEM HAS
ABOUT FIVE TO EIGHT MINUTES TO
PRESENT. AND WILL ANNOUNCE THAT-THE FIRST PANELISTS PLEASE-
BEGIN. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS-
PLEASURE TO BE HERE BEFORE YOU
THIS AFTERNOON WE WERE GOING TO
SHOW A POWER POINT BUT IT LOOKS
LIKE- THAT IS DISABLED IN THIS
FUNCTION. SO I WILL GO AHEAD
WITHOUT THE POWER POINT SO IT
WAS ALL THERE WE GO. OKAY I WAS
JUST GIVEN THAT ALL RIGHTY SO
WE WANT TO START OUT. IN
COORDINATION MY COLLEAGUES AT
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD TALKING ABOUT THE
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE THAT
WAS RECENTLY AUTHORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA NATURAL RESOURCES.
AGENCY AND TALKING ABOUT SOME
OF THE BACKGROUND FROM THAT AS
MISS UNIVERSE MENTIONED THE-
ISSUE OF DROUGHT IN CALIFORNIA
IS CERTAINLY NOT A NEW THING
WE'VE HAD LOTS OF EXPERIENCE IN
DEALING WITH DROUGHTS. AND IN
THE LAST DROUGHT WE WERE
SIGNIFICANTLY CHALLENGED BY THE
RECORD BREAKING NATURE OF THAT
DROUGHT. OF VERY WARM
TEMPERATURES EXTREMELY- DRY
HYDROLOGY AND- SOME NEW
CHALLENGES IN THE FORM OF
IMPACTS RELATED TO THAT-
WARMING TRAY. INCLUDING
SPECIFICALLY THINGS LIKE UP
WILDFIRE FOR EXAMPLE. AND ALSO
OTHER CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED
WITH OUR FIRST EVER ZERO WATER
ALLOCATIONS TO AGRICULTURAL
CONTRACTORS OF THE BUREAU OF
RECLAMATION'S CENTRAL VALLEY
PROJECT WHICH IN TURN IN
INTRODUCED OTHER ISSUES SUCH
AS- INCREASED GROUNDWATER
PUMPING THAT IN SOME CASES
AFFECTED DOMESTIC- OF.
PRIVATELY OWNED DOMESTIC WELLS
AND- ALSO IDENTIFYING A NUMBER
OF WATER RIGHTS CHALLENGES
ASSOCIATED WITH MANAGING IN
THOSE CONDITIONS SO THE C. N.
R. A. REPORT LOOKED AT THESE-ITEMS THAT WERE SPECIFIED IN
THE LEGISLATIVE DIRECTION. AND
IT WAS THE SECOND TIME THAT WE
HAD A STATE WIDE DROUGHT
EMERGENCY PROCLAMATION FOR
DROUGHT THE FIRST TIME THE
STATE ORDERED MANDATORY URBAN
WATER USE REDUCTION. AND
WORKING IN SOME- REALLY
UNPRECEDENTED AREAS FOR US SUCH
AS THE ASSISTANCE FOR THE SMALL
WATER SYSTEMS AND ESPECIALLY
THE PRIVATE WELL OWNERS WHOSE-
WELLS WORKED- DEWATERED DURING
THE DROUGHT. FOLLOWING THAT
DROUGHT DURING AND FOLLOWING WE
SAW A NUMBER OF NEW INITIATIVES
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THESE ISSUES
INCLUDING ENACTMENT OF THE
SIGNAL I JUST LIBATION.
INCREASED ATTENTION TO WATER
CONSERVATION VERY IMPORTANT DOT
FUNDING SOURCE- SUPPORT FOR
SMALL WATER SYSTEMS BECAUSE ONE
OF THE- LESSONS LEARNED FROM
THIS DROUGHT WAS THE NEED TO
PLAN AND ACT SOONER IN RESPONSE
TO DRY CONDITIONS. BECAUSE
THINGS SUCH AS THE RESPONDING
TO SMALL WATER SYSTEM- OUTAGES
AND- MANAGING FOR THINGS TO
TAKE LONG LEAD TIME TO
DEVELOPMENT TO DEVELOP. REALLY
DO REQUIRE I STARTING EARLIER
GETTING BACK DATA AND BEING
PREPARED TO RESPOND EARLIER TO
IMPACTS WE MAY NOT HAVE QUITE
SEEN IN A SIMILAR FASHION IN
PRIOR DROUGHTS SO YOU KNOW FOR
EXAMPLE- SPEAKING OF. THE OTHER
THINGS THAT WE I SHOULD BE
DOING EARLIER IS HAVING THE
DATA COLLECTION AND FORECASTING
TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THESE
ACTIONS THAT WE NEED TO TAKE
WHETHER IT IS- CONTRACTING FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE TO BE ABLE TO. UPGRADE
AND IMPROVE THEIR FACILITIES
AND RESPOND TO- WATER
CONDITIONS OR TO BE ABLE TO
DELIVER EMERGENCY ASSISTANCE TO
THE SMALL WATER SYSTEMS SO ARE
OUT OF THIS WE'VE IDENTIFIED A
NUMBER OF INITIATIVES TO MOVE
FORWARD IN THE DATA AND
FORECASTING. AREA AND ALSO
REALLY WORKING ON CLOSE
COORDINATION AMONG OUR AGENCIES
AND ONE GOOD EXAMPLE OF
WAS THE WORK THAT WAS DONE IN
THE LAST ROUTE WITH THE VERY
CLOSE COORDINATION OF THE STATE
WATER PROJECT AND FEDERAL
CENTRAL VALLEY PROJECT
OPERATIONS. WITH THE STATE AND
FEDERAL FISHERY AGENCIES AND
WITH THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD WHICH HAD A
NUMBER OF OUR CHALLENGES TO
ADDRESS IN TERMS OF MANAGING
WATER RIGHTS WITH LIMITED DATA
AND UNDER THESE EXTREMELY DRY
HYDROLOGIC CONDITIONS. SO YOU
KNOW HOW DOES THIS INFORM OUR
RESPONSE IN THE ACTIONS WERE
TAKING THE CURRENT DROUGHT
WELL- SO WE'VE HAD NOW A
SEPARATE DRY YEAR VERY DRY IN
MUCH OF THE STATE ABOUT HALF OF
AVERAGE PRECIPITATION FOR MANY
PARTS OF THE STATE. AND WE ARE
IN FACT SEEING STREAM FLOWS IN
OUR MAJOR SIERRA CASCADE RIVER
BASINS THAT ARE SO IMPORTANT
FOR URBAN AND AGRICULTURAL
SUPPLIES ACTUALLY TRACKING-
BELOW OR AT THE LEVELS WE SAW
IN THE TWO DRIEST YEARS OF THE
LAST DROUGHT IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
AND TWENTY FIFTEEN- WHICH IS
CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT GIVES
MY COLLEAGUES AT THE- STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD.
LAWS BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO
ADMINISTER THE WATER RIGHTS
UNDER THESE VERY CHALLENGING
CIRCUMSTANCES AND ALSO POINTING
OUT THE EFFECT OF LONG TERM
WARMING IN THE CLIMATE SYSTEM
THAT WE HAVE BEEN SEEING
THERE'S REALLY BEEN A
NOTICEABLE CHANGE SINCE IN THIS
CENTURY AS COMPARED TO DROUGHTS
IN PRIOR CENTURIES. WITH THE
IMPACT OF WARMING CONDITIONS-
LOWER RUNOFF EFFICIENCY FACTOR
MEANING THAT EVEN IF WE GET A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF. RAINFALL
LITTLE BETTER THAN AVERAGE
LET'S SAY IN THE NEXT WATER
YEAR WE MAY STILL BE DEALING
WITH DRY CONDITIONS IN THE NEXT
YEAR BECAUSE MORE WATER IS-
BEING LOST TO THE SYSTEM AND
THEREFORE WE REALLY DO HAVE TO
PROACTIVELY PLANNED FOR. WHAT
IF NEXT YEAR IS DRY SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WE AT D. W. R. HAVE
BEEN DOING- ON THE STATE WATER
PROJECT SITE- STREAMLINE THE
WATER TRANSFER PROCESS FOR-
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO USE OUR
FACILITIES TO MOVE WATER.
PREPARING DROUGHT CONTINGENCY
PLAN AND- SHARING THAT WITH THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD AND FISHING WILDLIFE.
UPDATING OUR INFORMATION
COLLECTION. ABOUT REPORTING OF
DR PRICE BUT WELLS SO THAT WE
NOT HELP PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO
THESE FOLKS AS WE SEE THESE
CONDITIONS DEVELOPMENT AND
RECENTLY WE SUBMITTED A REPORT
TO THE LEGISLATURE WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS ON. INCREASED
UP TECHNICAL AND OTHER
ASSISTANCE FOR THE SMALL WATER
SYSTEMS AND RURAL COMMUNITIES
THAT WE KNOW FROM PAST
EXPERIENCE HAVE BEEN SO
ADVERSELY AFFECTED DURING OUR
PRIOR BALLOTS BECAUSE LARGER
URBAN WATER AGENCIES TEND TO BE
ABLE TO. HAVE THE RESOURCES AND
THE CAPACITY TO MANAGE WELL TO
MEET OUR CUSTOMERS NEEDS
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A LARGE
RATEPAYER BASE AND KEY- AFFORD
THE INVESTMENTS AND RELIABILITY
WHICH IS NOT NECESSARILY THE
CASE FOR SYSTEMS THAT ONLY HAVE
A FEW HUNDRED CONNECTIONS. AND
THIS IS WHERE I SHOULD STOP AND
ASK GOD IF MY COLLEAGUES AT THE
WATER BOARD WITH LIKE TO CHIME
IN. THANK HI THIS IS ERIC I
THOUGHT I THINK I A- I CAN GO
FIRST IN TURN WILL GO.
SUBSEQUENTLY GOOD- AFTERNOON.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE PANEL
MY NAME IS ERIC ACT ON THE TIP
HE DIRECTOR FOR THE DIVISION OF
WATER RIGHTS AT THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD. AND TO
FOLLOW JEANINE'S STATEMENTS I'D
LIKE TO OFFER A FEW- KIND OF
HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEWS OF.
CHALLENGES AND- FIVE SUCCESSES
IN AND FUTURE AREAS WHERE WE
WANT TO FOCUS ON IMPROVEMENT
FOR THIS DROUGHT AS WELL AS
FUTURE DROUGHTS THAT COULD
OCCUR. AS JEANINE HIGHLIGHTED
THE- TWENTY TWELVE TO TWENTY
SIXTEEN DROUGHT. WE HAD A
NUMBER OF CHALLENGES WITHIN THE
DIVISION OF WATER RIGHTS- WE
ISSUED CURTAILMENT NOTICES OR
NOTICES OF WATER UNAVAILABILITY
TO OVER NINE THOUSAND WATER
RIGHT HOLDERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. HE IS- WATER RIGHT
HOLDERS RANGED IN PRIORITY FROM
ABOUT NINETEEN OH TWO TO THE
RESIDENTS AND AFFECTED MILLIONS
OF ACRE FEET OF POTENTIAL WATER
DIVERSIONS FROM OUR STATE'S
SURFACE WATER SYSTEMS. ALONG
WITH THOSE CURTAILMENT NOTICES
CAME IN UNPRECEDENTED NUMBER OF
SITE INSPECTIONS AND WHILE
ENFORCEMENT ISN'T ALWAYS A
POPULAR WORD IN SOME AREAS-
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT COMPONENT
IN MAKING SURE THAT- THE
STATE'S WATER RATES SYSTEM IS
FOLLOWED AND THAT PEOPLE ARE
COMPLYING WITH THE CURTAILMENT
NOTICES. WHEN THEY ARE- ISSUED.
WE ALSO ISSUED A NUMBER OF
WHAT'S REFERRED TO AS TEMPORARY
URGENCY CHANGE PETITIONS AND
THESE ARE PETITIONS TO MODIFY.
PERMIT TERMS OR REQUIREMENTS
WHEN CONDITIONS MAY BE
UNAVOIDABLE OR UNFORESEEABLE.
IN A REALLY NEEDED I KIND OF
EMERGENCY CONDITIONS WE DID A
NUMBER OF QC PEAS IN THE
BROADER BE DELTA WATERSHED BUT
ALSO OTHER WATERSHED THROUGHOUT
THE STATE INCLUDING THE RUSSIAN
RIVER. WE ALSO ADOPTED A NUMBER
OF VERY SUCCESSFUL INSTREAM
FLOW EMERGENCY REGULATIONS
THESE WERE PRIMARILY FOCUSED ON
AN ADDRESS FISH HABITAT IN
MIDDLE DEER AND ANTELOPE CREEK
WHICH ARE TRIBUTARIES TO THE
SACRAMENTO. AS WELL AS FOR
SMALL TRIBUTARIES TO THE
RUSSIAN RIVER. AND THESE WERE
SUCCESSFUL IN ENSURING KIND OF
MINIMAL WHAT WE SOMETIMES
REFERRED TO AS BELLY SCRAPING
FLOWS TO ENSURE THAT THERE'S
JUST ENOUGH WATER TO. HELP
PREVENT- IN. LOSS OF ENTIRE
COHORTS OF CERTAIN PER CLASS IS
A OF A FISH. AND ALTHOUGH I'D
IT WAS NOT DIRECTLY WITHIN THE
DIVISION OF WATER RIGHTS THAT
DELTA WATER MASTER. DEVELOPED
EXECUTED A VOLUNTARY DROUGHT
AGREEMENT FOR WATER USERS IN
THE DELTA THE ULTIMATELY
RESULTED IN APPROXIMATELY 25%
REDUCTION IN OVERALL WATER
DIVERSIONS FROM SERVICE DELTA
WATERS. THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
SUCCESSES IT HIGHLIGHTED THE
NOTICES OF WATER UNAVAILABILITY
IT WAS THE FIRST TIME IN ABOUT
FORTY YEARS THAT THE DIVISION
HEAD ISSUED THAT SCOPE AND
SCALE OF. CURTAILMENT NOTICES-
THAT WAS A SIGNIFICANT LIFT FOR
THE DIVISION BUT ULTIMATELY ONE
THAT WAS FAIRLY SUCCESSFUL.
EMERGENCY INSTREAM REGULATIONS
WERE ALSO SUCCESSFUL AND- THE
NUMBER OF ENFORCEMENT
INSPECTIONS OVER TWO YEAR TIME
PERIOD WE DID ABOUT. A TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED INSPECTIONS AND
SITE VISITS COMPARED TO A
NORMAL YEAR WHERE WE MIGHT HAVE
BETWEEN FIFTY AND ONE HUNDRED-
THAT CAME WITH ADDITIONAL STAFF
RESOURCES TO HELP US DO THAT.
IT WAS A SIGNIFICANT LIFT BUT
ULTIMATELY HI. PERFECTIVE IN
ENSURING THAT THE BOARD'S
CURTAILMENT NOTICES WERE
FOLLOWED OR OBSERVED. WE ALSO
HAD A NUMBER OF CHALLENGES IN
SOME OF THESE CHALLENGES
CONTINUE HI SACRAMENTO RIVER
TEMPERATURE WAS A CHALLENGING
THE PREVIOUS DROUGHT. I THINK
IT REMAINS A BIT OF A CHALLENGE
THIS YEAR AS WELL ALTHOUGH. THE
COORDINATION AND COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN OUR STATE AND FEDERAL
PARTNERS. HAS MARKEDLY IMPROVED
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE- US BUREAU OF
RECLAMATION NDW ARE. INTENDED
MANAGING- JUST BROADER WATER
RELEASES FROM PROJECT
OPERATIONS TO ENSURE. IN
TEMPERATURE ALTHOUGH FROM
SHASTA IT'S LARGELY THE CDP OR
US BUREAU OF RECLAMATION THAT'S
RESPONSIBLE FOR THOSE RELEASES.
HI AND IT ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
IN KIND OF LONG TERM ISSUES
THAT WE'VE WE'VE NOTED IN THE
PREVIOUS DROUGHT AND CONTINUE
TO HIDE OBSERVE OUR TIMELINESS
IN TERMS OF DATA WATER RATES
DATA IS REPORTEDLY CURRENTLY UP
TO EIGHTEEN MONTHS AFTER IT WAS
ACTUALLY DIVERTED WHICH RAISES
CHALLENGES FOR HOW TIMELY WE
CAN KIND OF OBSERVE AND COMPILE
AND UNDERSTAND WATER USE IN
ACROSS A REAL TIME BASIS. TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THESE JUDGES WE
RECENTLY DEVELOPED A REPORT
CALLED THE WATER RIGHTS DROUGHT
AFTER REVIEW OR WATER REPORT.
HEY INVOLVES REACHING OUT TO A
NUMBER OF STAKEHOLDERS TO YOU
ESSENTIALLY ASK THEM WHAT
WORKED WELL DURING THE PREVIOUS
DROUGHT WHAT DIDN'T WHAT ARE
THE AREAS FOR IMPROVEMENT. AND
FROM THOSE TWENTY FOLLOWER
TWENTY FOUR ENTITIES. THERE
WERE- OVER FIVE HUNDRED UNIQUE
RECOMMENDATIONS. BUT THEY ALL
KIND OF FELL AND WITHIN FOUR
BROAD CATEGORIES AVERAGING
COMMUNICATION WAS CITED BY
EVERY SINGLE PARTICIPANT. AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT- DIVISION
IS SPECIFICALLY FOCUSING ON
THIS. YEAR AND THIS DROUGHT.
DATA AND ACCOUNTING WERE ALSO
IDENTIFIED BY ALMOST EVERY
PARTICIPANT. AND I'M SITTING
AREAS WHERE WE COULD SHARE DATA
EARLIER AND HAVE A BETTER KIND
OF QAQC DATA. HI THERE WOULD BE
ONE OF POLICY AND POLICY
UNCERTAINTIES I THINK THAT
THOSE STILL REMAIN IN MANY
RESPECTS- AND THEN ALSO
COORDINATION JUST BETWEEN. OUR
STATE PARTNERS AND OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS AS WELL AND THAT'S
AGAIN AN AREA THAT WE'RE
ACTIVELY IMPROVING UPON AND
FOCUSING ON CURRENTLY. I THINK
WITH THAT I'LL TURN IT OVER TO
MY COLLEAGUE DURABLE HEMOS.
THANK YOU WORK AND THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN- I'M TERRIBLE HIM IS
I'M DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
DIVISION OF DRINKING WATER AT
STATE WATER BOARD. I WANTED TO
FOCUS TODAY- LARGELY ON OUR
RESPONSE FOR WATER SYSTEMS-
DURING THE LAST DROUGHT THERE
WERE A LOT OF SYSTEMS THAT
PERFORMED ADMIRABLY LARGELY ARE
LARGE SYSTEMS WE HAVE FOUR
HUNDRED WATER SYSTEMS THAT WE-
CONSIDERED TO BE A LARGE
DELIVER THE BOOK THE WATER TO
LARGEST POPULATION IN THE
STATE. HOWEVER WE ALSO HAVE
OVER TWO THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED
SMALL WATER SYSTEMS IN THE
STATE- AN INCREDIBLE NUMBER-
AND THEY RANGE IN A LOT OF
DIVERSITY- MANY OF THEM UNDER
RESOURCE AND OR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. AND THEY AS A MISS
OVERSTATED OFTEN SUFFER THE
MOST AND I CONDITIONS LIKE
THESE. SO FOCUSING ON THE
LESSONS WE LEARNED FROM THE
LAST DROUGHT. OF FOUR KIND OF
AREAS I WANTED TO TOUCH ON ONE
OF THEM IS WERE THIS YEAR UNDER
THIS CONDITIONS STARTING TO
PERFORM EARLY ASSESSMENTS
ASSOCIATED WITH HOW THE WATER
SYSTEMS ARE PERFORMING-
SPECIFICALLY WELL MONITORING
UNDERSTANDING THE LEVELS OF
WATER IN THEIR WELLS SO THAT
WE- CAN. ADDRESS THE SITUATION
BEFORE THEY ACTUALLY HAVE DRY
WELLS ON THEIR HANDS AND- MAYBE
EVEN UP YOU KNOW PULLED ERA TO
THE PUMPS AND DAMAGED EQUIPMENT
WHICH OBVIOUSLY CREATES A MUCH
MORE CATASTROPHIC FAILURE THAN
JUST ON THE WATER FLOWS. AND SO
ON THAT ALONG WITH
UNDERSTANDING OF WATER SYSTEMS
A CALL FROM RESERVOIRS AND HAVE
IN TAKES IN THOSE RESERVOIRS
MANY SMALL SYSTEMS DO THAT- AND
IT'S NOT THE DRESS OR HAS TO GO
INTO BEFORE THEIR INTAKE IS
ABOVE THE WATER SURFACE. AND
SUB MONITORING THE LEVEL AS
RESERVOIRS ARE MOVED DOWN AND
THEY'RE GREATLY DEPLETED THIS
YEAR I'M COMING INTO THIS THIS
IS YOUR AT THE END OF THE-
SEASON SO- IT'S SUPER CRITICAL
THAT WE BE ABLE TO MONITOR
THOSE AND ANTICIPATE. AT A TIME
BEFORE GOING TO NEED TO TAKE
EMERGENCY ACTIONS ALONG THE
WATER SYSTEM. TO TRY TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY MAINTAIN THEIR
WATER FLOW. I KNOW VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WE SAW THE LAST
WAS DOMESTIC WILL FAILURES. AND
WE HAVE ALREADY. THERE INCREASE
THE TECH ASSISTANCE. OUR MONEY
THAT WE PROVIDE TO SEVERAL OF
OUR- NON GOVERNMENTAL PARTNERS
THAT WORK IN THIS SPACE WITH
US. TO ASSIST PRIVATE DOMESTIC
WELL OWNERS AND SO THAT PROGRAM
IS- GETTING READY TO TAKE OFF
AS I'M SURE. WE HAPPEN WE STILL
HAVE DRY WELLS FROM THE LAST
DROUGHT WATER SYSTEMS THAT. ARE
INDIVIDUAL PRIVATE DOMESTIC
WELLS IS NOT RECOVERED AND ARE
STILL IN THE PROGRAM AND THE
PROGRAM IS BASICALLY CONTINUE
TO RUN AND OUR JUST. AMPING IT
UP A LITTLE BIT MORE TO.
ANTICIPATED INCREASE THERE
UNFORTUNATELY. THIRDLY IS-
WATER QUALITY OF STAND BY
WELLS. DURING THE INTERIM-PERIOD BETWEEN THE DROUGHTS
WE'VE HAD SEVERAL NEW. MAXIMUM
CONTAMINANT LEVELS UP AND OTHER
CONTAMINATING EVENTS COME INTO
PLAY THAT WEREN'T IN THE LAST
DROUGHT SPECIFICALLY ONE TWO
THREE T. C. P. HAS IMPACT AND
IMPACT A LARGE NUMBER OF
DRINKING WATER WELLS IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY- AND SOME IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. AND THEN
WE HAVE THE P. FAST
CONTAMINATION AS WELL THERE'S
NOT A REGULATORY LIMIT THERE
BUT- THERE IS LEGISLATION ABOUT
PUBLIC NOTIFICATION AND MOST
WATER SYSTEMS ARE TRYING TO
LIMIT THEIR OUR POPULATIONS
EXPOSURE TO THOSE CHEMICALS BY
TAKING WHILE OFFLINE. CHANNELS
ARE NOT SERVING THAT WATER BUT
OF COURSE REMOVES A RESOURCE
THAT THEY WERE COUNTING ON
HEADING INTO THIS DROUGHT. AND
SO ONE OF OUR PRIORITIES HERE
IS TO MAKE SURE WE COMMUNICATE
WITH WATER SYSTEMS THAT AS THEY
PLAN TO BRING BACK. THOSE TYPE
OF WELLS- THAT THEY PLANNED NOW
FOR MAKING SURE THEY'RE
INSTALLING THE NECESSARY
TREATMENT TO MAINTAIN WATER
QUALITY AS THEY BRING THAT
STAND BY WHILE BACK. AND WE'RE
COMMITTING TO WORK WITH THEM TO
MAKE THAT HAPPEN AND PRIORITIZE
OUR- OUR RESOURCES AS WELL TO
MAKE SURE WERE PROMOTING THOSE
IN GETTING THOSE SOURCES BACK
ONLINE AHEAD OF OTHER WORK THAT
WE WOULD NORMALLY BE DOING. AND
FINALLY- ERIC MENTIONED THE
CURTAILMENT ORDERS THAT
HAPPENED LAST YEAR. LAST
DROUGHT. PREVIOUSLY WE HAD A
TWENTY TWO THOSE WHERE WE ISSUE
A- A COROLLARY BUILDING
MORATORIUM OR CONNECTION
MORATORIUM TO MAKE SURE THE
WATER SYSTEMS ARE NOT ADDING.
FURTHER CAPACITY DEMANDS.
BECAUSE THEY'RE UNDER
CURTAILMENT. AND JUST TRYING TO
MEET HEALTH AND SAFETY FLOWS.
OUR PREPARING TO CONTINUE TO DO
THAT AS WE DID LAST TIME AS-
CURTAILMENTS ARE NECESSARY AND-
TO FOLLOW THROUGH. AND WITHOUT
I WILL. IN MY PRESENTATION AND
STAND BY FOR QUESTIONS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE HAVE. I THINK
ONE FINAL PRESENTER AND THAT
THE CHAD DOUBLE THE P. DIRECTOR
OF THE ECOSYSTEM CONSERVATION
DIVISION DEPARTMENT OF- FISH
AND WILDLIFE. THAT'S RIGHT
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
OF ME TODAY I'LL BE SITTING AT
FOR DIRECTOR BOTTOM. MY NAME IS
JOE DEWAN THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF THE ECOSYSTEM CONSERVATION
DIVISION A PHARMACIST WHILE I.
WAS ASKED TO PROVIDE YOUR
UPDATE ON LESSONS FROM THE LAST
DROP. IT HIGHLIGHTS SOME OF THE
CURRENT ACTIVITIES THE
DEPARTMENTS ALREADY ENGAGED IN
IN RESPONSE THE DRY CONDITIONS
WE'RE EXPERIENCING ACROSS THE
STATE. DURING THE LAST DROUGHT
WOULD SPEND ROUGHLY FROM TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE THE TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN. THE
DEPARTMENT IS ACTIVELY INVOLVED
ON MANY FRONTS TO NOT ONLY
RESPOND TO THE CONDITIONS WE
EXPERIENCE BUT ALSO BEGIN.
BUILDING CAPACITY AND
RESILIENCY FOR THE FUTURE.
SHOULD BE FIND OURSELVES IN THE
STATE RIGHT NOW. AND I AGREED
SHERMAN. THAT IT'S UNFORTUNATE
THAT WE FIND OURSELVES AGAIN
HERE SO SOON. THROUGH THE
COURSE OF THE LAST DROUGHT THE
DEPARTMENT SPOTTED QUICKLY TO
REDIRECT STAFF TO BRING
TEMPORARY HELP TO THE TUNE OF
TWO HUNDRED STUFF OR WILDLIFE
AND FISHERIES FUNCTIONS. THIS
EXCEEDED APPROXIMATELY A
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND HOURS OF
STAFF TIME. THE WORK CONDUCTED
FOCUSED ON SEVERAL KEY AREAS
RELATED TO MONITORING. FISH
WILDLIFE RESCUES AND RELEASE
STRATEGIES WATER SYSTEM
IMPROVEMENTS FOR HIGH TREASON
WELL IF THERE IS. VOLUNTARY
DROUGHT AGREEMENTS TO AUGMENT
CHILL FLOWS AND CERTAIN
WATERWAYS. TEMPORARY FISHING
CLOSURES- AND IN THE DRESSING
HIMMATWALA CONFLICTS. TO GIVE
YOU A COUPLE EXAMPLES THE LAST
ROUTE WE DEPLOYED STAFF TO
MONITOR MANY OF OUR WATER WAYS
AND VOCAL SPECIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. THIS ALLOWED US TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND DROUGHT
RELATED THREATS TO THE SPECIES
AND HELP TO MAKE RESOURCE
MANAGEMENT DECISIONS. SOME OF
THIS INCLUDED PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT TO THE STATE
WATER PROJECT TO MONITOR KEY
LOCATIONS IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
TO HELP MINIMIZE DROUGHT
AFFECTS AND IMPLEMENT DELTA
SPECIFIC REGULATORY
FLEXIBILITY. SOME OF THESE
MONITORING OPERATIONS WERE
CONDUCTED TWENTY FOUR HOURS A
DAY SEVEN DAYS A WEEK DURING
HIGH MIGRATION BIRDS. THE
MARKET DEPARTMENT CONDUCTED
OVER NINE HUNDRED THIRTY FISH
RESCUES OF THIRTY EIGHT
DIFFERENT FISH SPECIES
EXCEEDING TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
THOUSAND FISH. WERE RICHARD LET
THE FISH RESPONSE ACTIONS SUCH
AS TRUCKING OVER FIFTY MILLION
SALMON SMALTZ THE DOWNSTREAM
REALLY STARTS. RATHER THAN
ALLOWING THEM TO MAKE THEIR WAY
DOWN THE CENTRAL VALLEY RIVERS.
HOPEFULLY IMPROVING THEIR
CHANCES OF SURVIVAL. ALL
TOTALED WE BROUGHT IN MORE THAN
THREE THOUSAND FISH IN THE
CAPTIVITY AND MORE THAN A
HUNDRED QUANTIC DEPENDENT
TRACHSEL ANIMALS. THAT WOULD
THEN CARE FOR ANGELA HOW TO
TOUCH RECOVERED IN THE ANIMALS
COULD BE RETURNED TO THE WILD.
WE IMPLEMENTED WATER USE
EFFICIENCY PROJECTS ARE
WILDLIFE AREAS ECOLOGICAL
RESERVES AND HATCHERIES. THE
HELP CONSERVE WATER IMPROVE
FUNCTION RESILIENCY AT THESE
FACILITIES. THIS INCLUDED
INSTALLATION OF. WATER
RECIRCULATION SYSTEMS CHILLERS.
FISH RESCUE UNITS UV SYSTEMS TO
KILL PATHOGENS. THE NEW TANKS
IN FISH TANKS TO REAR TROUT
STEELHEAD AND SALMON. UNDER
THESE OF NORMAL CONDITIONS
WE'RE EXPERIENCING. WE WORKED
QUICKLY WITH THE NATIONAL
RESEARCH. SERVICE WATER BOARD
AND LOCAL LANDOWNERS. IN THE
IRRIGATION DISTRICTS TO
NEGOTIATE VOTER DROUGHT
AGREEMENTS. THAT ENABLE US TO
MONITOR RESCUE FISH DEVELOP
FORBEARANCE AGREEMENTS AND
MODIFIED PROVISIONS OF ENTRY
FLOOR APARTMENTS TO STRIKE AN
APPROPRIATE BALANCE. BETWEEN
PEOPLE AND THE ENVIRONMENT. THE
DEPARTMENT WORKS THE FISHING
COMMISSION TO ADOPT REGULATE.
ALLOWING THE DEPARTMENT
TEMPORARILY CLOSE DROUGHT
AFFECTED DISTRICTS. WE ALSO
IMPLEMENTED A SUCCESSFUL HUMAN
WILDLIFE CONFLICT PROGRAM THAT
CONTINUES TODAY WE HAVE OVER
TWENTY THOUSAND HUMAN WILDLIFE
CONFLICT INCIDENTS REPORTED
BETWEEN. TWENTY FIFTEEN TO
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. WHAT WE
LEARNED WAS THAT IN SITUATIONS
LIKE THIS IT'S ALL HANDS ON
DECK AND THAT WE ALL NEED TO BE
ROWING IN THE SAME DIRECTION.
GIPSON MATTER. PEOPLE MATTER
THAT OUR PUBLIC TRUST RESOURCES
MATTER. AS THE L. A. REPORT
POINTS OUT THERE ARE SIMPLY NOT
ENOUGH CAPACITY FOR ONE AGENCY
OR DEPARTMENT. OR ONE GROUP TO
DO IT ALONE. THESE EFFORTS TAKE
A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
RESOURCES AND SUPPORT FROM ALL
LEVELS. WE ALSO LEARNED THAT
THERE WERE NOT THAT WE WERE NOT
AS PREPARED AS WE NEED TO BE
FOR WHAT SEEMS TO BE A
RECURRING THEME FOR STATE. WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO RESPOND AT A
MOMENT'S NOTICE WHILE ALSO
CONTINUING TO BUILD RESILIENCY
FOR LESSEN THE IMPACTS OF
DROUGHT. THE PROVIDE WATER FOR
US AND ARE YOU UNIQUE
BIODIVERSITY. SO THIS LEASE
WHICH IS TODAY SOME OF THE
ACTIONS THAT WERE PREPARED TO
TAKE AS WELL SOME OF THE THINGS
WE'RE ALREADY DOING. AS WE
SPEAK THE DEPARTMENT AGAIN
TRUCKING APPROXIMATE SEVENTEEN
MILLION FALL RUN CHINOOK
SALMON. BURKE CENTRAL VALLEY
SALMON HATCHERIES. TO BE
RELEASED IN THE SAN FRANCISCO
SAN PABLO BASED. TO THE POOR
FLOWING WATER QUALITY
CONDITIONS AND THE CENTRAL
VALLEY RIVERS AND ADULTS.
THROUGH OUR EFFORTS WITH THE
WATER BOARD WE'RE CONTINUING TO
BUILD OUR RELATIONSHIPS
DEVELOPED DURING THE LAST FROM.
WORKING WITH LANDOWNERS LOCAL
STATE FEDERAL AGENCIES TO
IDENTIFY OPPORTUNITIES FOR
VOLUNTARY DROUGHT AGREEMENTS.
MERGINGSEA CHECK PROGRAMS
DEVELOPMENT OF BEST MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES TO RESPOND TO
LOCALIZED AND REGIONAL DROUGHT
CONDITIONS. WE'RE PREPARED OF
SILK TO FACILITATE RAPID
IMPLEMENTATION OF DROUGHT
RELIEF MEASURES THE PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE COMMERCIAL
RECREATIONAL SALMON FISHING
ORGANIZATIONS THE FEDERAL
FISHING SEES. THE PARTNERSHIPS
WE'VE FORGED DURING THE LAST
ROW. WERE USING THE
TECHNOLOGIES AND EQUIPMENT
REQUIRED DURING THE LAST STRAW
SUCH AS THE STATE OF THE ART
TRAILERS THAT SHOULD ALLOW FOR
HIGHER SURVIVAL SURVIVAL RATES
OF OUR TRUCKS YOU WILL SOON.
UPGRADE WE MADE TO ENERGY
EFFICIENT WATER WELL PUMPS
USING SOLAR POWER ENABLING US
TO PROVIDE WATER TO DEPARTMENT
ODWALLA FOR IS AN ECOLOGICAL
RESERVES. THOSE WERE WISE
INVESTMENTS. THAT WE ARE
BENEFITING FROM NOW. WHAT
SPECIFICALLY IN THE RUSH RIVER
WHICH IS ARGUE LEASING SOME OF
THE MOST IMMEDIATE DROUGHT
AFFECTS. SINCE TWENTY FIFTEEN
THE DEPARTMENT HAS AWARDED TEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN PROP ONE
FOUR G. P. AND PROP SIXTY EIGHT
GRANT FUNDING TO THIRTY ONE
RESTORATION PROJECTS TO HELP
BUILD CRITICAL CRITICAL NEEDED
HABITAT. AND RELIEF FOR THOSE A
MEASURE MUSTACHE. LASTLY THE
DEPARTMENT IS POISED SHOULD WE
NEED TO GO THERE TO WORK WITH
THE FISHING IN COMMISSION TO
RAPIDLY RESPOND. TO AT RISK
FISHERIES VIA FISHING VOTERS.
WHEN WATER QUALITY AND FLOW
CONDITIONS ARE DEEMED TO POSE A
THREAT TO THE FISHERIES. THESE
MEASURES ARE INTENDED TO ENSURE
FISHERIES ARE PROTECTED OTHER
CRITICAL ENVIRONMENTAL
CONDITIONS. SO WITH THAT I WILL
USE MY TIME BACK TO THE PAY
WILL BE AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS
THANK YOU FROM ME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LOL ASCA. MEMBERS OF
OUR COMMITTEE. THE ONE
ADDRESSING QUESTIONS TO. ME THE
PALACE THE MOBILE THE SMOKERS.
WERE HEARD IN START OF ALWAYS
WANTED TO ASK THIS QUESTION AND
IT'LL BE OF. CHAD. FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE.
THE DELTA SMELT IS NOT NATIVE
TO THE DELTA. ESTUARY SEKARANG.
IF DELTA SMELT IS NOT DATA TO
THE ASSURE. I'M NOT SURE I'M
FOLLOWING YOUR QUESTION AUGUST
OKAY THE DELTA IS MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THE DELTA
SMELT IS NOT NATIVE TO THE
DELTA. AREA THERE AND SAID THAT
THE WHOLE AREA IS IT TRUE THAT
THE DELTA SMELT IS NOT NATIVE
TO THAT AREA. I WOULD HAVE TO
CONSULT WITH OUR FOLKS NOT SURE
IF I FULLY UNDERSTAND. THAT THE
STATE'S POPULATION THAT WE HAVE
ADULTS IS NOT THAT THEY DON'T.
BY DELTA. BECAUSE I DID A TOUR
WENT WHEN I WAS ON A WATER
BOARD ABOUT FOUR YEARS AGO. IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE IS RAISING THE DELTA
SMELT. AND PUTTING IT IN THE
DELTA I UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE TO
FEED THE OTHER FISH BUT IT IS
NOT NATIVE WHY ARE WE RAISING
IT TO FISH FEED THE OTHER FISH
IN THE DELTA. WHICH CREATES A
PROBLEM FOR PUMPING OUT THE
DELTA TO GO TO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. BUT IF YOU CAN
ANSWER THE QUESTION OF THE
DELTA SMELT IS NOT NATIVE.
WE'RE ALREADY AT THE END HERE.
CAN ANYONE ANYONE ELSE CENTER
ON THE PANEL IF THE DELTA SMELT
IS NATIVE. TO THE DELTA. OKAY
THEY WILL GO THAT CAN HELP THE
SIMILAR. THE DELTA SMELT IS
NATIVE TO THE DELTA. IT ISN'T
NATIVE TO THE DELTA WHO SAID
THAT. SORRY THIS IS OUT. SO
DOES NOT IS A NATIVE SPECIES TO
THIS DOCTOR I'M NOT SURE IF I
UNDERSTOOD SORRY I APOLOGIZE
FULLY WERE UNDERSTANDING THAT
DOCTOR SMITH RELATES TO THE
WESTERN COAST OR PERHAPS THE
DARKEST OF THE NATIVE SPECIES
TO I'VE ALWAYS BEEN UNDER THE
IMPRESSION THAT IT WAS NOT
NATIVE. TO THE DELTA SO I'LL
CHECK ON THAT PART ANYWAY. IN
THIS IS FOR. ANYONE MAYBE EVEN
SEND THAT JOHN'S. THE IN A IN
REGARDS TO THE PROP ONE FUNDS
THAT CALIFORNIA VOTERS AND
VOTED IN IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN. DO INCLUDED TWO POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS FOR NEW
WATER STORAGE. HOW MUCH OF THAT
MONEY HAS BEEN SPENT ON STORAGE
SINCE THEN. I'D HAVE TO SAY I
DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO THAT
QUESTION BUT WE CAN CERTAINLY
LOOK IT UP AND GET BACK TO YOU
OKAY AND THEN A FOLLOW UP ON
THAT IS EIGHT HUNDRED TEN
MILLION DOLLARS WERE FOR
REGIONAL WATER PROJECTS DO YOU
HAVE A LIST OF THE WATER
PROJECTS AND HOW MUCH OF THAT
MONEY HAS BEEN SPENT. WE CAN
CERTAINLY- COME UP WITH THAT
PROVIDE FOR YOU. OKAY AND HOW
MUCH OF THAT OF MONEY IS BEEN
SPELT SPENT AND PROJECTS TO
HELP US IN THE DROUGHT THAT
WERE IN CURRENTLY BECAUSE WE GO
ALL THERE'S BEEN A DROUGHT IN
CALIFORNIA FOR ALWAYS FOR THE
LAST HUNDRED FIFTY YEARS. BUT I
WAS WONDERING HOW MUCH MONEY
HAS BEEN SPENT IN WATER STORAGE.
AND HOW MUCH CAPACITY
ADDITIONAL CAPACITY IS
AVAILABLE BECAUSE THE RESULT OF
ANY OF THESE PROJECTS IN THE
MONEY SPENT. WE WILL GET A
RESPONSE TO ON THAT. I GET A
FOLLOW UP FOR THAT MY BIG KEY
FOR HERE HAS BEEN ON THIS
COMMITTEE AS WE'VE BEEN IN A
DROUGHT. FOR LET'S JUST SAY
OFTEN OVER THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS WE ALWAYS HAVE A DROP
CALIFORNIA WHY HAVE WE NOT USED
OUR RESOURCES FOR WATER STORAGE.
THE SIGN SITES RESERVOIR
PROJECT. I DO BELIEVE FIFTY TWO
YEARS AGO IT STARTED THAT
PROJECT. I'D LIKE TO KNOW HOW
MANY LAWSUITS HAVE BEEN FILED
THEY MIGHT ENVIRONMENTAL
COLLEAGUES TO STOP THEIR
PROJECT. OVER ALL THESE YEARS
AND HOW MUCH MONEY HAS BEEN
SPENT LITIGATING THESE LAWSUITS.
ANOTHER ONE IS THE TEMPERS
FLATS DAMS IS SOUTH OF THE
DELTA. HOW MANY LAWSUITS HAVE
BEEN FILED AGAINST THAT PROJECT
WITH MY ENVIRONMENTAL
COLLEAGUES TO STOP THAT PROJECT.
AND I'M GONNA GO AHEAD AND
TOUCH A NERVE I'M FEELING GOOD
RIGHT NOW. CAN THE GOVERNOR
SIGNED AN EXECUTIVE ORDER. WAVE
ALL THESE ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES
THAT COME UP IN BUILD RESERVOIR
IN CALIFORNIA FOR WATER STORAGE
WE HAVE A WET YEAR THE WAY
WE'RE GONNA GET THROUGH THESE
CAN'T CONTINUE TO LET IT RUN
OUT INTO THE OCEAN IF WE STORED
THAT WATER WE WOULD HAVE IT
WHEN WE HAVE A DRY YEAR. SO I
COULD TAKE JUST A FIRST STEP TO
ANSWERING THAT QUESTION AND
THAT WOULD BE- AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER FROM THE GOVERNOR SIMPLY
DIRECTS STATE AGENCIES. TO TAKE
SPECIFIED ACTIONS TO ACTUALLY
WAVE STATE LAWS AND REGULATIONS
WOULD REQUIRE AN EMERGENCY
PROCLAMATION AND THE STATE
EMERGENCY PROCLAMATION COULD
NOT WAIVE FEDERAL LAWS OR
REGULATIONS. OKAY. BUT I MUST
TO TOUCH ANOTHER NERVE CAN YOU
TELL ME WELL IT'S GONNA BE HARD
TO CLICK QUANTIFY WHEN THE
DELTA SMELT WAS NATIVE. BECAUSE
WHEN I WOULD DID MY TOUR OF THE
DELTA THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE WAS RAISING THE
DELTA SMELT. SO I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU CAN TELL ME NINETEEN THIRTY
OR NINETEEN FIFTY THE DELTA
SMELT. WAS FOUND IN THE DELTA
OR WHEN IT WAS SO VERY. I CAN
TELL YOU THAT THE DELTA SMELT
IT IS ENDEMIC TO CALIFORNIA SO
IT MEANS MEANING IT ONLY LIVES
IN THE DELTA INSIGHTS NAME THE
DOG THE SELL IT WAS LISTED
UNDER C. SIR IN NINETEEN NINETY
THREE I CAN'T I CAN'T GIVE YOU
THAT SO I CAN LOOK BACK TO
DETERMINE WHEN WE FIRST
DISCOVERED ADULT THE SMOKE I
DON'T KNOW THAT NUMBER OFF HAND
BUT THEY'RE ENDEMIC MEANING
THEY ONLY THEY ONLY LIVE IN ARE
FOUND WITHIN THE DELTA. THANK
YOU. SMITH ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
ABOUT MR. SO I HAVE A GRAPHING
FOR ME FROM THE- WATER
COMMISSION'S WEBSITE SHOWING
COMPLETION OF THESE PROJECTS
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT FOR
THAT WATER STORAGE OF TWENTY
THIRTY SO TODAY WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT WHAT WE'VE LEARNED FROM
PAST TROUT. AND HOW WE CAN DO
BETTER AND WHAT WE SHOULD BE
DOING BETTER TO PREPARE IN THE
FUTURE WHATEVER FOR FUTURE
WATER STORAGE IS. ALREADY FROM
PROP ONE FUNDS IS NOT GONNA BE
COMPLETED IN TWENTY THIRTY.
WHAT CAN THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY
RIGHT NOW DUE TO STREAMLINED.
TO BRING THAT UP MUCH SOONER
MAYES TWENTY TWENTY ONE. SB
NINE YEARS FROM NOW BEFORE WE
HAVE THE FIRST SET OF MONIES
FROM PROP ONE TO COMPLETED
STORAGE. SO I REALLY THINK WE
NEED TO. BE THINKING ABOUT AND
CONSIDERING AS A BODY WHAT WE
CAN DO TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
IMMEDIATELY NOT AND NINE YEARS
FROM NOW. SO CAN YOU IS THERE
ANYTHING FROM THE DEED IF YOU
ARE THAT. FOR YOU TO. EX
EXPEDITE THESE PROJECTS TO
COMPLETION THAT WE COULD BE
DOING TO HELP YOU. SO I THINK-
ONE THING I SHOULD POINT OUT
WAS THAT BOND MONEY WAS
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE- PUBLIC
BENEFITS SHARE THAT THE STATE
WAS PROVIDING SELL THOSE
PROJECTS REQUIRED ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS BY THE LOCAL PARK-
SPONSORS. AND AS WE HAVE SEEN
FOR EXAMPLE IN THE CASE OF
TEMPERANCE FLYING OUT THE LOCAL
SPONSORS FOR- UNABLE TO FIND
ADDITIONAL FUNDING SOURCES AND
I THINK THAT'S ALSO A CHALLENGE
HAS BEEN A CHALLENGE FOR THE
SITES RESERVOIR PROJECT AS WELL
BECAUSE THE STATE INVESTMENT
WAS ONLY INTENDED TO BE FOR A
SHARE OF THE PROJECT. THANK YOU
IN. TO OUT TO THE PALACE WHO
WERE ASKED QUESTIONS- FROM OUR
COLLEAGUES JUST MADE THE WOULD
LOVE TO GET SOME RESPONSES IN A
TIMELY MANNER TO SOME OF THOSE
QUESTIONS THAT I THINK OF
INTEREST TO MANY OTHER MEMBERS
IN THE COMMITTEE SO THANK YOU-
SOME MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA.
BUT YES THANK YOU MY QUESTION
IS FOR. THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD I THINK
AS DARREN WHO SPOKE. TO US
ABOUT PEOPLE US. ON AND SO
WONDERING IF WE HAVE SOME SORT
OF INVENTORY OF. HOW BIG THE
PROBLEM IS HOW MANY WALLS ARE
BEING TURNED OFF AND- THE COST
TO. REMEDIATE ARE THOSE LAWS
WILL TO BRING IT BACK IN.
ABILIFY GLAD SOME- YEAH WE
HAVEN'T AND WE HAVE SOME
ADDITIONAL WORK WERE STILL AND
WE'RE STILL UNDER INVESTIGATION
WE DO ON OUR STATE BOARD
WEBSITE HAVE A FAST PACED I'M
HAPPY TO SEND A LINK TO THE
COMMITTEE THAT MAPS ALL OF THE-
DETECTIONS THAT WE HAVE AT THE
DIFFERENT LEVELS THAT WERE
DETECTED OUT OF THE LOCATION OF
THOSE WELLS FOR. FULL
INFORMATION- BUT HONESTLY WE
HAVEN'T EXPLORED THE FULL EDGE
OF THE CONTAMINATION SO WE'RE
STILL TRYING TO DELINEATE SOME
OF THE BOUNDARIES OF THE PLUMES
ASSOCIATED WITH IT WE JUST A
COUPLE MONTHS AGO ISSUED A
ANOTHER ORDER KIND OF OUR
BIGGEST HOLE AS IT COMES TO
UNDERSTANDING P. BASS AND THAT
IS FOR PUBLIC WATER SYSTEM
WELLS THAT ARE NEAR AND AROUND
A DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE SITES
BOTH ACTIVE AND FORMER AND WE
WILL START GETTING DATA FROM
THEM IN JULY AND AUGUST. AND
THEN ALL OF CAN DO QUARTERLY
MONITORING LIKE THE OTHER
ORDERS WITH ISSUED AROUND THAT-
I CAN'T SAY THAT THERE'S BEEN
BUT THE MOST IMPACT HAS BEEN
IN- SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IN
ORANGE COUNTY AREA- CORONA YOUR
BRAIN- THE END OF SEVERAL OF
THE COMMUNITIES IN ORANGE
COUNTY WATER DISTRICT AREA SAW
EXTENSIVE NUMBERS OF WELLS THAT
WERE IMPACTED I BELIEVE MOST OF
THOSE COMMUNITIES SWITCHED TO
SURFACE WATER FROM METROPOLITAN
WATER DISTRICT TEMPORARILY AND
ARE ACTIVELY WORKING WITH
PROJECTS TO TRY TO BRING
TREATMENT ON TO THEM AND GET
THEM. BACK IN PLACE OF SANTA
CLARITA ALSO LIKE FIVE OR SIX
WELLS IMPACTED SO THERE'S A
BEGINNING OF IT I DON'T HAVE
OBVIOUSLY A FINAL NUMBER AND
WE'RE STILL IN THE
IVESTIGATION MODE TO CONTINUE
THAT BUT WERE. HAPPY TO SHARE
WHAT WE KNOW AT THIS POINT.
YEAH I AS WE ARE GOING INTO
DROUGHT THE SWELLS ARE BEING.
SHUT OFF AND WE'VE BEEN WORKING
HARD AS OF THE CALIFORNIA TO BE
MUCH MUCH MORE SUSTAINABLE AND
RELATE RELY LESS ON THAT
IMPORTED WATER- BUT I HAVE A
NUMBER OF COMMUNITIES WHO HAVE
TURNED OFF. WELLS AND ARE
IMPORTING WATER AND CAN'T
AFFORD THE INFRASTRUCTURE COST-
TO FOR THAT FOR THE CLEAN UP OF
THAT PEOPLE'S ON AND IN MY
COMMUNITY STILL. REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE RATE PAYERS
PAYING FOR THAT REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE INCREASE IN
WATER RATES WITH THE IMPORTED
WATER- AND JST THE DROUGHT
SITUATION THOUGH AND SO I JUST
APPRECIATE THE- THAT YOU
BROUGHT THAT. FOR TODAY AND I
WOULD APPRECIATE THAT THIS
OPERATION AND WE HAVE AN
INVENTORY OF HOW MANY WALLS ARE
CURRENTLY OUT. OF USE BECAUSE A
FEW PEOPLE OFF. YEAH THE CHECK
AS WE GET MORE DATA ALL THE
TIME BUT IT'S ON THE ORDER. OF
OVER. AND OVER- TWO HUNDRED
WELLS WE NOW HAVE IMPACTS IN
THE STATE THAT ARE ABOVE OUR
NOTIFICATION LEVELS AND- THIS
GRAPHICS ON THE WEB PAGE THAT
KEEP THAT UPDATED CURRENTLY SO
WE'LL DEFINITELY GET THAT TO
YOU. AND YES IT'S A BIG CONCERN
WE KNOW IT'S- DOUBLY IMPACTFUL
IT IT'S INCREASING RATES AND-
IT IS A CONTAMINATION ISSUE
THAT. THE WATER SYSTEMS ARE
WORKING THROUGH. SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
MISTER BENNETT. THANK YOU I
HAVE BOB- THREE COMMENT MORE
THAN QUESTIONS OR REQUESTS FOR
LONG TERM- ITEMS THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE- THE WATERS OURS
IN THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
AGENCY SAID TO LOOK AT AND ONE
IS. IN TWO DIFFERENT PLACES
HERE- ON OUR ADAPTIONS TO THE
LAST DROUGHT WE MAKE REFERENCE
TO- THE GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY AGENCIES THAT
HAVE BEEN CREATED AND I JUST
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT. THEY
HAVE TWENTY YEARS TO. REACH
SUSTAINABILITY AND VERY FEW OF
THEM ARE MAKING ANY-
SIGNIFICANT CUTS- THIS EARLY
THEY'RE JUST GETTING THEIR
PLANS TOGETHER AND ALMOST ALL
OF THEM ARE GOING TO HAVE PLANS
TO CALL FOR A VERY SLOW RAMP
DOWNS SO WE SHOULDN'T- WE
SHOULDN'T EXPECT MUCH IN THE IN
TERMS OF THE SHORT RUN- HELP TO
COME FROM. GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY PLANS THAT HAVE
A TWENTY YEAR CYCLE BEFORE THEY
YEAH- ARE SUPPOSED TO HAVE
REACHED A SUSTAINABILITY IF
THEY'RE IF THEY'RE ABLE TO EVEN
DO THAT IN TWENTY YEARS. THE
SECOND THING IS- IT SEEMS THAT
WE HAVE A LACK OF DATA A BALLOT
WELLS- AND IT WOULD SEEM THAT.
ONE THING I'D LIKE TO
ADMINISTRATION TO CONSIDER- AND
POTENTIALLY THE LEGISLATURE TO
SUPPORT IS FUNDING FOR
MONITORING WELLS THAT WOULD
GIVE THE STATE- FASTER
INFORMATION ABOUT POTENTIALLY
HIGH RISK AREAS AREAS NEAR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES LIKE
CENTER SO THE STATE COULD GET
RAPID. INFORMATION AND WE JUST
HAVE LOTS OF AREAS WHERE WE
JUST DON'T HAVE A GOOD
MONITORING WELLS- THE END SO
THAT THAT. WOULD BE THE SECOND
AND THEN THE FINAL THING IS. WE
SHOULD BE. ARE FOR A STEADY AND
MORE SEVERE DROUGHT CYCLES TO
COME AND IF WE'RE GOING TO DO
THAT I THINK WE HAVE TO BECOME
MUCH MORE AGGRESSIVE- ABOUT
WHAT WE DO AND I APPRECIATE OF
MY COLLEAGUES HERE OF TALK
ABOUT STORAGE- I WOULD SUGGEST
THAT- THE RECYCLING OF WATER-
IS. A VERY RIGHT- AREA AND IT
PARTICULARLY IS RIGHT FOR
MUNICIPAL GOVERNMENTS- AND I
THINK WE SHOULD HAVE A
STATEWIDE PLAN- THAT WOULD
ENCOURAGE AND BOTH THE SCIENCE
OF THE TECHNOLOGY FOR. THE
RECYCLING OF WATER TO
DRAMATICALLY DECREASE A
MUNICIPAL- AGENCIES RELIANCE ON
BOTH IMPORTED WATER AND WATER
THAT COMES FROM- GROUNDWATER
SUPPLIES- TO THE WE GET MUCH
MORE BANG OUT OF THE WATER-
THAT WE DO- SPEND AN ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF MONEY TO TRY TO GET
INTO OURMUNICIPAL SYSTEMS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
MISTER BENNETT WOULD YOU ANY
THE PALACE LIKE TO COMMENT ON
ANY OF OUR COLLEAGUES.
PERSPECTIVES THAT HE'S A SHARK.
OKAY THIS IS RACHEL EHLERS FROM
LA- JUST ONE COMMENT- IN
RESPONSE TO THAT AND IF AND
ALSO TO THE COMMENT OF THE VICE
CHAIR JUST- WHEN WE THINK ABOUT
STORAGE IT'S NOT JUST ABOVE
GROUND STORAGE IT'S
HISTORICALLY KIND OF HOW WE
THOUGHT ABOUT WATER STORAGE BUT
IT JUST ENCOURAGING THAT
COMMITTEE TO ALSO CONSIDER
BELOW GROUND STORAGE- AS AS
POTENTIALLY PROJECTS THAT COULD
MOVE FASTER THEIR DAIRY MAYBE
SMALLER- SO THINKING ABOUT
GROUNDWATER RECHARGE CAPTURING
FLOOD WATERS- STORM WATER
CAPTURE. THINK AS MISTER
BENNETT JUST NOTED HOW CAN WE
BE AGGRESSIVE AND THINK I THINK
MORE CREATIVELY SO REALLY
EXPANDING WHEN WE THINK ABOUT
WATER STORAGE- AND RESOURCES-
THAT THAT'S PROBABLY KIND OF
THE NEXT FRONTIER THAT WE
SHOULD REALLY BE THINKING ABOUT
CRIME MORE SERIOUSLY SO JUST
MAKING SURE THAT THAT'S PART OF
THE PORTFOLIO YOU'RE
CONSIDERING. THANK YOU  GOTHAM
QUEBEC FOR OUR PRESENTERS IN
ABOUT TWO. IT'S IN THE KIND OF
ARENA OF- RESOURCES THAT WAS
MENTIONED BY THE ALLEY- IN. HER
PRESENTATION THREE POINT FOUR
BILLION TO RESPOND TO THE LAST
DROP. 7% OF THOSE FUNDS COMING
FROM VOTER APPROVED BONDS- AS
WE GO INTO THIS DROUGHT- HOW DO
YOU FEEL ABOUT THE FUNDS THAT
ARE AVAILABLE- TO RESPOND TO
THE EARLY. SIGNS THAT WE'RE
SEEING AND WHETHER OR NOT WE-
ARE IN A POSITION. TO ADDRESS
WHAT WE CAN FORECAST WOULD- THE
DROUGHT DECLARATION THAT'S
TAKEN PLACE IN TWO COUNTIES
AND- AND POSSIBLY ADDITIONAL
COUNTIES BEING ADDED TO THE
LIST. BOB THE OTHER COMMENT
WOULD BE- AND HOW DO YOU FEEL
YOU ALL GET TO- DEPLOY AND
IMPLEMENT- THESE- POLICIES
REGULATIONS OR FOR THAT MATTER.
OVERSEE THESE INVESTMENTS ON
HARD INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS.
WHEN YOU SEE US MOVING THE
NEEDLE ON- YOU KNOW PER
PREPARING AND- ADDRESSING KIND
OF THE CURRENT NEED AT THE
MOMENT. AND AND LASTLY I'M
CURIOUS TO KNOW IF- YOU ALL
YOUR AGENCIES. ARE WEIGHING IN
AS THE MAY REVISED BUDGET IS
BEING PUT TOGETHER- AND WHAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR AND I SEE WE
YOU US- FOR PURPOSES OF ONE
TIME INVESTMENT WITH. THE
SURPLUSES THAT WERE SEEN HERE
IN THE STATE OR- A LINING- WITH
THE FUNDS THAT ARE COMING FROM.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- TO-
TACKLE THE INITIAL PHASE OF
THIS TRIAL TO AVOID ANOTHER SEC
THREE QUESTIONS I WANT. ANY OF
THE PANELISTS- CAN. TRY TO.
ADDRESS THAT PLEASE. WELL ON
ALL TAKE A US THAT I THINK-
VISITORS MADE A- POINT IN HER.
OPENING REMARKS ABOUT THE
DISTINCTION BETWEEN SHORT TERM
DROUGHT RESPONSE PROJECT AND
THE LARGE WATER INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS THAT TAKE LONGER TO
PUT INTO PLACE THE NATURE OF
THOSE LARGE PROJECTS IS SUCH
THAT. IT YOU KNOW THEY CAN BE
ON A- FOUR YEAR FIVE YEAR TEN
YEAR PLANNING HORIZON-
HOPEFULLY MUCH LONGER THAN THE-
SPAN OF OUR NEXT DROUGHT. YET
THEY ARE VERY IMPORTANT IN THE
LONG TERM BECAUSE WE EXPECT
CALIFORNIA TO BE FACING A
FUTURE IN WHICH WE SEE THE
EFFECTS OF A WARMING CLIMATE
AND CONSEQUENTLY- A GREATER
RISK OF WATER SCARCITY. SO
YOU'RE TURNING TO THE THINGS
THAT CAN BE DONE IN THE SHORT
TERM THE NEAR TERM. THE
CERTAINLY- OF MUCH OF THAT IS
THE DATA AND FORECASTING AREA
AND YOU KNOW WE HAVE SOME IDEAS
OF WHAT CAN BE IMPROVED THERE
AND ALSO IN THE NEAR TERM
ASSISTANCE TO US SMALL WATER
SYSTEMS. THAT DOES TEND TO
STRUGGLE DURING DROUGHT THE-
SAFER PROGRAM THAT THE LEDGER
LEGISLATURE AUTHORIZED A COUPLE
OF YEARS AGO IS A GREAT STEP
FORWARD IN THAT REGARD- AS ARE
SOME OF THE- RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR. TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
OTHER DIRECT ASSISTANCE THAT WE
HAVE IN OUR REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON THE DROUGHT
VULNERABILITY OF SMALL HANDOUT
RURAL COMMUNITIES. SO I THINK
WE CERTAINLY HAVE SOME PASSED
FORWARD TO BE GOING DOWN AND IN
OF THE RISK OF DROUGHT IS NOT
GOING TO GO AWAY IF ANYTHING WE
WOULD EXPECT- PROBABLY. A
WORSENING IN THE LONG TERM
FUTURE. ANYONE ELSE LIKE TO THE
TAKE A STAB AT THE- THE
QUESTIONS. SURE I CAN READ IN
THE SIGNATURE DOUBLE THE PARK
THIS WHILE I'VE- YOU KNOW AS I
MENTIONED WE ARE WE'RE ACTIVELY
ENGAGED IN IN STARTING
CONVERSATIONS WE DEVELOP WITCHY
RETURN EARLY TO START. TALKING
ABOUT IT AND REGULARLY
COMMUNICATING ON ISSUES WE'RE
SEEING ACROSS THE STATE WE'VE
FAR START SOME CONVERSATIONS IN
THE RUSSIAN- WE'RE WORKING WITH
THE WATER BOARD ANOTHER SHOULD
BE CHANGED TO BEGIN
CONVERSATIONS ARE SORT OF LAST
TIME TO START LOOKING AT.
PARTNERSHIPS WE CAN CREATE
ABOUT HOW IN TRYING TO ENSURE
FLOWS CAN BE MODIFIED OR OR
JUST TO INSURE PROTECTION THE
SPECIES WERE MONITORING SOME
STRINGS ALREADY FOR- FISH
STRANDING- DUE. TO LOW FLOW
CONDITIONS. RIGHT ON THE
HATCHERY AS WE TALKED ABOUT IT
THE TRUCK BECAUSE FISH SO. WE
ARE ACTIVELY. I WOULD NEVER SAY
WERE TOTALLY PREPARED BECAUSE
WE NEVER KNOW REALLY WHERE
WE'RE GOING. BUT WE'RE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN BASED ON WHAT
WE LEARN- IN THE RECENT PAST TO
PREPARE OURSELVES FOR WHAT'S
AHEAD OF US AND TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN RESPOND TO THAT WE
ARE RESPONDING. AND WORKING
WITH ALL THE PARTIES AND WE
NEED TO AS WE CONTINUE TO LEARN
MORE MORE ABOUT SO HOW DARBY
MAY OR MAY NOT BE MOVING INTO
THE NEXT COUPLE MONTHS OF
POTENTIALLY THE NEXT YEAR.
MISTER CHAIR AYE AYE DODD- YOUR
QUESTIONS AS WELL FOCUSING ON.
DRINKING WATER ASPECTS. THAT I
DO FEEL LIKE WE'RE MOVING THE
NEEDLE THE- GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE DID PASS THE SAVE A
FORMAL DRINKING WATER ACT AND
BROUGHT. ON OUR SUPER PROGRAM
AS MICELLAR MENTIONED- THERE'S
A LOT OF WORK REALLY STARTING
UP THERE. THE SMALLER WATER
SYSTEMS ARE THE ONE THAT ARE
IMPACTED AS MICELLAR MENTION AS
WELL. AND WE'RE REALLY WORKING
HARD TO TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE- ADDRESS THAT. A LOT OF THAT
WILL BE COMBINING WATER SYSTEMS
OF THE- THE AGE OF A SMALL
INDEPENDENT LITTLE WATER SYSTEM
WITH ONE WHILE SURVIVING THE
DROUGHT. IS PROBABLY A THING OF
THE PAST AND HOW WE HARDEN THEM
AND PREPARE THOSE COMMUNITIES
FOR. THEIR FUTURE IS- IMPORTANT
WE'RE WORKING REALLY HARD IN
THAT AREA- TO MOVE THAT
FORWARD. IT DID REALLY GET
ASKED ALL THROUGHOUT AS WELL
OUR DEPARTMENT AND MY GROUP IS
WORKING ON DIRECT POTABLE REUSE
FOR RECYCLED WATER REGULATIONS.
THAT'LL BE NEW IN CALIFORNIA
AND SEVERAL OF OUR LARGE WATER
AGENCIES IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AND EVENTUALLY
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WILL
CONSIDER. HOW TO BRING THAT
ONLINE AND FURTHER TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF- RECYCLING IN THE
STATE. IN THE LAST DROUGHT
THERE WAS- EIGHT HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS AT THE BOARD
OFFERED AT A 1% LOAN INTEREST
RATE THAT WAS SNAPPED UP AND-
ALL THOSE PROJECTS ARE NOT
COMPLETED IN CONTRIBUTING. TO
THE WATER SUPPLY IN CALIFORNIA
SO WE CONTINUE TO MAKE PROGRESS
BUT- HISTORICALLY THE
INVESTMENT IN WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE. HAS BEEN
UNDERFUNDED NATIONALLY AND IN
CALIFORNIA'S NO DIFFERENT. IN
THAT REGARD AND THERE'S MUCH
MORE WORK TO DO. I THANK YOU.
I'VE GOT THAT TO MARK. ONE IN
THE AREA OF THE WATER
RESTRICTIONS AT THAT SOME POINT
ANOTHER. ARE BROUGHT UP UPON
YOU KNOW OUR WATER AGENCIES ARE
CITIES- AG INDUSTRY. CURIOUS TO
KNOW- IF WE ARE PREPARED- AS IT
COMES TO- IMPOSING THESE
RESTRICTIONS- REQUIRED
PERMITTING WATER CHANGES A- NEW
WATER RIGHT KIND OF
RECONFIGURATION. TO DO- JUST
THAT IT'S A LONG PROCESS- ARE
WE DOING ANYTHING WITHIN THE
AGENCIES THAT CAN HELP US MOVE
IT IN A MUCH MORE EXPEDITIOUS
MANNER- TO TRY TO COMPLY WITH
THOSE- WATER RESTRICTIONS THAT
WE BEGIN TO. IMPOSE ACROSS THE
BOARD ON INDUSTRIES-
MUNICIPALITIES AND OTHER.
ENTITIES IS THERE SOMETHING
THAT WE'RE ALREADY LOOKING AT A
TO HELP US- POSITION OURSELVES
TO BE MORE EFFICIENT AT WHEN IT
COMES TO THOSE RESTRICTIONS.
THIS IS- ERICA DOG JUMPED IN
IN- MAYBE OTHERS CAN JOIN AS
WELL- OF CERTAINTY FROM THE
WATER RIGHTS PERSPECTIVE AND-
REFERENCE THAT- CURTAILMENTS
THAT WE DID BACK IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN AND TWENTY FIFTEEN. WE
DID HAVE A NUMBER OF CHALLENGES
IN IMPLEMENTING THOSE.
CURTAILMENTS AT THAT TIME- IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN IN PARTICULAR-
UP UNTIL THAT POINT THE WATER
RATES YOU STATE OR DEMAND DATA
WAS ONLYREPORTED EVERY THREE
YEARS. AND SO IT WAS HARD TO
GET AN ASSESSMENT OF KIND OF
WHAT. WAS A REAL TIME DATA WAS.
LOOKING LIKE THERE WERE
LEGISLATIVE CHANGES IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN THAT REQUIRE PEOPLE TO
REPORT THEIR WATER USE EVERY
YEAR AND THAT HAS SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPROVED- HOW OFTEN WE GET THAT
DATA BUT EVEN STILL THE TIME
WHEN SUPPORT AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER ABOUT ONCE EVERY
EIGHTEEN. MONTHS IN SOME
CIRCUMSTANCES AND SO THAT'S
GOING TO LEAD TO THE ON GOING
CHALLENGES JUST MAKING SURE WE
HAVE ACCURATE UP TO DATE DATA.
BUT GIVEN THE IDEA THAT WE DO
HAVE WE ARE DOING EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO COORDINATE IT AND TO
MAKE SURE THAT. THAT DATA IS
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC AND SO
JUST IN THE LAST COUPLE OF
WEEKS THE DIVISION RELEASED A
SUPPLY DEMAND VISUALIZATION
TOOL WHERE YOU CAN ACTUALLY GO
ONLINE AND SEE- CAMP WITHIN A
CERTAIN WATERSHED THAT DEMAND
BASED ON. WHO'S REPORTED WHAT
WATER USE IN THE PAST AND
PROJECTED SUPPLY BASED ON SOME
INFORMATION FROM OUR SISTER
AGENCIES AND THAT'S A
SIGNIFICANT STEP FORWARD. THE
PURPOSE OF THAT IS TO PROVIDE
SOME OF THAT INFORMATION
EARLIER AND MORE OFTEN SO THAT
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND WHEN WE ARE
DRY CONDITION WHAT DO YOU
SUPPLY DEMAND CONDITIONS LOOK
LIKE IN ARE WE HEADING TOWARDS
A POTENTIAL- NEED FOR
CURTAILMENT SCORER NOTICES THAT
THERE ISN'T SUFFICIENT. SUPPLY
RELATIVE TO DEMAND- THERE WAS
ALSO I THINK- I'D IT TO ENSURE
THE QUESTIONS REFER TO SOME OF
THE- BEEN WATER CONSERVATION
REQUIREMENTS THAT WERE IN PLACE
THROUGH TWENTY SIXTEEN- IN.
SINCE THAT TIME THERE WAS
LEGISLATION PASSED THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION AS A
WAY OF LIFE LEGISLATION. THAT
CAN REFOCUS IS THE- PROCS
INSTEAD OF LOOKING AT MANDATORY
CUTBACKS WITHIN THE FOUR
HUNDRED LARGEST URBAN WATER
AGENCIES- THE INNOVATIVE CAN'T
MANDATORY CONSERVATION
REQUIREMENTS INSTEAD WE'RE
PIVOTING TOWARDS EFFICIENCY AND
INCORPORATING. THE UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCE AND KIND OF THE
MICROCLIMATES ALL ACROSS
CALIFORNIA SO THAT THE WATER
USE WITHIN ANY PARTICULAR AREA.
IT REALLY REFLECTS WHAT THE
GEOGRAPHY IS LIKE WHAT THE
CLIMATE IS LIKE AND THAT
LEGISLATION IS IN ITS PROCESS
OF KIND OF WORKING ITS WAY
THROUGH THE- THE IMPLEMENTATION
STEPS THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES. IS CONDUCTING SOME
TECHNICAL ANALYSIS NOW AND IT
WILL REFER THAT INFORMATION TO
THE STATE WATER BOARD I THINK
THE NEXT YEAR OR TWO AT WHICH
POINT THE BOARD WILL LOOK AT
THAT INFORMATION AND ADOPT
REGULATIONS TO A KIND OF
PERMANENTLY IN TRYING SOME OF
THESE EFFICIENCY REQUIREMENTS
STATEWIDE. SO AGAIN THERE WE'VE
LEARNED I THINK A TREMENDOUS
ABOUT SINCE LAST DROUGHT AND
ARE BETTER POSITIONED MOVING
FORWARD. FIVE I THINK I'LL
LEAVE IT THERE AND ENTERED A TO
MICHAEL. OKAY THANK YOU ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS FOLLOW UP
COMMENTS BY THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU GET- PAL
NUMBER TWO WE WILL BE FOLLOWING
UP WITH YOU AS IT RELATES TO
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS THAT
WENT. UNANSWERED AND- TRY TO
GET THOSE- QUESTIONS RESPONDED
TO IN A TIMELY MANNER THANK YOU
AND I HOPE THAT YOU WILL STICK
AROUND. AS WE HAVE OUR THIRD
PANEL THAT WILL BE SPEAKING AND
PERHAPS ANY QUESTIONS THAT MAY
ARISE AT THE BACK TO YOU ALL
THANK YOU AGAIN THEIR PANEL IS-
HOW DROUGHT IMPACTS REGION'S
DIFFERENTLY WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
SPEAKERS HERE'S WELL DAVID
ROBINSON- MY- COUNTY SUPERVISOR
AS ANIMAL WATER. DIRECTORS
SASSANID THEN THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AND CO FOUNDER OF
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER THAT
WILL BE SENIOR ATTORNEY WATER
PROGRAM NOT TO RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL JOE DEL BOSQUE
IT DOUBLES GIVE FARMS CENTER
CURLED GENERAL MANAGER. THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY WATER AUTHORITY
IF- FIRST PRESENTERS. READING
PLEASE- PLEASE PROCEED. RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AT CHARTER
C. N. THANK YOU COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR ALLOWING ME. ON THE
COUNTY SUPERVISOR AND AS SUCH
I'M A DIRECTOR FOR THE SONOMA
COUNTY WATER AGENCY ALSO KNOWN
AS CINEMA WATER. SO NUMBER
WATER IS A SPECIAL DISTRICT OUR
CORE FUNCTION IS TO PROVIDE
DRINKING WATER TO APPROXIMATELY
SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE
AND- SILVA AND RATE COUNTIES.
WE ARE A WHOLESALE PROVIDER OF
WATER TO CITIES AND WATER
DISTRICTS. WATER COMES FROM THE
RUSSIAN RIVER WATERSHED SYSTEM
AND WE RELY ON TO RESERVOIRS
MENDOCINO. AND LAKE CINEMA.
BOTH OF WHICH WE JOINTLY MANAGE
WITH THE UNITED STATES ARMY
CORPS OF ENGINEERS OBVIOUSLY WE
MANAGE IT FOR WATER SUPPLY WELL
THE COR MANAGES. DURING THE
WINTER MONTHS FOR FLOOD
CONTROL. OF NOTE THE SYSTEM IS
BASICALLY SELF CONTAINED IN WE
ARE NOT CONNECTED TO ANY PART
OF THE STATE WATER PROJECT OR
THE CENTRAL VALLEY PROJECT. WE
ALSO HAVE THREE GROUNDWATER
BASINS UNDER THE AUSPICES OF
SIGMA HERE IN CINEMA COUNTY I
ACTUALLY SERVE ON TWO OF THOSE
THREE GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY AGENCIES AND WE
ARE MAKING PROGRESS IN THAT
REGARD. CINEMA COUNTY IS MOSTLY
WORLD BEYOND- THE ONE ON ONE
CORRIDOR. IN OUR ECONOMY IS
BASED IN AGRICULTURE IT'S BASED
ON TOURISM AND RECREATION AS
WELL. IT OF COURSE RAINFALL
MEANS EVERYTHING TO OUR
REGION'S WATER SUPPLY AND THUS
FAR ECONOMY. OBVIOUSLY IT FEELS
OUR RESERVOIRS OF REPLENISHES
OUR GROUNDWATER IT PROVIDES
WATER FOR LIVESTOCK AND CROP
IRRIGATION WATER FOR ENDANGERED
FISH. WATER FOR RECREATION IN
OUR ENVIRONMENT AND FORTUNATELY
OR UNFORTUNATELY. WATER FOR
FIREFIGHTING EFFORTS. WORST
DROUGHT ON RECORD IN OUR AREA
WAS IN. NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN BACK
WHEN I WAS IN HIG SCHOOL- THAT
WINTER IN COLORADO WE'RE
WITNESSING IT WAS LOCATED
RECEIVE JUST OVER SIXTEEN
INCHES OF RAINFALL. AS OPPOSED
TO THE USUAL- RAINFALL OF ABOUT
THIRTY SEVEN INCHES. ARE FOR
COMPARISON THIS YEAR IN
COLORADO HAS RECEIVED JUST A
TAD OVER THIRTEEN INCHES
SOULFUL THREE INCHES LESS. THAN
THE WORST DROUGHT YEAR OF
RECORD. AS A RESULT LAKE
MENDOCINO IS AT 43% OF CAPACITY
WITH LESS THAN THIRTY SEVEN
THOUSAND TOTAL ACRE FEET.
THAT'S THE LOWEST STORAGE LEVEL
EVER AT THIS TIME OF YEAR IN
THAT PARTICULAR LAKE. OUR
SECOND RESERVOIR LIKE CINEMA IS
ABOUT 61% OF CAPACITY AND THAT
RAINFALL THAT FEEDS THAT LAKE
WAS NOT QUITE THIRTEEN INCHES.
THAT RESERVOIR IS AS LOW AS IT
HAS EVER BEEN AT THIS TIME OF
YEAR AS WELL. IN WHILE PERHAPS
NOT QUITE AS DIRE WE HAD
SIMILAR CONDITIONS DURING THE
DROUGHT OF TWO THOUSAND AND
FOURTEEN. BUT THANKFULLY WE
LEARNED SOME LESSONS AND DOUBLE
DOWN ON PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTING CONSERVATION AND
RESILIENCY PRACTICES AND
PROGRAMS WHICH REALLY ARE
STARTING TO PAY OFF. IN EARLY
TWENTY TWENTIES CINEMA WATER
FILED A TEMPORARY URGENCY
CHANGE PETITION. TO PRESERVE
WATER IN LAKE MENDOCINO THAT
ACTION HAS SAVED OVER TEN
THOUSAND ACRE FEET OF WATER
WITHIN THE LAKE THROUGH THE END
OF TWENTY TWENTY. SO WHILE THE
pSHOULD BE WORSE. HAD WE NOT
TAKEN THAT ACTION THAT WE ALSO
IMPLEMENTE A PUBLIC SERVICE
ANNOUNCEMENT CAMPAIGN GETTING
THE WORD OUT TO OUR COMMUNITY.
I THINK OF NOTE ARE PER CAPITA
WATER USE IS DOWN ABOUT 31%
OVER THE LAST TWENTY YEARS OR
SO. AND WE USE THAT TO SPREAD
THE WORD TO USE WATER WISELY
AND TREATED AS PRECIOUS AS IT
IS. IN THIS YEAR'S NUMBER WATER
FILED ANOTHER. TEMPORARY
URGENCY CHANGE ORDER TO REDUCE
WATER RELEASES FROM LAKE
MENDOCINO. THIS PETITION WAS
APPROVED BY THE STATE WATER.
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD AS WELL.
SO WE HAVE TO MAINTAIN OUR
FLOWS IN RUSSIAN- FOR
ENDANGERED SALMON AND STEELHEAD
THAT RUN THE RIVER FOR OUR OWN
DRINKING WATER SUPPLY THE
HEALTH OF THE RIVER AND ALL
THAT FLOWS FROM IT INCLUDING
RECREATION. AS YOU DON'T
GOVERNOR NEWSOM STOOD ON THE
BIG LAKE BED OF LAKE MENDOCINO
JUST A COUPLE WEEKS BACK AND
PROCLAIM TO DROUGHT EMERGENCY
FOR. MEDICINAL AND SNOW
COUNTIES. WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR
THE PROCLAMATION AND WE'RE
WORKING WITH OUR STATE LOCAL
PARTNERS USING EVERY TOOL MADE
AVAILABLE THROUGH THE
DECLARATION TO ENSURE WATER
AVAILABILITY. AND TO PROTECT
OUR WATERSHEDS HEALTH AS MUCH
AS POSSIBLE IN THESE
CHALLENGING TIMES. I WANT TO
INTRODUCE TO YOU IF YOU AREN'T
ALREADY FAMILIAR WITH THE
PROGRAM WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
ON- AND WE'VE ALREADY SEEN SOME
BENEFIT FROM. I HEARD THE
COMMENTS- IN QUESTIONS ON
STORAGE AND THIS IS A PROJECT
PROJECT AND I'M VERY EXCITED
ABOUT AS A DIRECTOR OF THE
WATER AGENCIES CALL FORECAST
INFORMED RESERVOIR OPERATIONS-
OR PHARAOH. IF YOU WILL. IT'S
USING THE BEST DATA AVAILABLE
TO MANAGE WATER STORAGE IN
RESERVOIRS. IT'S BEST TOLD
REALLY I THINK BY GOING BACK TO
ITS INCEPTION. SO IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FOURTEEN THE LAST
DROUGHT THAT WE'VE EXPERIENCED.
LIKE MENACING OF WATER LEVEL
WAS NOT CLOSE TO CAPACITY. BUT
THE U. S. ARMY CORPS AGAIN WHO
MANAGES RESERVOIR FOR FLOOD
CONTROL REFERRED TO A DIDN'T
RULE BOOK FOR NEARLY FIFTY
YEARS AGO. WHICH SAID IN
ESSENCE IF THE WATER LEVEL IS
AT THIS ELEVATION AND THE STORM
IS COMING. YOU RELEASED THE
WATER. MAKES SENSE IN THEORY-
BUT WHAT HAPPENED WAS THAT RAIN
NEVER FOLLOWED. AND TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF ACRE FEET OF WATER
WAS LOST. AND THAT PARTICULAR
YEAR WE NEVER REALLY RECOVERED.
WE STARTED WORKING WITH THE
SCRIPTS INSTITUTE OF
OCEANOGRAPHY CENTER FOR WESTERN
WEATHER AND WATER EXTREMES AS
WELL AS G. W. ARE. NO LONGER
AND THE WEATHER SERVICE TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND FORECASTING
AND PRECIPITATION AS STORMS
FROM IN ACROSS THE PACIFIC.
WHAT WE DISCOVERED IS THESE
NARROW BANDS OF MOISTURE THAT
HIT OUR WATERSHED WE NOW WE NOW
ALL KNOW THEM AS ATMOSPHERIC
RIVERS. THEY DO ACCOUNT 450% OF
THE STATE'S PRECIPITATION IT
REALLY COMES DOWN TO A FEW
STORMS A YEAR THAT DETERMINE IF
WE HAVE A DRY AN AVERAGE OR
WHAT YEAR. IN IF YOU ARE
MANAGING A RESERVOIR. YOU WANT
TO KNOW IF THE ATMOSPHERE IS
GOING TO HIT YOUR WATERSHED OR
MISS. MANY TIMES A FEW MILES
EITHER WAY CAN MAKE OR BREAK IN
OUR WATER YEAR. SO AGAIN
WORKING WITH SCRIPTS WITH OUR
PARTNERS AT THE STATE- RESEARCH
WAS DONE TO REALLY TRY TO
TRACK. ALL THESE ATMOSPHERIC.
RIVERS ARE PERFORMED IN WHAT WE
CAN TAKE FROM THATSO THAT WE
CAN ACTUALLY CHANGE THAT RULE
BOOK TO BE A LITTLE MORE
CONSERVATIVE AND RELEASING
WATER- OUR PARTNERSHIP BEGAN
FLYING RECON MISSIONS OUT OVER
THE PACIFIC OCEAN TO TRACK THE
ROUTES IN INTENSITY THE
ATMOSPHERIC RIVERS- I CAN TELL
YOU THAT WE ARE VERY GRATEFUL
THAT IN THAT PARTICULAR YEAR
WITH THE- WITH WORKING WITH
THEN SENATOR MARTY BLOCK.
PASSED SB SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT IN
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AND
CREATED THE ATMOSPHERIC RIVERS
RESEARCH MITIGATION AND CLIMATE
FORECASTING- PROGRAM. AND
THANKS TO SUBSEQUENT
APPROPRIATIONS THAT PROGRAM
WE'RE ABLE TO CONDUCT A PILOT
PROGRAM AT LAKE MENDOCINO
WORKING WITH THE ARMY CORPS TO
CHESTER RESEARCH AND THEORIES.
AND USE A DEVIATION TO HOLD
BACK WATER INTO THE FLOOD POOL.
THAT WOULD HAVE OTHERWISE BEEN
RELEASED- THE RESULT IS ABOUT
ELEVEN THOUSAND ACRE FEET- THAT
I MENTIONED EARLIER. TO ME THIS
IS VERY EXCITING- THIS IS
WHERE- IF WE CAN IMPROVE THE
STORAGE CAPACITY OF EACH AND
EVERY RESERVOIR IN THE STATE-
BY. SOME PERCENTAGE POINT OF.
MAYBE FIVE MAYBE UP 210% THAT
WOULD BE A GREAT MOVE FORWARD I
THINK IN TERMS OF TRULY
MANAGING OUR WATER SUPPLY WITH
THIS VOLATILE WEATHER PATTERNS
THAT WE'VE BEEN SEEING. WE
PUBLISHED INITIAL VIABILITY
ASSESSMENT THAT SHOWS FORECAST
INFORMED RESERVOIR OPERATIONS-
DO WORK. IN CINEMA WATER IS NOT
THE ONLY WATER AGENCY INVESTING
IN EUROPE AT WE BUILT A
COALITION. AND THAT WE HAVE
SUPPORT FROM THAT EFFORT THAT
INCLUDES THE FOLLOWING- SAN
DIEGO COUNTY ORANGE COUNTY
IRVINE RANCH TURLOCK YUBA AND
SANTA CLARA. AND IN ORDER TO
EXPAND UPON THE PROMISE OF VERO
WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO FIND IT
E. W. R. PROGRAM AND PILOT
DEVIATIONS AT OTHER RESERVOIRS.
THE ATMOSPHERIC RIVER RESEARCH
CREATES THE FORECAST THAT'S THE
F. IN VERO AND WITHOUT THAT
ATMOSPHERIC RIVER RESEARCH
FUNDING. THERE REALLY IS NO
PHARAOH. AND FOR MY WATER
AGENCY WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO APPLY
THAT HAD WE BEEN ABLE TO APPLY
FOR. LAKES NANA WE COULD SAVE
EVEN MORE WATER AND CRITICALLY
NEEDED AT THIS MOMENT. I THANK
GOD THIS IS A REALLY EXCITING
PROGRAM THAT HAS GREAT
POTENTIAL TO REALLY BE A GAME
CHANGER WATER MANAGEMENT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND IT REALLY DOES
DEPEND ON SOME STABLE FUNDING
TO BE W. OURS ATMOSPHERIC
RIVERS PROGRAM. I THINK IT'S AN
INVESTMENT AND- IN THE FUTURE
AS WE MANAGE THROUGH THESE
DROUGHTS THAT ARE COMING ALL
TOO OFTEN. I WILL SAY IN THE
SAME VEIN IS ZERO THE WATER
AGENCY IS WORKING AGAIN WITH
SCRIPTS. HYLARANA STATE
UNIVERSITY GW ARE AGAIN A GREAT
PARTNER. IN FLOOD CONTROL AND
WATER AGENCIES PARTNERS AROUND
THE BAY AREA I'M WHAT WE CALL.
THE ADVANCED QUANTITATIVE
PRECIPITATION INFORMATION. IT'S
A MOUTHFUL- BUT THE ACRONYM IS-
BASICALLY AQ PI. IT'S NOT
REALLY MUCH BETTER AS AN
ACRONYM BUT- IT REALLY IS-
ABOUT USING ADVANCED RADAR
TECHNOLOGY TO FORECAST AGAIN
THE PRECIPITATION THAT COMES IN
ACROSS THE PACIFIC. R. AS I
UNDERSTAND IT A LOT OF OUR-
RADAR SYSTEMS THROUGHOUT FOR
WEATHER FORECASTING DON'T HAVE
THE FINE GRAIN DETAIL THAT ONE
NEEDS TO REALLY- GET THE
INFORMATION NEEDED. THAT SET AT
THE SCALE- THAT YOU NEED TO
REALLY PUT INTO WORK ON TO
CHANGE THE WORLD BOOKS TO
CHANGE THE WAY THE RESERVOIRS
ARE MANAGED- AND- THESE THESE
RADAR SYSTEMS WILL HELP US DO
THAT. SO WE'RE REALLY EXCITED
ABOUT THAT AS WELL WE THINK
THAT IT'S ALL ON WORKING
TOGETHER TO REALLY MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN REALLY UNDERSTAND
HOW THESE STORMS ARE GONNA HIT
WHERE THE CAR HIT HOW MUCH
PRECIPITATION IS GOING TO FALL.
WHETHER IT'S IN THE WAERSHED
OR NOT AND THEN WHAT YOU DO
WITH THE RESERVOIR- AS YOU
PREPARE FOR IT BUILDING AFTER
THOSE STORMS- SO IT WORKS IN
CONCERT WITH GIRL IT COULD BE I
GUESS. ON AGAIN BETTER
PINPOINTING- IN BETTER
MANAGEMENT. THE OTHER THING
THAT WE'VE DONE- BESIDES THESE
REALLY HIGH TECH VERSIONS OF
THINGS AND SOME OF THE REALLY
DOWN AND DIRTY THINGS THAT ONE
DOES- DURING DROUGHTS- WE HAD A
DROUGHT DRIVE UP. A DROUGHT
DRIVE UP TO REALLY JUST THAT ON
THINK OF- COATED- YOU KNOW
VACCINES ARE TESTING. IT'S
REALLY HAVING PEOPLE DRIVE UP
AND GET A PACKAGE OF- TOOL KITS
THAT INCLUDE WATER SVING
DEVICES FOR IMMEDIATE WATER
CONSERVATION NEEDS DURING THE
DROUGHT. LIKE SHOWER HEADS AND
TOILETS DONNA TABS TO CHECK FOR
LEAKS. SHOWER BUCKETS HOSE
NOZZLES EDUCATIONAL MATERIALS
ITS REALLY GETTING THE WORD
OUT. IN A WAY THAT- WE FOUND TO
BE VERY SUCCESSFUL- WE THINK WE
WOULD LIKE TO IT WORKS WELL IN
URBANIZED AREAS QUITE FRANKLY
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO EXPAND
THIS. A BUT OF COURSE THAT
TAKES US SOME FUNDING AS WELL
AND WE DO THINK- WE'VE- HAD A
LOT OF SUCCESS. ON BY HAVING
THESE. DROP POP UPS THEY
BECOME- KNOWN ON THE NEWS AND
GETS THE WORD OUT. I BELIEVE IN
A MUCH MUCH BETTER WAY. AND I
CAN TELL YOU THIS FROM WHERE I
SIT IN MY DISTRICT HERE IN THE
SOUTHERN END OF CINEMA COUNTY
AGRICULTURE IS ONE OF OUR
ECONOMIC DRIVERS. RATES IN OUR
REGION- VALUED AT THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY SIX MILLION LAST YEAR
THAT'S ONLY ABOUT HALF OF WHAT
IT WAS IN TWO THOUSAND AND
NINETEEN. WE HAVE A LOT OF FIRE
DAMAGE LAST YEAR AND SMOKE
DAMAGE- FROM THE WILDFIRES-
FOLLOWING GRAPES MILK
PRODUCTION WAS VALUED IN TWO
THOUSAND AND NINETEEN AT ABOUT
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION. LIVESTOCK AND POULTRY-
ALSO ARE BIG AND SONOMA COUNTY.
THE SEVERE DROUGHT CONDITIONS
ARE IMPACTING RIGHT NOW- IF
YOU'RE DISHING FOR CROPS AND
WATER LIVESTOCK. WATER FOR
LIVESTOCK AND FEED AND I COULD
TELL YOU THAT THE- THERE ARE
WATER HAULING PROGRAMS ALREADY
UNDERWAY- FOR AREAS WEST OF
WHERE I LIVE HERE IN PETALUMA-
FOR RANCHES ACT HAVE. RUN DRY
OR THEIR AG PLANS ARE NOW DRY.
AND OF COURSE IT'S ONLY ON THE
FIFTH OF MAY GOING FORWARD SO
IT'S GOING TO BE A LONG DRY
YEAR. WE'RE HOPEFUL- THAT WE
HAVE A REPRIEVE FROM WILDFIRES
THIS YEAR BUT AGAIN WE ALL
KNOW- WE'RE- YOU KNOW WHAT
WE'RE FACING. I KNOW OF
PERSONALLY I CAN TELL YOU MY
SONS- CALIFORNIA FIREFIGHTER-
WAS THAT A COUPLE FIRES UP IN
LAKE COUNTY. LAST WEEK AND SAID
THE MOISTURE CONTENT ON AT MAY
FIRST WAS ABOUT WHAT IT SHOULD
BE AND AUGUST FIRST SO WE ARE
ALREADY AND- I DIRE SITUATION
THERE- ON THE AGRICULTURE FRONT
AGAIN- RANCHERS HAVE. BEEN
FACING TOUGH DECISIONS THEY'VE
BEEN CALLING THEIR HERDS
THEY'VE BEEN SELLING THEIR
HERDS TRANSFERRING THEIR HERDS
TRYING TO FIND ALTERNATE
SOURCES OF WATER- OUR ON FARM
BUREAU HERE HAS BEEN WORKING
WITH- WITH THEM- TO DO WHAT WE
CAN AND WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
THEM AS WELL TO. MAKE SURE THAT
WE CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THEM AS
THEY GO FORWARD THROUGH THIS.
DIFFICULT TIME. THERE'S ALSO
BEEN A SIGNIFICANT- DECREASE
THE AVAILABILITY OF RECLAIMED
WATER SOMETHING THAT WE'VE
REALLY BEEN WORKING ON HERE
IT'S NOT MY COUNTY AND WITH THE
OTHER COUNTY ARE MARIN COUNTY.
AS WELL AS NAPA- IN KIND OF A
LARGER- WATERSHED APPROACH TO
RECYCLED WATER. IN MAKING IT
AVAILABLE FOR OUR AGRICULTURAL-
OF PARTNERS INCLUDING FOR FROST
PROTECTION. ON THE GREAT FINDS
WHICH IS A- A VERY GOOD USE FOR
THIS WATER AS WELL AS- PASTURE
AND HAY CROP IRRIGATION. IT'S
THAT THOUGH IS AMPLIFYING THE
CHALLENGE OF WATER SCARCITY
AGAIN. HAVING A- NOT HAVING AS
MUCH RECYCLED WATER AS WE WOULD
LIKE- YOU KNOW THE EDMONSON
RESERVOIRS OF ALSO BEEN CRUCIAL
FOR FIGHTING FIRES. AND WE'RE
SEEING THESE WATER SOURCES ARE
QUICKLY DRYING UP- AND- WE
WORRY ABOUT THAT AS THIS YEAR
GOES ON AND AS THE WEATHER
BECOMES WARMER GOING FORWARD. I
THINK- OBVIOUSLY THAT FARMERS
ARE CONDUCTING STEPS ARE READY
THEY ARE REALLY HAVE THEIR NOSE
TO THE GRINDSTONE AND
UNDERSTAND THEIR- WHAT IT TAKES
TO SURVIVE BUT AT THE END THE
DAY WE NEED WATER TO FALL FROM
THE SKY AND WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE TREATING IT AS
PRECIOUS AS IT IS- WE NEED
IMMEDIATE DROUGHT RELIEF
FUNDING TO SUPPORT AGRICULTURE
QUITE FRANKLY IN THIS COUNTY-
AND THAT INCLUDES PROJECTS TO
JUMPSTART GROUNDWATER RECHARGE.
REALLY THE INSTALLATION OF
LINERS IN OUR AREA- AREA PONDS
AND RESERVOIRS THAT'LL HELP
WOMEN THAT GROUNDWATER OR THE
AMOUNT OF WATER LOST TO
ABSORPTION AND ALLOW FOR LONGER
STORAGE TIME CAPACITY WHEN
MACHINES TO COMBAT FROST AS
OPPOSED TO USING WATER- WOULD
BE A GOOD THING SOIL MOISTURE
PROBES TO EFFICIENTLY MANAGE
IRRIGATION NEEDS EFFICIENT
STORAGE OF OFFSITE AND ONSITE
WATER. IN THE WAY WE LOOK AT
THESE THINGS THAT THERE'S A THE
SHORT TERM IMMEDIATE NEED TO
KEEP THE BUSINESSES UP AND
GOING THROUGH THE SUMMER MONTHS
THERE'S A LONGER TERM
INVESTMENTS THAT NEED TO BE
MADE TO REALLY PROVIDE THE
RESILIENCY NEEDED TO SURVIVE-
THIS VERY FLASHY SYSTEMS THAT
WE HAVE WORDS- EITHER IS
SEEMINGLY IN A DROUGHT YEAR OR
FLOOD YEAR AND NOTHING IN
BETWEEN. SO WE JUST NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
TO MAKE THOSE INVESTMENTS IN
INFRASTRUCTURE IN. IN IN
RESILIENCY GOING FORWARD. I
THINK THE FINAL TOPIC I WANTED
ON IS HOW THE DROUGHT IMPACTS
THE HEALTH OF OUR WATERSHED AND
AGAIN INCREASES THE FIRE
DANGER. AND I DON'T THINK I
NEED TO TELL YOU- HOUSE CINEMA
COUNTY HAS BEEN AFFECTED BY
WILDFIRES- STARTING IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WITH TUBBS
AND NUNS FIRES FOLLOWED IN BY
THE CAN GET FIRED IN TWO
THOUSAND AND- NINETEEN. AND
THEN JUST LAST YEAR WE WERE HIT
WITH THE ALLEN YOU COMPLEX-
THESE FIRES HAVE WREAKED HAVOC
ON OUR COMMUNITIES I CAN TELL
YOU THAT- THERE IS A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF PTSD. AND THE
COMMUNITY AS WELL- BUT IT'S
ALSO RECOUNTED ON A WATERSHED.
THE ASHLEY DEBRIS OFFLOAD THE
RUSSIAN RIVER IMPACTING THE
QUALITY OF THE WATER. PLACING
FURTHER STRAIN ON THE DEPENDED
FISH ANDWILDLIFE SPECIES ARE
PARTNERS IN THE AND THE AGENCY
HAS. DONE A GREAT JOB I
BELIEVE. IN TERMS OF GETTING
OUT THERE RIGHT AWAY RIGHT
AWAY- POSE FIRE BURNING UP THE
STRAW WATTLES DOING ALL THE
THINGS THAT YOU ARE SUPPOSED TO
DO AND DO REALLY WELL. BUT AT
THE END OF THE DAY- LANDSCAPE
IS UP. IT'S BEEN REALLY
CHARRED. AND IT IN- IN A
NEGATIVE IMPACT IS- IS CREATED.
THAT'S REALLY HARD TO OVERCOME.
SO WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THE
INVESTMENTS THE STATE HAS
ALREADY MADE TO ADDRESS WILD
FIRE RESCUE IN WEIRD COURAGE BY
THE PROSPECT OF. ADDITIONAL
FUNDING THIS YEAR TO RESTORE
THE FOREST HEALTH AND REDUCE.
WILDFIRE RISK EVEN MORE SO- BUT
WE KNOW THAT THAT ALSO NEEDS TO
BE SUSTAIN FOR THE LONG TERM. I
IN OUR COUNTY WE PUT A- TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT THAT WERE
REALLY THINKING UP IS-
HOPEFULLY GOING TO BE
LEVERAGED- TO REALLY HAVE- KIND
OF THAT LANDSCAPE SCALE
APPROACH. TO REALLY FIGURE OUT
WHAT WE CAN DO TO MAKE SURE
THAT EACH AND EVERY YEAR WE'RE
NOT FACED WITH THE WILDFIRE
RISKS THAT WE HAVE BEEN-
DROUGHTS OBVIOUSLY PLAY A HUGE
ROLE IN THAT. WE BELIEVE THAT
SOME OF THOSE EARLIER FIRES I
MENTIONED. ARE WERE THE DIRECT
RESULT OF THE DAMAGE THAT WAS
DONE DURING THE DROUGHT OF TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN. A LOT OF
TREES OUT THERE WERE- WERE
KILLED BECAUSE OF THAT DROUGHT.
AND THEY WERE LEFT TO BURN-
WHEN THOSE FIRES HIT SO WE'RE
TRYING TO BE PROACTIVE GOING
FORWARD WE KNOW THAT DROUGHTS.
ARE ALL PART OF THAT PICTURE.
IN AGAIN TO- I WANT TO THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR ALLOWING ME TO BE
HERE FOR RECOGNIZING THESE A
PERILOUS CONDITIONS THAT THE
STATE IS FACING FOR WORKING ON.
I HOPE- YOU TAKE AWAY. FROM MY
ROUTE REMARKS THAT THERE ARE
OPPORTUNITIES TO CONSERVE
WATER- WHETHER THAT'S UTILIZING
CUTTING EDGE TECHNOLOGY LIKE IT
UP I OR ZERO- OR EVEN DOING
THEM THE- KIND OF USUAL THINGS
LIKE MAKING SURE THAT THE
CONSERVATION- KIDS ARE OUT
THERE AND THAT PEOPLE ARE TRULY
AWARE THROUGH- EDUCATION.
OUTREACH BUT ALSO UNDERSTANDING
THE IMPACTS THAT IT TAKES TWO
OR EVERYONE. INCLUDING OUR
AGRICULTURAL PARTNERS- THAT
REALLY ARE ARE SO DEPENDENT
UPON HAVING WATER ON THEIR
PROPERTIES. TO BE ABLE TO- FEED
THERE ARE LIVESTOCK. OR TO
WATER THEIR CROPS. ON SO WE'VE
MADE SOME GOOD PROGRESS SINCE
LAST DROUGHT. ARE WE AND WE
KNOW THE STATE HAS MADE
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS AS WELL
BUT I THINK TOGETHER WE ALL
HAVE A LOT MORE WORK TO DO. AND
WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO MAKE THE
INVESTMENTS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE PREPARED FOR.
WHATEVER THE FUTURE HAS AN OLD
HAS A HOLD FOR US- SO AGAIN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK AT THE-
LOOK FORWARD YOUR COMMENTS AND-
THANK YOU FOR ALL THE WORK THAT
YOU DO NOT BEHALF OF THE STATE.
THANK YOU OUR SUPERVISOR AND WE
APPRECIATE YOU HIGHLIGHTING.
FORECAST INFORMED RESERVOIR
OPERATION PROGRAM THAT THEY
BELIEVE THAT SOMETHING THAT. OF
MANY ARE. INTERESTED IN WE DID
HAVE A QUESTION FOR YOU TO
ELABORATE ON THAT. WE WILL GET
BACK TO YOU T THE- POLE THAT-
MEMBERS WILL BE ASKING
QUESTIONS MOVE ONTO THE NEXT
SENTENCE IS ONE OF THE AND THE-
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER AND JUST
WANT TO KNOWLEDGE TO. HER
LEADERSHIP ON MANY OF THE
EFFORTS. THAT HAVE BEEN
UNDERTAKEN BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO PROVIDE SAFE
CLEAN DRINKING WATER. TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS SO BUT THANK YOU
FOR THAT- WORK IN PLEASE- BEGIN
YOUR PRESENTATION.
OKAY DID
YOU. CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN
HEAR YOU WELCOME. OKAY GREAT
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
NUMBERS MY NAME IS ONE OF THE
ON THAT. I'M A CO FOUNDER AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF COMMUNITY
WATER CENTER AND CENTER KALANI
DIRTY WATER LEVEL. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE
SOME PERSPECTIVES FROM OUR HARD
WORKING FAMILIES WITH YOU TODAY.
GWC IS A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
BASED IN CALIFORNIA THE SILICON
VALLEY WITH OFFICES IN
SACRAMENTO. AND THE CENTRAL
COAST. OUR MISSION IS TO ACT AS
A CATALYST FOR COMMUNITY DRIVEN
WATER SOLUTION THROUGH
ORGANIZING EDUCATION AND
ADVOCACY. WORK ALONGSIDE AND
SUPPORT COMMUNITIES IMPACTED BY
UNSAFE DRINKING WATER AND
AFFORDABLE WATER. THE SAME VERY
SAME COMMUNITY SPACE VERY
DEVASTATING IMPACTS AS RELATES
TO WATER YOU CAN TALK MORE
ABOUT THAT IN MY PRESENTATION.
I WE KNOW WE HAVE HAD A
DRINKING WATER CRISIS IN THE
STATE FOR DECADES. EACH YEAR
OVER ONE MILLION CALIFORNIANS
ARE EXPOSED TO UNSAFE DRINKING
WATER. FROM THEIR TAPS IN THEIR
HOMES. MANY CALIFORNIANS
STRUGGLE TO ACCESS AFFORDABLE
WATER. DUE TO THE LACK OF NOT
HAVING A STATE WIDE WATER
AFFORDABILITY PROGRAM. AN
ESTIMATED OF FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS WERE
IMPACTED BY WATER SHUT OFFS IN
TWO THOUSAND NINE THANK YOU
ALONE. THE PANDEMIC CREATED
FURTHER CHALLENGES WITH
CALIFORNIA'S CAPTURING AN
ESTIMATE OF ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION AND DRINKING WATER DEBT
I THINK THIS MONTH. AND NOW
WE'RE FACING ANOTHER JAPANESE
CALIFORNIA ONE THAT HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO CAN BE WORSE THAN
THE LAST DROUGHT. THE PRIMARY
DRINKING WATER GROUNDWATER TO
PERRY DRINKING WATER SOURCE FOR
OVER 95% OF OUR COMMUNITIES IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY. MANY
COMMUNITIES RELY 100%
GROUNDWATER. MANY OF THE VERY
SAME ONE MILLION CALIFORNIANS
WITHOUT SAFE DRINKING WATER OR
AT RISK OF LOSING COMPLETE
WATER DURING THE DROUGHT. I
WITNESSED FIRST HAND. THE
DROUGHT IMPACTED MANY A FAMILY
SPACE DURING THE LAST DROUGHT
MANY SYSTEMS DIDN'T HAVE I
COMPLAINTS INCREASED
CONTAMINATION IN SOME LOCATIONS
WE HAVE MAJOR LANCE INSIGHTS AS
IN THE COMMUNITY ABOUT ALL. THE
GROUND OF THE DROP. AND TO MAKE
MATTERS WORSE MANY FAMILIES
LOST WATER COMPLETELY. MANY OF
THE STATE AND THE COUNTRY AND I
WHICH EVEN THE WORLD WATCHED IN
DISBELIEF AT WHAT HAPPENED IN
SUPPORTER ABOUT. COUNTY WERE
APPROXIMATELY SIXTEEN HUNDRED
DOMESTIC WELLS WENT DRY DURING
THE LAST DROUGHT. AND MANY MORE
FAMILIES DROPPED THE VALUE
STATE WE'RE WE'RE IMPACTED.
MANY OF OUR COMMUNITIES HAVE
NOT RECOVERED FROM THE LAST
DROUGHT. RIGHT RIGHT WELL
TRIMMING DRYING SOME DAMAGE TO
HAVE A WATER TANK IN FRONT OF
THEIR YARD. WE KNOW DROUGHT
WILL CONTINUE TO GET WORSE DUE
TO CLIMATE CHANGE. SHARK
COMMUNITIES AND OUR FAMILIES
CLIMATE CHANGE IS ALREADY HERE.
SHIVER COMMUNITIES DROUGHT IS
ABOUT MORE THAN JUST KEEPING
WATER FLOWING THAT COMPARED
DROUGHT IT'S ALSO ABOUT CLIMATE
CRISIS AND WHETHER WE WILL
PROVIDE OUR COMMUNITIES WITH
THE RESILIENCY INVESTMENTS THEY
NEED. FOR A DROUGHT IS ABOUT
RACIAL JUSTICE EQUITY AND
RESPECT. IN A CONTINUE PANDEMIC
DROUGHT IS ABOUT PRESERVING
ACCESS FOR MORE MOST BASIC
FORMAT P. P. WATER. WITH THE
REMAINDER OF MY TIME I WOULD
LOVE TO OFFER THREE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. FIRST WE NEED A
STATE DROUGHT PREPAREDNESS AND
RESPONSE PLAN PUT IN PLACE
BEFORE LARGE NUMBERS ARE
FAMILIES ARE STARTING TO USE
THE WATER FOR THE SUMMER WE
WERE NOT READY FOR THE LAST
ROUTE AS A RESULT WE SCRAMBLED.
THE LOCAL STATE RESPONSES VERY
UNCOORDINATED FAMILIES TO KNOW
WHO TO CALL. AND MANY OF THEM
WENT WITHOUT WATER FOR FAR TOO
LONG. SHOULD THE STATE SHOULD
PROACTIVELY PRIORITIZE REGION
WE KNOW ARE AT RISK OF HAVING
THE WATER INTERRUPTED DURING
THIS DROUGHT. HIS TEACHER PRE
POSITIONED EMERGENCY RESPONSE
TO PROVIDE SUCH A BOTTLED WATER
AND TANKS. I ALSO THINK THAT
THE STATE NEEDS TO ENSURE THAT
WE CREATE A CLEAR PUBLIC
STANDARDIZED PROTOCOLS TO WHO
SO THAT WE KNOW WHO TO CALL
WHEN RESIDENTS LOSE WATER ALONG
WITH A PROACTIVE. OUTREACH
STRATEGY TO SHARE THE CONTACT
INFORMATION WITH OUR COMMUNITY.
SECOND WE NEED TO ALLOCATE
SIGNIFICANT EMERGENCY DRINKING
WATER FUNDING NOW. WE HAVE A
PLACE ONLY NEEDED. THE
LEGISLATURE REGULARLY ALLOCATED
EMERGENCY FUNNY DURING THE LAST
ROUTE FOR BOTTLED WATER AND
STATE HELPFUL WELL AND
PROGRAMS. IT IS EASY BUT I DO
THINK IT WORKS WE HAVE PUT IN
PLACE NOW THERE'S ONE THING
LEFT TO WORRY ABOUT DURING THIS
CRISIS. THIRD AND FINALLY LET'S
SEIZE THIS MOMENT TWENTY BASK
IN DROUGHT RESILIENT
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES WHO ARE ON THE
FRONTLINE OF CALIFORNIA'S WATER
KIND OF CRISIS. HERE'S THE
THING WE ALREADY KNOW THE KINDS
OF INVESTMENTS THAT WOULD MAKE
OUR COMMUNITIES MORE DROUGHT
RESILIENT. FIFTY JUST RELEASED
A DROP REPORT THAT OUTLINES HE
BASIC DROUGHT RESILIENT
MEASURES THESE INCLUDE.
PROVIDING A BACKUP SOURCE OF
WATER FOR MORE THAN ONE POLICY
SYSTEMS THAT CURRENTLY ONLY
DEPEND ON ONE DRINKING WATER
WELL. WE TO ENSURE THAT WE
IMPLEMENT WALK. L. MONITORING
SYSTEM SO THAT WE KNOW. THE
DEPTH OF WATER BEFORE IT
ACTUALLY RUNS DRY. WE NEED TO
SUPPORT AND DEEPEN WELLS FOR
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
HOUSEHOLDS. WE ALSO NEED TO
SUPPORT COMMUNITY DRIVEN
CONSOLIDATIONS WERE APPROPRIATE.
AND I ALSO THINK WE TO ENSURE
THAT WE PROVIDE FUNDING TO
IMPLEMENT THE PROVISIONS OF SB
FIVE FIVE Q. AUTHORED BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG WHICH IS
CURRENTLY WORKING ITS WAY
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE. VERY
IMPORTANT BILL HE CALLED FOR
MORE PROACTIVE DRUG PLANNING AT
THE LOCAL COUNTY LEVEL WE NEED
TO PASS THIS NOW. COMMONSENSE
WE HAVE TO BE BETTER PREPARED
FOR. DROUGHT CLOSE WE SHOULD
FEEL EMPOWERED TO CHOOSE A
BETTER PATH FORWARD THROUGH
THIS DROUGHT FOR TOWARD THE
MORE RESILIENT FUTURE. WE HAVE
REAL LEADERSHIP IN THE STILL
DRINKING WATER. AS YOU KNOW THE
GOVERNOR THE LEGISLATURE WITH
PARTICULAR LEADERSHIP FROM THE
CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
HOW TO PASS THE SAME PRINCIPLE
DRINKING WATER TWENTY TWENTY
NINETEEN IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
COMMUNITY ACTIVIST. THIS
PURPOSE THE PARTNER AGAIN AND
LEAD AGAIN AND I KNOW WE WILL.
DO OUR CENTER INTRINSICALLY
DEBORAH LEVEL LOOKS FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU THE
ADMINISTRATION AND SAFETY
AGENCY IS TO ENSURE THAT THE
HUMAN RIGHT TO ENSURE THAT WE
DELIVER THE CORRECT WATER ALL
CALIFORNIANS. DURING CRITICAL
TIMES THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I HOPE THAT- YOU'LL
STAND BY FOR. POSSIBLE
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS TO YOU
MAY WEIGH IN ON WILL GO ON TO
THE NEXT PRESENTER THIS IS A-
DOG OVER HE WITH NRDC. WHO WILL
BE OUR NEXT PRESENTER. Q. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME
IS DOUG THE PUG I'M A SENIOR
ATTORNEY WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL OR
NRDC. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY. I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT RECOGNIZE
THE CALIFORNIA HAS MADE SOME
PROGRESS IN PREPARING FOR
DROUGHT SINCE THE LAST ROUTE
PARTICULARLY REGARDING
IMPROVING WATER USE EFFICIENCY.
AS OTHER CALIFORNIA'S EFFORTS
TO DIVERSIFY WATER SUPPLIES TO
REDUCE RELIANCE ON THE
BATTLEFIELD. THEY'VE ALSO BEEN
IMPORTANT ACTIONS TO TRY TO
ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S LONG
STANDING DRINKING WATER CRISIS
WHICH YOU JUST HEARD ABOUT.
HOWEVER WHEN IT COMES TO
PROTECTING CALIFORNIA'S FISH
AND WILDLIFE AND THE THOUSANDS
OF JOBS IN COMMUNITIES THAT
DEPEND ON THEIR HEALTH. RATHER
THAN LEARNING FROM THE LESSONS
OF THE LAST DROUGHT WE'RE ON
TRACK TO REPEAT THOSE MISTAKES.
AND HAVE ANOTHER DISASTER LIKE
THAT IN TWENTY FOURTEEN TO
TWENTY FIFTEEN. TO PUT THIS IN
CONTEXT IT'S IMPORTANT
RECOGNIZE THE DROUGHT IS A
NATURAL PART OF LIFE IN
CALIFORNIA AN ARTIFICIAL
WILDLIFE EVOLVED TO ADAPT TO
PERIODIC DROUGHTS. BUT CLIMATE
CHANGE IS MAKING DRUGS MUCH
MORE SEVEREAND FREQUENT SO
FISH HAVE LESS TIME AND WHILE
THAT HAS LESS TIME TO RECOVER.
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY OR AS
IMPORTANTLY UNSUSTAINABLE WATER
DIVERSIONS FROM OUR RIVERS AND
STREAMS DRAMATICALLY WORSENED
CONDITIONS FOR FISH AND
WILDLIFE DURING CRAFTS. CLOSER
ALREADY LOW AND THEN WE DIVERT
AFTER MORE OF THE WATER THAT
WOULD OTHERWISE FLOW. MY
TESTIMONY TODAY IS GOING TO
FOCUS ON THE BAY DELTA
WATERSHED WHICH COVERS 40% OF
THE STATE'S LAND MASS. WHAT IS
IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE THE
DROUGHT IS CAUSING SIGNIFICANT
IMPACTS TO FISH WILDLIFE ACROSS
THE STATE. SUCH AS SALMON
INSTRUCTORS IN THE KLAMATH
RIVER. SALMON ANOTHER NAY
EFFICIENT STREAMS ALONG THE
NORTH COAST MIGRATORY BIRDS AND
WILDLIFE THAT DEPEND ON
WETLANDS AND WILDLIFE REFUGES
THROUGHOUT THE CENTRAL VALLEY
AND MANY MANY OTHERS. AND IT'S
NOT JUST FISH AND WILDLIFE BUT
IT'S THE JOBS AND COMMUNITIES
THAT DEPEND ON THEIR HEALTH
THAT ARE IMPACTED.
UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE ON TRACK TO
REPEAT THE DISASTROUS
CONDITIONS OF TWENTY FOURTEEN
TO TWENTY FIFTEEN. FOR THE BAY
DELTA ECOSYSTEM THIS YEAR. AS
IN THE LAST ROUTE STARTING LAST
MONTH THE STATE AND FEDERAL
WATER PROJECTS VIOLATED
NUMEROUS WATER QUALITY
STANDARDS IN THE DELTA THE
PROTECT FARMS CITIES AND FISH
AND WILDLIFE. LOS FLOWS AND
VIOLATIONS OF WATER QUALITY
STANDARDS ARE EXPECTED TO CAUSE
SIGNIFICANT HARMFUL ALGAL
BLOOMS OF SUMMER WHICH DELIVERY
ARE SCIENTISTS WARN ARE A
THREAT TO HUMAN HEALTH AND
SAFETY. IT'S ALSO LIKELY TO
HARM NATIVE FISH AND WILDLIFE.
YOU KNOW IT'S IMPORTANT
RECOGNIZE THE DELTA SMELT WHICH
IS HISTORICALLY ONE OF THE MOST
ABUNDANT. NATIVE SPECIES IN THE
DELTA. HAS ALL BUT DISAPPEARED
SINCE THE LAST DROUGHT THANKS
TO UNSUSTAINABLE WATER
DIVERSIONS ALONG WITH OTHER
STRESSORS. N. AS IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN AND TWENTY FIFTEEN THE
STATE FEDERAL WATER PROJECTS
ARE AGAIN LIKELY TO LOSE
TEMPERATURE CONTROL. AT THE
MAJOR UPSTREAM RESERVOIRS
CAUSING MASSIVE MORTALITY TO
NATIVE SALMON AND OTHER SPECIES
THAT SPAWN BELOW SHASTA DAM OR
BILL IN FULL SO. THE NATIONAL
FISHERIES SERVICE ESTIMATES
THAT UNDER THE BUREAU OF
RECLAMATION'S PROPOSED
OPERATIONS AT SHASTA DAM.
PROXIMALLY 7528580% OF THE
HIGHLY ENDANGERED WINTER RUN
CHINOOK SALMON WILL BE KILLED
BY LETHAL WATER TEMPERATURES.
AT HIGH WATER TEMPERATURES IN
THE FALL WILL LIKELY WIPE OUT
ALL THE FALL RUN CHINOOK
SALMON. THE COME BACK TO
SPONSOR THOSE FISH ARE THE
BACKBONE OF THE STATE'S SALMON
FISHERY SUPPORTING THOUSANDS OF
JOBS. AND WHILE IT'S IMPORTANT
TO RECOGNIZE THAT THE- SOME
WATER USERS ARE GETTING VERY
LITTLE OR NO WATER THIS YEAR.
OTHERS ARE GETTING A LOT OF
WATER THANKS TO CALIFORNIA'S
FIRST IN TIME FIRST IN WHITE
RIGHT WATER RIGHTS SYSTEM. IT
MEANS THAT SOME USERS GETTING
SEVENTY FIVE OR A 100% OF THEIR
OUT MAXIMUM CONTRACT AMOUNTS
WILL OTHERS GET. ZERO THE
GATHERED THE STATE FEDERAL
WATER PROJECTS ARE ON TRACK TO
ALLOCATE MORE THAN FOUR POINT
FIVE MILLION ACRE FEET OF WATER
THIS YEAR. AND THAT'S
CONTRIBUTING TO THE VIOLATIONS
OF WATER QUALITY STANDARDS AND
THE TEMPERATURE IMPACTS WE SEE-
AT OUR UPSTREAM RESERVOIRS.
WHAT'S MORE. WE'RE ON TRACK TO
END THIS WATER YEAR WITH THE
END OF SEPTEMBER HAVING VERY
LITTLE WATER IN STORAGE. WHICH
MEANS THAT IF NEXT YEAR OR TRY
WILL BE REALLY UP THE CREEK
WITHOUT A PADDLE. THERE
PROJECTIONS THAT SHASTA WILL
HAVE LESS THAN A MILLION ACRE
FEET OF WATER IN STORAGE AT THE
END OF SEPTEMBER. AND ORACLE
WILL HAVE LESS THAN EIGHT
HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRE FEET AT
THE END OF SEPTEMBER AND MAY.
STOP PRODUCING HYDROPOWER
BECAUSE LAKE LEVELS FALL SO LOW
SOMETIME IN AUGUST. WE STARTED
THIS YEAR WITH TWO POINT TWO
MILLION ACRE FEET OF WATER IN
SHASTA AND- DECENT STORAGE IN
ORVILLE. AND YET WE'RE SEEING
THE DEVASTATING IMPACTS TO OUR
NATIVE FISH AND WILD LIKE THIS
YEAR. IF WE START NEXT YEAR
WITH LESS THAN A MILLION ACRE
FEET OF WATER IN STE STE
STORAGE IN CHESTER. THE IMPACT
WILL BE FAR WORSE. AND FINALLY
I DO WANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT
WE'RE SEEING THESE IMPACTS IN
THE SECOND YOU'RE A DROUGHT.
WHEREAS DURING THE LAST DROUGHT
IT WAS NOT UNTIL THE THIRD YEAR
WARY SAW THOSE DEVASTATING
IMPACTS. IN TERMS OF VIOLATIONS
OF WATER QUALITY STANDARDS AND
TEMPERATURE DEPENDENT MORTALITY
BELOW SHASTA DAM. THERE ARE
THREE KEY LESSONS FROM THE LAST
DROUGHT THAT UNFORTUNATELY WERE
FAILING TO LEARN. AND THAT ARE
CONTRIBUTING TO THE DEVASTATING
IMPACTS WE'RE SEEING LIKELY TO
SEE THIS YEAR. ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT LESSONS OF THE LAST
OUT WAS THE NEED TO PLAN AHEAD
FOR DROUGHT. AS THE RESOURCES
AGENCIES LESSONS LEARNED REPORT
EXPLAINS. QUOTE THE TWENTY
TWELVE TO TWENTY SIXTEEN
DROUGHT DEMONSTRATED THAT FISH
AND WILDLIFE MANAGERS USUALLY
HAVE FEW PLANTS ARE RESOURCES
TO MANAGE. DEVELOPING IN
ADVANCE CONTINGENCY PLANS TO-
FOR WATERSHEDS IN THE ADVENT OF
EXTENDED DROUGHT. COULD HELP
WILDLIFE MANAGERS AVOID MAKING
TRADE OFFS AMONG SPECIES. AND
PUT IN PLACE MECHANISMS TO
SUSTAIN FLOWS AND STREAM
TEMPERATURES DROP DEEPENS.
REPORT ALSO RECOMMENDS. AS A
PRIORITY. SETTING AND
IMPLEMENTING INSTREAM FLOW
STANDARDS FOR THE PROTECTION OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE.
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE NOT DONE
THOSE THINGS. WE DO NOT HAVE A
PLAN FOR DROUGHT PARTICULARLY A
PLAN TO PROTECT FISH AND
WILDLIFE. MOST IMPORTANTLY THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD HAS NOT BEEN ALLOWED TO
UPDATE AND IMPLEMENT WATER
QUALITY STANDARDS FOR THE BAY
DELTA. MANY OF THE EXISTING
STANDARDS HAVE NOT BEEN UPDATED
IN TWENTY FIVE YEARS AND THE
STANDARDS THAT WERE UPDATED IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
ARE STILL NOT BEING IMPLEMENTED.
THE BOARD AND OTHER AGENCIES
ARE RECOGNIZED AT THE EXISTING
STANDARDS ARE NOT ADEQUATE TO
PROTECT FILE. FISH WILDLIFE AND
OTHER BENEFICIAL USES. WHAT'S
MORE. AFTER THE BOARD WHERE
STANDARDS IN THE LAST DROUGHT
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN TO TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND NEARLY PRO SPECIES
EXTINCT. THE BOARD RECOGNIZE
THAT QUOTE. THAT THAT THOSE
OPERATIONS QUOTE ARE NOT
SUSTAINABLE. AND QUOTE AND
RECOMMENDED CHANGES TO DROUGHT
PLANNING AND PROCESSES TO
PREVENT EXTINCTION. YEAH HERE
WE ARE AGAIN. LESS THAN A MONTH
AFTER THE DIRECTOR DETER OVER
OUR TOLD US THAT WE WOULD NOT
HAVE FEW CPA'S TEMPORARYSINCE
THE CHANGE PETITIONS FORCING
THE PROJECT VIOLATING WATER
QUALITY STANDARDS IN THE DELTA.
AND IN A LETTER FROM THE STATE
WATER BOARD AT THE END OF LAST
MONTH. THE BOARD EXPLAINED THAT
QUOTE ALTHOUGH THE CURRENT
VIOLATIONS ARE EXACERBATED BY
THE EXTREME DRY CONDITIONS.
THERE IN PART THE RESULT OF
OVER ALLOCATION OF PRODUCT
WATER DURING DRY CONDITIONS.
ADDITIONALLY A RISK MANAGEMENT
OPERATIONAL DECISIONS BY THE
PROJECTS WERE MADE THAT APPEAR
TO HAVE DISCOUNTED AND NEED TO
MAINTAIN REGULATORY COMPLIANCE.
IN OTHER WORDS THE STATE
FEDERAL WATER PROJECTS DON'T
HAVE A PLAN FOR DROUGHTS. THEIR
PROMISES AND WATER SUPPLY
CONTRACTS MAKE THEM UNABLE TO
MEET THEIR OTHER WATER RIGHTS
OBLIGATIONS INCLUDING THEIR
OBLIGATIONS TO THE PUBLIC. AND
THE PLAN FOR DROUGHT APPEARS TO
BE VIOLATING THE REGULATIONS
PROTECTING THE PUBLIC AND
VIOLATING WATER QUALITY
STANDARDS. AND AGAIN WELL THE
DROUGHT WHILE THE STATE WILL
RESIST WATER RESILIENCY PLAN
CALLS FOR. HAVING PLANS IN
PLACE TO PROTECT FISH WILDLIFE
FROM ABOUT LASTING TO SIX
YEARS. WE'RE NOT EVEN MEETING
THE OUTDATED AND INADEQUATE
WATER QUALITY STANDARDS IN YEAR
TWO OF A DROUGHT. A SECOND
RELATED RECOMMENDATION OF THE
REPORT FROM THE RESOURCES
AGENCY. CONCERNS THE NEED TO
MAKE THIS IS EARLY STATING THAT
QUOTE ROUTE PLANNING AND
RESPONSE EFFORTS SHOULD NOT
WAIT UNTIL THE MIDDLE OF A
DROUGHT EMERGENCY. AND QUOTE.
AND ON THIS CAL THE STATE IS
ALSO FEELING. ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT LESSONS WE LEARNED
WITH THE NEED TO DEVELOP
TEMPERATURE MANAGEMENT PLANS
EARLY IN THE YEAR BECAUSE
RESERVOIR RELEASES FROM SHASTA
AND KESWICK DAMS AND HER MOTHER
RESERVOIRS. CAN DEPLETE THE
COLD WATER POOL NECESSARY TO
MAINTAIN WATER TEMPERATURES FOR
SALMON LATER IN THIS IN THE
YEAR. THE STATE HAS NOT DONE SO
IN PART BECAUSE THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION. ROLL BACK
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS UNDER
THE ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT. AND
LEGALIZED KILLING A 100% OF THE
ENDANGERED WINTER RUN CHINOOK
SALMON. THANKS AS A GIVEAWAY TO
CORPORATE AGRIBUSINESSES. THESE
BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS ARE PLANNED
FOR EXTINCTION. AND IT IS
ESSENTIAL THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION SET THEM ASIDE
AND RE INITIATE CONSULTATIONS
SO THAT WE CAN DEVELOP
SCIENTIFICALLY CREDIBLE PLANS
TO PREVENT EXTINCTION AND
MANAGE THESE WATER PROJECTS IN
A ERA. WHEN WE FACE GROWING
THREATS AND STRUCK HARDER
CONDITIONS FOR FISH AND
WILDLIFE. IT'S NOW EARLY MAY
AND WE STILL DON'T HAVE A DRAFT
TEMPERATURE MANAGEMENT PLAN FOR
SHASTA. EVEN AS EXCESSIVE
RELEASES FROM THE RESERVOIR
DEPLETED THE COLD WATER POOL
STARTING LAST MONTH AND WE'RE
ON TRACK TO KILL 75280% OF THE
IT THIS. HIGHLY ENDANGERED
SPECIES. REDUCING THOSE
RESERVOIR RELEASES WOULD
SUBSTANTIALLY DECREASE HOW MANY
EXAMINER KILLED THIS YEAR. AND
LEAD MORE WATER IN STORAGE IN
CASE NEXT YEAR'S ALSO DRIVE.
HIDING RELEASES WOULD COULD CUT
MORTALITY FROM 80% DOWN TO
FIFTY PERCENT. IMPROVE WATER
TEMPERATURES FOR FALL RUN
CHINOOK SALMON AND INCREASED
RESERVOIR STORAGE IN CASE NEXT
YEAR'S STUFF. AT THE
RECOMMENDATION OF THE REPORT IS
TO STREAMLINE WATER RIGHTS
ENFORCEMENT. AND AGAIN THERE'S
A LOT MORE WORK TO BE DONE. THE
WATER BOARD HAS ISSUED TERM
NINETY ONE CURTAILMENTS BUT
THAT APPLIES TO A VERY SMALL
SUBSET WATER USERS IN THE BAY
DELTA. AND EVEN AS WATER
QUALITY STANDARDS ARE BEING
VIOLATED AND SAM OR FACING
LETHAL WATER TEMPERATURES THIS
WINTER THIS FALL AND SUMMER.
THE STATE BOARD HAS NOT ISSUED
WIDESPREAD CURTAILMENT ORDERS
LIKE THEY DID IN THE LAST
DROUGHT. STATE BOARD HAS THE
LEGAL AUTHORITY AND THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO CURTAIL WATER
DIVERSIONS INCLUDING PRE
NINETEEN FOURTEEN WATER RIGHTS
HOLDERS TO PROTECT FISH AND
WILDLIFE AND THE PUBLIC TRUST.
THAT IT ALREADY HAS AN UP SELL
A PUBLIC WORKS INCLUDING A
TWENTY TWENTY DECISION IN THE
STANFORD BEING A CASE. WE THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THE STATE
FOR TAKE ACTION TO START. FOR
TAILING WATER RIGHTS. BECAUSE
NO WATER RATES IN CALIFORNIA
ARE SUPERIOR TO THE PUBLIC
TRUST. AND EXTINCTION IS
FOREVER. UPDATING WATER QUALITY
STANDARDS WILL ALSO HELP
BECAUSE TODAY. THE STATE AND
FEDERAL WATER PROJECTS ARE
LARGELY THE ONLY WATER USERS
HAVE TO CONTRIBUTE TO MEETING
WATER QUALITY STANDARDS. AND
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT IN A YEAR
LIKE THIS EVERYONE HAS TO
CONTRIBUTE. IN CONCLUSION
UNFORTUNATELY CALIFORNIA'S FISH
AND WILDLIFE IS A REPEAT OF THE
DISASTROUS CONDITIONS IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN TO TWENTY FIFTEEN.
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA'S REPEATING
MANY OF THE SAME MISTAKES FROM
THE PRIOR DROUGHT. THE STATE'S
PLAN FOR DROUGHT ALL TOO OFTEN
SEEMS TO FOCUS ON TRAINING
RESERVOIRS AND PRAYING FOR
RAIN. WAIVING ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTIONS THAT ARE ALREADY
TOO WEAK TO PROTECT OUR NATIVE
FISH AND WILDLIFE. AND DRIVING
FISH AND WILDLIFE TO THE BRINK
OF EXTINCTION. AND POTENTIALLY
TO EXTINCTION. THIS FAILURE TO
PLAN FOR DROUGHTS AND UPDATE
OUR WATER QUALITY STANDARDS
DOESN'T JUST HARMONY TO FISH
AND WILDLIFE. IT ALSO HARMS
NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES
THOUSANDS OF FISHING JOBS AND
COMMUNITIES IN THE DELTA THAT
ARE FACING HARMFUL ALGAL
BLOOMS. WE CAN AND MUST DO
BETTER BECAUSE OF NEXT YEAR'S
ALSO DRIVE THE DEVASTATION THAT
WE FORESEE THIS YEAR. WILL BE
FAR WORSE. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY
THAT CONCLUDES MY PREPARED
REMARKS. THANK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OUR NEXT PRESENTERS HERE
IN PERSON AND IT'S A TROLL. THE
BOSS CARE. ACT PLEASE. FOR THE
LOVE CARE. REUTERS GOOD
AFTERNOON I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
CHAIR VICE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY ON HOW DROUGHT HAS
IMPACTED MY FRIENDS MY FAMILY
MY BUSINESS AND MY COMMUNITY
AND ABOUT WAYS TO CALIFORNIA
CAN IMPROVE ITS RESILIENCE TO
DROUGHT MY NAME IS JOE THE LOS
QUE AND I'M A FARMER FROM
FIREBAUGH CALIFORNIA. I'VE BEEN
INVOLVED IN FARMING ALL MY LIFE
ON THE WEST SIDE OF THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY FOR MY FAMILY
SETTLED AFTER YEARS OF WORKING
IN THE FIELDS IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY FIVE I STARTED MY OWN
FARM DEL BOSQUE FARMS ARE MY
OUR PRIMARY BUSINESS IS GOING-ORGANIC CROPS WHICH INCLUDE
CANTALOUPES I NEED NEWS MIXED
MELONS WATERMELONS
ESPERICUETA'S AND SWEETCORN WE
ALSO GROW CONVENTIONAL ALMONDS
CHERRIES. I'VE BEEN VERY
FORTUNATE TO BE ABLE TO SERVE
MY COMMUNITY- AND MY INDUSTRY
IN VARIOUS CAPACITIES AS A
MEMBER OF THE LATINO WATER
COALITION. WAS TERROR ATTACKS
A- A MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF
CENTRAL VALLEY COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION AND A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA WATER COMMISSION. AS
I TOLD PRESIDENT OBAMA WHEN I
VISITED WHEN HE VISITED THE
VALLEY IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
DURING THE LAST DROUGHT THERE
ARE THREE THINGS THAT MAKE
FARMING WORK IN CALIFORNIA. SO
OIL WATER AND PEOPLE. REMOVE
ANY OF THE THREE COMPONENTS AND
CALIFORNIA WOULD NOT BE THE TOP
PRODUCING AGRICULTURAL STATE IN
THE NATION. NOR COULD WE
PROVIDE CALIFORNIANS IN THE
NATION TE SECURITY OF KNOWING
THAT ITS FRUITS AND VEGETABLES
WILL BE ON THE SHELVES
AVAILABLE FOR PURCHASE. AND
PRODUCED ADDED IN AN
ENVIRONMENTALLY SOUND MANNER.
THE COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC
TAUGHT US MANY THINGS BUT ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT LESSONS
LEARNED WAS THAT THE FOOD
SUPPLY CHAIN MUST BE PRESERVED.
IRVING THAT FOOD SUPPLY CHAIN
MEANS THAT WE MUST PROTECT
THOSE THREE COMPONENTS SOIL
WATER AND PEOPLE ESPECIALLY
DURING THE DROUGHT. MOST
NATURAL DISASTERS ARE QUITE
OBVIOUS HERE KINGS UPROOT TREES
DISPLACED POWER LINES WELL
FIRES WIPE OUT HOMES AND
LANDSCAPES EARTHQUAKES SHAKE
THE VERY GROUND WE WALK ON
DROUGHT IS DIFFERENT. ON MY OWN
FARM WE SEE ON PLANTED FEELS.
WE ARE WE ARE NOT ABLE TO GROW
CROPS THERE'S NO WATER THERE'S
NO CROPS THERE'S NO PEOPLE. I
CALL IT SILENT SPRING IN THE
FIELDS AND RIGHT NOW OF MORE
THAN 25% OF MY FARM IS LAID
FALLOW. CALIFORNIA'S LAST
DROUGHT WAS ONE OF THE MOST
SEVERE IN OUR HISTORY. TESTED
ALL ASPECTS OF OUR OF WATER
MANAGEMENT IN THE STATE
SHOWCASING INNOVATIVE
SOLUTIONS. BUT ALSO LAYING BARE
THE SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES THAT
STILL EXIST. FIVE CONSECUTIVE
DRY WINTER SHUT OFF WATER
DELIVERIES TO MANY A
COMMUNITIES AND FARMS IN THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY FOR TWO
CONSECUTIVE YEARS FORCING THE
REGION TO SOLELY RELY ON
GROUNDWATER AQUIFERS. FOR WATER%
SUPPLY. WHICH IN TURN HAD OTHER
NEGATIVE OF NEGATIVE AFFECTS
INCLUDING IMPAIRED DRINKING
WATER QUALITY DRY WELLS AND
DAMAGED HIS INFRASTRUCTURE.
FARMERS FOLLOWED AN ESTIMATED
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES OF
FARMLAND ABOUT 10% OF THE FARM
LAND IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
AND A 45% INCREASE OF STATEWIDE
ANNUAL FELLOW ACREAGE. THE
TOTAL ECONOMIC IMPACT TECH
RECALLED HER IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN WAS TWO POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLAR LOSS WITH TWENTY
ONE THOUSAND JOBS BEING LOST
WHICH AMOUNT 25% OF
AGRICULTURAL EMPLOYMENT. LET ME
REPEAT THAT TWENTY ONE THOUSAND
JOBS LOST MOSTLY FARMWORKERS.
THAT'S TWENTY ONE THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS WHO NO LONGER HAVE
THE SECURITY OF A JOB TO FEED
THEIR FAMILIES. AND FOR NO
OTHER REASON THAN LACK OF
AVAILABLE WATER. IMPORTANTLY
THESE JOB LOSSES COINCIDE WITH
SOME OF THE MOST ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA AS COMMUNITIES IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY WITH
POVERTY LEVELS OVER 75% ARE
THOSE MOST IMPACTED BY JOB
LOSSES RESULTING FROM LAND
FOLLOWING. AND THE IMPACTS OF
THE OF THE LAST TROUT WERE NOT
LIMITED TO ECONOMIC LOSSES. THE
WORST SEVERE. PHYSICAL AND
MENTAL HEALTH IMPACTS THE DEBT
THAT RESULTED FROM THE LAST
DROUGHT. A REPORT DONE BY
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
FRESNO INDICATES THAT DURING
THE LAST TROUT INSTANCES OF
VALLEY FEVER INCREASED BY
NEARLY SEVENTY PERCENT. WEST
NILE VIRUS WITH THIS DETECTED
AT AN ALL TIME HIGH IN FORTY
FOUR COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA.
SUICIDES RATES INCREASED
DRAMATICALLY AS HIS SOCIAL
CRIMES LIKE DOMESTIC OR
DOMESTIC ABUSE AND THEFT. THREE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY COUNTIES
KERN MADERA KINGS REPORT THAT
TWELVE POINT 5% OF THE SERVICE
SURVEYED OF POPULATIONS HAVE
SERIOUS PSYCHOLOGICAL
ILLNESSES. IT ALSO HAPPENS THAT
THESE COUNTIES AND THE VALLEY
GENERALLY HAVE THE LOWEST
NUMBER OF PRACTICING PHYSICIANS
PER COUNTY SO THESE COMMUNITIES
ARE AMONG THE THOSE LEAST
EQUIPPED TO DEAL WITH THESE
IMPACTS. WE KNOW THAT THE
IMPACTS OF DROUGHT AS WE HAVE
ONLY RECENTLY BEGUN TO RECOVER
FROM THE LAST ONE. AND MAKE NO
MISTAKE ABOUT IT WE ARE IN A
DROUGHT. THERE ARE A COUPLE OF
VERY SIGNIFICANT AND VERY REAL
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE LAST
DROUGHT AND THIS ONE. THE FIRST
AND MARK MOST TROUBLING ONE IS
THAT DURING THE LAST DROUGHT WE
BEGIN TO EXPERIENCED SERIOUS
IMPACT DURING THE THIRD YEAR.
TODAY WE'RE ONLY IN THE SECOND
YEAR AND WE HAVE NO SURFACE
WATER DELIVERIES TO MANY
FEDERAL WATER DISTRICTS IN THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY. AND
DRAMATICALLY REDUCE CREASE
DELIVERIES TO THOSE SERVED IN
THE STATE WATER PROVIDE THE
STATE WATER PROJECT. FROM THAT
STANDPOINT IT SEEMS LIKE WE'VE
TAKEN A STEP BACKWARDS. FURTHER
AS I MENTIONED EARLIER DURING
THE LAST DROUGHT FARMERS WERE
ABLE TO RELY ON GROUNDWATER TO
GROW ROPS WHEN SERVICE WATER
WAS NOT DELIVERED. HOWEVER
PUMPING GROUNDWATER TO
COMPENSATE FOR THE LACK OF
SURFACE WATER WILL NO LONGER BE
AVAILABLE. GOV GIVEN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN WHAT WE CALL SIGMA.
GIVEN THE FUTURE CONSTRAINTS WE
MUST BUILD THE INFRASTRUCTURE
WE DESPERATELY NEED SO WE ARE
ABLE TO MOVE AND SAVE THE WATER
TO GET. IN THE WAY YOURS AND
USE THAT WATER IN THE DRY YEARS
WE KNOW WILL COME. THIS MEANS
INVESTMENTS AND CONVEYANCE
SURFACE WATER STORAGE AND APPLE
FOR RECHARGE NOT IN FIVE YEARS
BUT TODAY. ON TO MY FAVORITE
PART HOW DO WE DO BETTER FOR
TODAY AND FOR THE FUTURE. IN
THE SHORT TERM THERE ARE FEW
POTENTIAL SOLUTIONS THAT CAN
IMMEDIATELY DELIVER BENEFITS TO
THE COMMUNITIES MOST IN NEED.
THE LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR
SHOULD IMMEDIATELY AND PASSED
THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT OF FUNDING
POSSIBLE. INTO SHOVEL READY
PROJECTS THAT CAN IMPROVE THE
WATER SUPPLY FOR THOSE FARMS
COMMUNITIES AND ECOSYSTEMS THAT
HAVE MOST BEEN IMPACTED BY THE
DROUGHT WITH. AND WITHIN
EIGHTEEN MONTHS. FOR EXAMPLE
<c.magenta>OS BANOS CREEK RECLAMATION D.</c>
W. R. CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
MAINTAINED THE LOS MANIC STREET
DETENTION RESERVOIR AS A
DETENTION FLOOD CONTROL
RESERVOIR MEANING WATER IS HELD
IN THE RESERVOIR UNTIL IT
EVAPORATES. INSTEAD THE
OPERATIONS OF THE RESERVOIR
COULD BE MODIFIED TO IMPROVE
GROUNDWATER RECHARGE BY
INSTALLING A PIPELINE AND PUMP
STATION TO RELEASE FLOWS FROM
THE RESERVOIR INTO LOS BANOS
CREEK. IMPROVING WHAT
GROUNDWATER RECHARGE WATERSIDE
A SUPPLY RELIABILITY AND
HABITAT. FOUR TWO POINT NINE
MILLION ITS ESTIMATE THIS
PROJECT COULD GENERATE NEARLY
EIGHT THOUSAND ACRE FEET OF
GROUND WATER RECHARGE IN WET
YEARS WATER THAT IS CRITICAL
AND YEARS LIKE THE ONE WE'RE IN.
SECOND THE WATER TRANSFER
PROCESS. A VITAL LIFELINE FOR
FARMERS LIKE ME. SHOULD BE
STREAMLINED TO MOVE AS MUCH
WATER FROM WILLING SELLERS TO
WILLING BUYERS AS POSSIBLE WHEN
IT'S NEEDED. IT DOESN'T HELP ME
TO PURCHASE WATER FROM PARTNERS
IF I AM ONLY ABLE TO RECEIVE
THAT WATER WHEN MY PLANTS HAVE
ALREADY DIED. AND IMMEDIATE
EXAMPLE OF THIS WOULD BE TO CUT
THE GREEN TAPE BY REDUCING THE
REGULATORY HURDLES WHICH WOULD
EXPEDITE WATER TRANSFERS. FOR
INSTANCE DURING THE LAST TROUT
SEQUEL WAS WAIVED FOR CERTAIN
TYPES OF INTER REGIONAL WATER
TRANSFERS SIMILAR EFFORTS
SHOULD BE MADE THIS YEAR.
ANOTHER OPTION THAT WAS
IMPLEMENTED DURING THE LAST
DROUGHT IS THE INSTALLATION OF
BARRIERS IN THE DELTA TO
PREVENT SALT WATER INTRUSION.
HOW FOR LONG TERM IN THE LONG
TERM THE SOLUTIONS FOR
IMPROVING CALIFORNIA'S DROUGHT
RESILIENCE HAVE BEEN WELL
UNDERSTOOD FOR A LONG TIME.
ONLY A TEN YEAR AVERAGE THERE
IS ENOUGH PRECIPITATION AND
SNOWPACK TO MEET. CALIFORNIA'S
DEMANDS THE CHALLENGES MOVING
IT WHERE IT'S NEEDED WHEN IT'S
AVAILABLE WHICH IS LIMITED
DURING. LIMITED NOT A NUMBER OF
YEARS AND STORING IT FOR WHEN
IT'S NEEDED WHICH IS A LARGER
NUMBER OF YEARS. TRADITIONALLY
CALIFORNIA HAS RELIED ON THE
SNOW PACK TO BE A NATURAL
RESERVOIR AND THIS FIFTY
HISTORICALLY HAS WORKED WELL.
HOWEVER CLIMATE CHANGE MEANS
THAT CALENDAR CALIFORNIA'S WHAT
YEARS ARE BOTH MORE WET AND
LESS FREQUENT AND IT'S A DRY
YOURS ARE MORE FREQUENT AND
MORE DRY. SO CALIFORNIA MUST
ADAPT. THIS MEANS APPROVING THE
ADAPTIVE MANAGEMENT MANAGEMENT
OF OUR WATER SYSTEMS MANAGING
WATERSHEDS IN A COMPREHENSIVE
WAY THAT HAS MULTIPLE BENEFITS
INCLUDING WATER SUPPLY. IT IT
MEANS BUILDING PROJECTS THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF PROJECTS THAT
HAVE BEEN PLANNED FOR YEARS
SOME FOR DECADES THAT MUST BE
FINALLY BUILT THIS MEANS
RESTORING AND INCREASING
CONVEYANCE CAPACITY AND
INCREASING WATER STORAGE IN
CALIFORNIA PARTICULARLY SOUTH
OF THE DELTA. THERE ARE MANY
BILLS BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE
THAT WOULD ACCOMPLISH SOME OF
THOSE GOALS. BUT I WILL
HIGHLIGHT ONE OF THEM OF
PARTICULAR IMPORTANCE. SENATOR
MELISSA OR TITLES SB FIVE FIVE
NINE. SB FIVE FIVE NINE WOULD
MAKE A ONE TIME INVESTMENT TO
RESTORE THE CONVEYANCE CAPACITY
OF CALIFORNIA'S ARTERIAL CANALS
WHICH HAVE LOST SIGNIFICANT
CAPACITY. ADDRESSING THE
IMPACTS OF THE OF THE
SUBSIDENCE ALONG THESE CANALS
IS PERHAPS THE MOST IMPORTANT
STEP. TO BUILD TO BUILDING
RESILIENCE TO CHANGING CLIMATE
AND TO PRESERVING THE ECONOMY'S
JOBS ECOSYSTEMS OF CENTRAL AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. SEPARATELY
WE MUST FINALLY INCEASED WATER
STORAGE BY MOVING FORWARD WITH
PROJECTS LIKE EXPANDING SAN
LUIS RESERVOIR EXPANDING LOS
VAQUEROS RESERVOIR AND
INCREASING GROUNDWATER STORAGE
AND RECHARGE. THE SOLUTIONS ARE
THERE. THEY'VE BEEN STUDIED FOR
YEARS WE SIMPLY NEED TO HAVE
THE POLITICAL WILL TO FOLLOW
THROUGH. LUCKILY THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET SURPLUS COMBINED WITH
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ANTICIPATED
INVESTMENT IN INFRASTRUCTURE
COMBINED WITH BOND PROPOSALS
ADVANCED BY THE SENATE AND
CHAIRMAN GARCIA I MEAN THAT WE
CAN ADVANCE THEM NOW. DROUGHT
HAS BEEN AND WILL CONTINUE TO
BE A REALITY IN CALIFORNIA WE
MUST BE PREPARED. BUT
CALIFORNIA HAS ALSO BEEN
BLESSED WITH ABUNDANT NATURAL
RESOURCES SOME OF THE MOST
FERTILE LAND IN THE WORLD AND
CREATIVE SOLUTION ORIENTED
PEOPLE. FROM THE DAYS OF ITS
FOUNDING. WE HAVE SOIL WATER
AND PEOPLE THIS IS A PROBLEM WE
CAN OVERCOME WITH PLANNING
INVESTMENT FORWARD THINKING.
JOHN STEINBECK SAID IT BEST AND
IT NEVER FAILED THAT DURING THE
DRY YEARS THE PEOPLE FORGOT
ABOUT THE RICH YEARS AND DURING
THE WAIT YEARS THEY LOST ALL
MEMORY OF THE DRY YEARS. IT WAS
ALWAYS THAT WAY. SADLY THIS HAS
BEEN TRUE IN MANY AREAS OF
CALIFORNIA. THE PEOPLE OF THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY DO NOT HAVE
THAT LUXURY WE MUST DO BETTER
FOR THE FARMERS FOR THE PEOPLE
IN MY COMMUNITY AND FOR OUR
NATION'S FOOD SECURITY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I LOOK
FOR TO ANSWERING ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU- THIS IS THE MOST
GIVE FOR PREPPING IN THE
PERSPECTIVE OF THE AG INDUSTRY
IN CALIFORNIA. AND SOME REAL
CHALLENGES THAT ARE BEFORE ALL
OF US- WHEN IT COMES TO THIS
JOB DISCUSSION SO- PLEASE STAND
BY AND I'M SURE THERE'LL BE
SOME. QUESTIONS FOR YOU AS WELL
WE GET INTO OUR LAST-
PRESENTER. AND THAT IS- SANDY
CURL WITH THE SAN DIEGO. COUNTY
WATER AUTHORITY AND I JUST SO.
WANTED TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
MEMBERS THAT ARE HERE-
LISTENING DILIGENTLY AND-
WANTING TO. CHIME IN ON THIS
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND FOR
YOUR PARTICIPATION- OUTLASTED
THE SANDY- PLEASE- IF YOU'RE
READY- PROCEED WITH YOUR
PRESENTATION. GOOD AFTERNOON-%
AND CAN YOU SEE MY FLIGHTS. YES
YEAH- THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK HERE TODAY
ON THE GENERAL MANAGER OF THE
SAN DIEGO COUNTY WATER
AUTHORITY- I WANT TO THANK HER
GARCIA IN THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DISCUSS- WHAT WE'VE DONE IN OUR
STORY IN SAN DIEGO. COUNTY OUR
REGION AND- WHAT WE'VE DONE IN
TERMS OF- PREPARING FOR THE
DROUGHT WE ARE WHOLESALE-
PROVIDER FOR THE REGION AND OUR
AGENCY WAS CREATED IN NINETEEN
FORTY FOUR AS AN ACT OF THE
STATE LEGISLATURE TO BE ABLE TO
ALLOW US TO TAKE WATER FOR
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IN LA
BETTER KNOWN AS M. W. D. WE DO
THAT FOR ABOUT SAID- SYSTEM OF
PIPELINES THREE HUNDRED AND TEN
MILES OF THEM THAT DELIVER
WATER. TO OUR TWENTY FOUR
MEMBER AGENCIES THAT IS
HIGHLIGHTED ON THE MAP UP ON
THE SCREEN WE ALSO PLAY A
CRITICAL ROLE IN TERMS OF LONG
TERM WATER SUPPLY PLANNING AND
PREPARATION FOR THE REGION A
ROLE THAT NO OTHER AGENCY PLAYS.
IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY. BUT WE ARE
AT THE END OF A VERY LONG
PIPELINE THAT CONNECTS TO BOTH
THE STATE WATER PROJECT AND THE
COLORADO RIVER AQUEDUCT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT SAN
DIEGO WHO REALLY IS A UNIQUE
REGION. WE HAVE VERY FEW
NATURAL WATER RESOURCES SUCH AS
GROUNDWATER AND WE GET VERY
LITTLE RAINFALL- SUMMER
SURPRISED TO KNOW THAT WE GET
ABOUT TEN INCHES OF RAIN A YEAR
THAT COMPARES TO LOS ANGELES
THAT FIFTEEN INTEREST A YEAR.
AND SAN FRANCISCO WHICH GETS
ABOUT TWENTY ONE INCHES. SO THE
MORE MAJORITY OF OUR WATER
COMING INTO THE REGION TRAVEL
SOME DISTANCE. ON THE COLORADO
RIVER TO REACH THE WATER
AUTHORITY'S AQUIDNECK SYSTEM.
ABOUT- 10% OF THE WATER HOW WE
USE IN THE REGION INCOME SIX
HUNDRED MILES- THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA AQUEDUCT AND THE
REMAINING 24% IS FROM LOCAL
SUPPLIES AND THIS INCLUDES OUR
SEA WATER DESALINATION PLANT IN
CARLSBAD WATER PURIFICATION
PROJECTS- THAT ARE CURRENTLY-
THAT. CONSTRUCTED AND THOSE-
COMING ONLINE AND THEN SURFACE
WATER WHICH IS STORM WATER RUN
OFF AGAIN- A SMALL PORTION OF
THE WATER THAT WE HAVE. SO
TODAY I'M PROUD TO SAY THAT WE
HAVE SUFFICIENT SUPPLIES FOR
THIS VERY DRY YEAR I IN FACT
OUR STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT WE
HAVE SUFFICIENT SUPPLIES TO-
WHETHER MULTIPLE DRY YEARS IN A
ROW WHICH SUPPORT OUR QUALITY
OF LIFE AND OUR ECONOMY FOR
DECADES TO COME. SO HOW DID WE
GET HERE BACK IN NINETEEN
NINETY ONE THE COUNTY WATER
AUTHORITY. DISTINTIVO COUNTY
WAS RELIANT ON ONE SOURCE OF
WATER- FOR ABOUT 95% OF ITS
WATER. AND THEN DUE TO SEVERE
DROUGHTS- BECAUSE- THE SAN
DIEGO REGION TO SUFFER THIRTEEN
MONTHS OF SUPPLY ALLOCATION
REDUCTION. THAT ADULTS A SEVERE
BLOW TO THE ECONOMY AND THE
QUALITY OF LIFE AND THAT
HAPPENED IN THE- EARLY. IN
NINETEEN NINETY. THE PAINFUL
RESTRICTIONS ON WATER SUPPLY
CHAIN GALVANIZED HER REGION'S
BUSINESSES AND COMMUNITY
LEADERS TO MAKE DEMANDED.
STRATEGY THAT WOULD PREVENT
SUCH A SITUATION FROM HAPPENING
AGAIN IN FACT THERE WAS A RALLY
IN CLIENTS THAT WE SHOULD NEVER
AGAIN BE PLACED IN THIS
SITUATION. TACKLING A MYRIAD OF
CHALLENGES SUCH AS GROWING
DEMAND FOR WATER ACROSS THE
SOUTHWEST ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS
DROUGHTS AND IN THEIR STATE
LEGAL BATTLES THE WATER
AUTHORITY CAREFULLY CHARTED A
NEW COURSE FOR BEATING THE
REGION'S WATER NEEDS. THROUGH A
VARIETY OF SOURCES NICK AND NEW
OR IMPROVED FACILITIES IT WAS
THE WATER SUPPLY EQUIVALENT OF
A DIVERSIFIED STOCK PORTFOLIO.
THE MULTI PRONGED APPROACH
RELIED MORE. I'M MORE THAN
THREE BILLION DOLLARS
OPERATIONAL INVESTMENTS
RATEPAYERS LONGSTANDING
COMMITMENT TO WATER USE
EFFICIENCY INNOVATION AND
CHALLENGING THE STATUS QUO. AND
DIVERSIFY IT IS WHAT WE DID.
OVER THE PAST TWO DECADES HOW
DID WE DO IT FIRST RESIDENTS
AND BUSINESSES IN OUR REGION
ARE MAKING THE MOST USE OF
EVERY DROP OF WATER IN THE SAN
DIEGO REACH AND- WE ARE A
LEADER IN WATER CONSERVATION
AND WATER USE EFFICIENCY AND
HELPING DISTRICT HELPED SHAPE
THE STATUTORY AND REGULATORY
FRAMEWORK. IN THIS POLICY AREA
FOR MORE THAN THREE DECADES.
SAN DIEGO COUNTY RESIDENTS AND
BUSINESSES HAVE REDUCE PER
CAPITA WATER USE BY NEARLY HALF
OVER THE PAST THIRTY YEARS. AND
A COMMITMENT TO EFFICIENCY IS
SO DEEPLY INGRAINED IN OUR
CULTURE THAT THERE'S BEEN A
LITTLE REBOUND IN WATER USE
FALLING IN THE- TWENTY TWELVE
TO TWENTY SIXTEEN DROUGHT.
WE'VE ALSO ADDED NEW SUPPLIES
HISTORIC WATER TRANSFER AND
CONSERVATION AGREEMENTS ARE
PROVIDING SIGNIFICANT SUPPLIES
EACH YEAR IS NOW ABOUT 50% OF
THE SLOT SUPPLY THAT WE USE IN
THE SAN DIEGO REGION. OUR
MEMBER AGENCIES HAVE BUILT
PROJECTS TO RECYCLE WASTE WATER
FOR IRRIGATION USES USING
PURPLE PIPE AND LOOKING AHEAD
TO THEY ARE IN VARIOUS STAGES
OF DEVELOPMENT FOR POSSIBLE
REUSE PROJECTS. THAT WILL TURN
WASTE WATER INTO DRINKING WATER.
WE'VE TURN SEAWATER INTO
DRINKING WATER AT THE CARLSBAD
DESALINATION PLANT. AND WE'VE
BUILT ADDITIONAL STORAGE
CAPACITY SO WE CAN CAPTURE
RUNOFF FROM. NEW BIG RAINSTORMS
WE GET MOST YEARS. HERE ARE
SOME OF THE- MOST IMPORTANT
PROJECTS INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS THAT THE WATER
AUTHORITY HAS MADE TO EXPAND
OUR STORAGE AND DIVERSIFY OUR
WATER SUPPLY WE HAVE NEW AND
EXPANDED WATER STORAGE WE BUILT
ALLEVIATE PAIN DAM AND
RESERVOIR AND THAT WAS
COMPLETED IN TWO THOUSAND
THREE. THE SANTA CENTER YOU
REYES WHICH IS THE LARGEST
SINGLE INCREASE AND REGIONAL-
STORAGE IN OUR HISTORY WAS
COMPLETED IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FOURTEEN. WE BUILT A STATE OF
THE ART WATER TREATMENT PLANT
TO IMPROVE OUR REGION'S
CAPACITY TO TREAT WATER WATER
WE ALSO BUILT ADDITIONAL
PIPELINES AND PUMP STATIONS TO
ADD THE ABILITY TO MOVE WATER
INTO AND OUT OF. LIKE COLLEGES
TO TAKE BETTER ADVANTAGE OF
SUPPLIES THERE LAKE HUNDRED
PROJECT ALSO INCLUDES THE
ABILITY TO PRODUCE
HYDROELECTRIC POWER ON DEMAND
TO HELP MEET THE REGION'S
ENERGY NEEDS AND NOW WITH THE
CHANGE IN THE ENERGY
ENVIRONMENT IT IS USED EVERY
DAY. WE HAVE AN EXTENSIVE
AQUIDNECK PROTECTION PROGRAM
WHICH MONITORS THE CONDITION OF
OUR THREE HUNDRED AND TEN MILES
OF LARGE DIAMETER. WATER
TRANSMISSION PIPELINES AROUND
THE COUNTY WHICH MAKE UP THE
WATER AUTHORITY'S WATER SYSTEM.
THE GOOD NEWS. IS THAT WE HAVE-
INVESTORS ARE INVESTMENT MEANS
THAT WE HAVE SUFFICIENT WATER
SAID SPPLIES FOR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND BEYOND AND INDEED FOR
MULTIPLE WATER AND DRY WATER
YEARS. SO IF YOU LOOK AT THIS-
PIE CHART IT IS STARKLY
DIFFERENT FROM THE ONE THAT YOU
SAW- THAT I SHOWED YOU EARLIER
FROM NINETEEN NINETY ONE. OUR
DIVERSIFICATION HAS YIELDED
MANY BENEFITS- IN PROVIDING-
PROTECTION AGAINST DROUGHT AND
BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE THIS IS
WHAT OUR CARDS HARPER LOOK LIKE
AND THE MAJORITY OF THE
INCREASE DIVERSIFICATION. ON
THIS PIE CHART IS COMING IN THE
AREA OF POSSIBLE REUSE PROJECT.
THIS IS WHAT OUR WATER BILLS
ARE CAME FOR SAFE AND RELIABLE
WATER SUPPLIES EVEN WHEN
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF WATER TO
GO AROUND. LOOKING AHEAD I WANT
TO GIVE YOU A PICTURE ABOUT
SOME VERY IMPORTANT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PARTNERSHIPS
IN LINE WITH GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S
WATER RESILIENCY PORTFOLIO
MODEL. THE WATER AUTHORITY
BOARD OF DIRECTORS VOTED IN
JULY TWENTY NINETEEN TO SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S APPROACH WHICH
ALIGNS CLOSELY WITH OUR
APPROACH SINCE THE EARLY
NINETEEN NINETIES. POSSIBLE
REDUCE DEVELOPMENT AGAIN AS THE
NEXT INCREMENT OF WATER SUPPLY
IN THE REGION. COLLECTIVELY THE
REGION IS EXPECTED TO BRING
ONLINE MORE THAN A HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACRE FEET OF NEW
POSSIBLE RE USE WATER. IN THE
NEXT FIFTEEN YEARS. IMPORTANTLY
I AND AS WAS MENTIONED BY ONE
OF THE SPEAKERS EARLIER WE ARE
LOOKING FORWARD TO THE STATE'S
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK TO REMOVE
HURDLES FOR DIRECT POTABLE
REUSE. WHICH COULD EXPEDITE
DEVELOPMENT THE OF THESE
IMPORTANT WATER SUPPLIES AND
SAVE RATEPAYERS MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. WE ARE LOOKING FOR THE
OPTION FOR THE WATER
AUTHORITY'S STORE WATER IN LAKE
MEAD AND HELP THE COLORADO
RIVER BASIN AS A WHOLE WHICH
FINDS ITSELF IN A QUITE DIRE
SITUATION. THERE'S ALSO FUTURE
POTENTIAL FOR PARTNERSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES WITH REGIONAL
COMBAT SYSTEM THAT WOULD
TRANSPORT ARE INDEPENDENT KALRA
RIVER WATER SUPPLIES STRAIGHT
FROM THE IMPERIAL VALLEY TO SAN
DIEGO. THIS RECENT EDITORIAL
CARTOON FROM SAN DIEGO UNION
TRIBUNE SUCH THAT BASS HERE IN
SAN DIEGO COUNTY WE'VE TAKEN
THE SCOUTS MOTTO ALWAYS BE
PREPARED AS WE HEADED INTO
ANOTHER DROUGHT YEAR WITH OUR
CANTEENS FILLED BY MULTIPLE
WATER SOURCES. THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
HERE TODAY I'D BE HAPPY TO
DISCUSS ANY OF THESE ISSUES IF
WE- HAVE ADDITIONAL TIME TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND ALL OF THE PRISONERS ON
THIS- THIRD AND FINAL PANEL WE-
HAVE- DOING GOOD ON TIME WE'VE
THAT THIRTY MINUTES- THAT WE
RESERVE. FOR QUESTIONS AND
ANSWERS TO ANY OF THE PALACE
AND FALL ASK THAT THE MY
COLLEAGUES HERE. YOU WANT TO-
JUMP RIGHT IN. OF WHAT WE WANT
TO ASK QUESTIONS BEFORE PUBLIC
COMMENT YES SIR OKAY NOW GO
RIGHT TO SANDRA BECAUSE I HAD A
QUESTION IN REGARDS TO THE-
CARLSBAD DESALINATION PLANT.
WHAT IT COST YOU BUT THEN YOU
SAID IT WAS ONE BILLION DOLLARS.
HOW LONG DID IT TAKE YOU TO GET
THAT PLANT. CONSTRUCTED AND IS
IT CURRENTLY RUNNING. SURE I AM
HAPPY TO DRENCH STEERER-
QUESTIONS- COMMITTEE MEMBER-
THE PLANTWENT ONLINE IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN IT WAS ABOUT A FOURTEEN
YEAR- TIME LINE TO GET THE
PROJECT FROM INCEPTION TO
ACTUALLY IN OPERATIONS IT COST
ABOUT ONE BILLION DOLLARS IT
REPRESENTS ABOUT 10% OF OUR
WATER SUPPLY. IT IS A BIT OUR
MOST EXPENSIVE SOURCE OF SUPPLY
BUT BECAUSE IT IS 10% OF THE
SUPPLY WE MELT IT WITH OUR
OTHER SOURCES OF WATER- TO
PROVIDE A MELTED RATE- WHICH IS
MUCH MORE MODERATE. TAKE OUT OF
THAT ONE BILLION DOLLARS WHAT
WAS THE LEGAL COSTS THAT YOU
HAD TO SPEND FOR ALL THE
CHALLENGES THAT YOU FACED. I
DON'T HAVE THAT FIGURE RIGHT
OFF THE TOP- WE THIS WAS A
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP- THE
DEVELOPER WENT THROUGH THE
LEGAL- LAWSUITS- FOURTEEN
LAWSUITS- BEFORE- THIS PROJECT
COULD COME TO FRUITION- THOSE
WERE CARRIED AS THE- PRE
DEVELOPMENT COSTS- WHICH DID.
UGH GET. FOLDED INTO THE ENTIRE
COST OF THE PROJECT I CAN GET
BACK TO YOU BUT- THAT'S
CERTAINLY TIME AND MONEY-
INVOLVED IN THAT EFFORT- TO GET
THE PLANT UP AND RUNNING. IT IN
HOW MANY. ACRE HOW MANY ACRE
FEET OF WATER DO YOU. ARE YOU
ABLE TO PROCESS FOR THAT COST.
IT'S SAD SIX THOUSAND ACRE FEET-
AND THE- COSTS FOR ACRE FOOT-
INCLUDING A TEN MILE PIPELINE
THAT HAD TO BE- CONSTRUCTED TO
GET TO OUR- WATER PIPELINES-
FOR DISTRIBUTION- THE PER ACRE
FOOT COST IS TWO THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLARS AN
ACRE FOOT AGAIN IT IS OUR MOST
EXPENSIVE SUPPLY BUT WHEN
BLENDED WITH OUR OTHER CHEAPER
SOURCES OF WATER- IF WE'RE ABLE
TO PROVIDE- A RATE THAT IS MORE
MODERATE THAN IF WE- BEEN FULLY
1100% THE SOUTH. END USER JUST
A LITTLE OVER TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER ACRE FOOT THE HER
DIRECT TWO THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED AND. FIFTY DOLLARS PER
ACRE BUT SEVEN HUNDRED. AND I
WOULD CONSIDER THAT OF NOT IS
EXPENSIVE IN MY DISTRICT
BECAUSE YOU CAN RUN BETWEEN
FOUR AND FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
AN ACRE FEET. OR NOT THE CELL
BUT AS JUST OF WATER RIGHTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND THEN I
WANT TO ASK A- OF MISTER. DEL
VOCE. IF I SAY THAT RIGHT.
BEAUJOLAIS MOSQUE. THE QUESTION
IN REGARDS TO A BECAUSE I
UNDERSTAND YOU ARE ON A OF
WATER COMMISSION. WHAT IS YOUR
OPINION AND THE IMPACT YOUR
ABILITY TO MOVE PROP ONE MONEY
FORWARD FOR NEW STORAGE IN A
MORE TIMELY MANNER. AND TO BE
ABLE TO SPEED UP THAT PROCESS
FOR US AND I THINK HE WAS IN
THE HOUSE THANK YOU- JOE DEL
BOSQUE- IT HAS BEEN. KIND OF
SLOW IN MY OPINION OBVIOUSLY-
HAS TO GO THROUGH- OF A LENGTHY
PROCESS. TO GET APPROVED- IT
TOOK A WHILE JUST TO GET. THE
PROJECTS- EVALUATED BECAUSE
THEY HAD TO MEET CERTAIN
PARAMETERS FOR- FOR EVALUATION
FOR PUBLIC BENEFITS. AND I'M
NOT SURE AT THIS POINT IF
THERE'S ANY OF THEM UNDER
CONSTRUCTION I THINK I THINK
THAT THERE'S A GROUNDWATER BANK
IN KERN COUNTY THAT IS. I THINK
ALREADY LIKE ALMOST READY TO GO.
OTHER THAN THAT- I DON'T KNOW
OF ANY OTHERS. PIC THANK YOU
BECAUSE UP BY SET OF LAST FOUR
YEARS A MOJAVE WATER AGENCY.
AND WE'VE BEEN DOING UP IT'S A
FACT THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH TO FOR GROUNDWATER STORAGE
OF TRYING TO GET IT IN THE
MOJAVE. OF RIVER VALLEY AREA
MY- DISTRICT. AND THEN I'M
GONNA JUST MAKE A COUPLE
COMMENTS. BECAUSE ON THE AGENDA
BUT WE'VE DONE A LOT OF TALKING
AGAIN RIGHT NOW. AND THAT'S
pTALKING. WE NEED TO GET WATER
STORAGE IN CALIFORNIA AND PART
OF THE AGENDA SAYS IT CAP IT IS
CALIFORNIA READY FOR ANOTHER
DROUGHT. NO WE'RE ARE NOT
PREPARED AGAIN FOR ANOTHER
DROUGHT. BECAUSE WE DON'T STORE
THE WATER FOR WHAT YEARS FOR
WHEN WE NEEDED IN DROUGHT
YEARS. SO I LIKE TO WORK WITH
MY COLLEAGUES IN THE FUTURE
ESPECIALLY ON THIS COMMITTEE.
TO GET GROUNDWATER STORAGE
ABOVE GROUND STORAGE BUT WE
NEED STORAGE IN CALIFORNIA LOOK
FORWARD TO THE DISCUSSION IN
THE FUTURE. AND THANK YOU
EDUARDO FOR DOING THIS
COMMITTEE HEARING TODAY
APPRECIATED. THANK YOU THANK
YOU SIMILAR SMITH. CALLING THE
SHOTS- MISTER. DEL BOSQUE. YES
MINE'S DALLY SO I HAVE A LAST
NAME LIKE IT'S HARD AS WELL. I
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR SHARING
YOUR STORY TODAY MY HUSBAND'S-
FAMILY WERE HOMESTEADERS INTO
WITH THE TO LAKE BASIN WHICH
THEIR WATER HAS BEEN NOW. FROM
THE FARMERS THERE HAD THEY'VE
HAD ZERO ALLOCATION NOW MOVING
FORWARD. SO AND IT'S NEAR AND
DEAR TO OUR HEART AS FARMERS
OURSELVES SO I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TRAVELING
HERE TODAY AND SHARING YOUR
STORY AND ALL OF YOUR THOUGHTS
AND CONCERNS WITH THAT. I
REALLY APPRECIATE IT. THANK
YOU- IT WAS WORTH DRIVING UP
HERE TWO HOURS TO BE ABLE TO.
TALK TO YOU FACE TO FACE I
THOUGHT THAT THIS ISSUE IS. IS
SO IMPORTANT FOR US BECAUSE WE
HAVE BEEN SUFFERING THESE
DROUGHTS FOR TOO MANY YEARS.
WE'VE HAD WATER REDUCTIONS ON
OUR FARMS SINCE NINETEEN NINETY
PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE THAT. IN
THE MOST SEVERE ONES HAVE
HAPPENED SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND
NINE- SO IT'S SOMETHING THAT
HAS. YOU KNOW HAS NOT REACHED
MANY SOLUTIONS AND WE'RE WE'RE
REALLY REALLY REACHING OUT FOR-
SOMETHING THAT REALLY NEEDS TO
BE DONE NOW IS TO EXPEDITE
TRANSFERS SO WE CAN GET THE
WATER IN TIME TO GET THE CROPS
TO GROW THROUGH THE SUMMER.
BECAUSE WE'RE PLANTING CROPS
AND WE ONLY HAVE ENOUGH WATER
TO GET TO JULY. AND THE REST OF
THE WATER THAT WE NEED IS HUNG
UP IN THE TRANSFER. SO WE WOULD
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE IF
ANYTHING COULD BE DONE THERE TO
EXPEDITE THAT. AND OF COURSE WE
NEED THOSE LONG TERM PROJECTS-
ARE SOME OF THOSE PRICE X. THAT
WERE. BY THE CALIFORNIA WATER
COMING. WERE UNFORTUNATELY NOT
WHAT THEY WERE KIND OF UNDER
FUNDED SOME OF THESE PROJECTS
NEEDED MORE FUNDS. OF THE
PRIVATE THE PROPONENTS. DID NOT
HAVE THE FUNDING BECAUSE THE OF
PROP ONE FUNDS FELL SHORTER. OF
BOARD FOR THEM THEN THEY REALLY
NEEDED TO GET TO MAKE IT GO.
AND SO THAT'S WHY I THINK THAT
THIS IS A GOOD TIME FOR THE
STATE AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO COME IN. AND HELP
THEM WITH THOSE ADDITIONAL
FUNDS. OF PROJECTS LIKE
TEMPERANCE FLAT. GOT A VERY
PITIFUL AMOUNT I THINK THEY GOT
LIKE A HUNDRED SEVENTY SEVEN
MILLION. AND THE PROJECT COST
LIKE MAYBE TWO TWO BILLION. SO
THEY WERE WELL WELL SHORT OF
FUNDING AND THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT CAN BE DONE NOW HOPEFULLY.
AND MAYBE GET THOSE PROJECTS
STARTED. THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I DO HAVE
A QUESTION FOR SANDY WITH THE
SAN DIEGO COUNTY WATER AGENCY
AND- THIS IS IN RELATION TO
COLORADO RIVER- DROUGHT
CIRCUMSTANCES I MEAN HOW IS THE
WATER AGENCY AND HOW DO YOU SEE
OTHER. WATER AGENCIES- THAT
DEPEND ON A RIVER ALLOCATIONS
ARE PREPARING. AT THIS MOMENT
IN TIME FOR- WHAT'S TO COME.
YES AND PREPARING FOR THE
CUTBACKS AND THE FIRST TO TAKE
THOSE CUTBACKS WILL BE OF THE
STATE OF ARIZONA- THERE'S A LOT
OF EFFORT TALKING ABOUT WATER
EFFICIENCY MEASURES- ALONG. ALL
OF THE- BASIN STATES WHO RELY
ON THE COLORADO RIVER AND SO-
THERE'S A HUGE EFFORT IN THAT
REGARD- I THINK THAT- ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I HOPE HAPPENS
OUT OF THIS DROUGHT IS WE- HAVE
MORE COMMUNICATION AND BETTER-
SHARING OF WATER MANAGEMENT AS
I MENTIONED WE'RE LOOKING TO BE
ABLE TO STORE. SOME OF OUR
ALLOCATION OF COLORADO RIVER
WATER IN LAKE MEAD FOR PROVIDE
A HIGHER ELEVATION THERE- AND
BE ABLE TO USE THAT WATER- WORK
APPROPRIATELY- WHEN WE NEED TO
AND IT COULD PROVIDE A SOLUTION
ON THE RIVER- FOR. THE FOLKS
WHO ARE RELYING ON IT SO- YOU
KNOW THERE'S MANY CONVERSATIONS
GOING ON A LOT OF WORK
HAPPENING IN THE AND- VERY
SIMILAR CHALLENGES TO WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT IN IN.
CALIFORNIA- SO I THINK YOU HAVE
THAT'S I WOULD END WITHOUT. ARE
THERE ANY ARE THERE ANY
SPECIFIC MEASURES THAT THE YOUR
AGENCY IS ALREADY TAKING ON- AS
YOU ANTICIPATE- TIMES HAVE COME
IN FROM BOTH THE STATE AND TO
AS DE ALLOCATION RESTRICTIONS
OR FOR THAT MATTER THE-
CIRCUMSTANCES OF. THE COLORADO
RIVER- DROP. YEAH WE CONTINUE
TO HAVE VERY STRONG WATER USE
EFFICIENCY AS I MENTIONED WE'VE
DROPPED OUR PER CAPITA USE BY
50% OF THE LAST THIRTY YEARS WE
CONTINUE TO INVEST IN-
EFFICIENT USE OF WATER-
FOCUSING ON OUTDOOR LANDSCAPING
ASSISTING RESIDENTS AND
BUSINESSES AND TRANSFORMING.
THEIR LANDSCAPE- TWO MORE
DROUGHT TOLERANT- OPTIONS AND
WE'VE HAD HUGE SUCCESS WITHOUT
AS WELL AS PROVIDING TRAINING
CLASSES FOR RESIDENTS AND
BUSINESSES AS WELL AS
LANDSCAPERS TO HELP A HELP IN
THAT TRANSFORMATION PROCESS
THOUGH WE CONTINUE TO HAVE A
HEAVY EMPHASIS ON- ADDED.
EFFICIENCY AS WELL AS
SUPPORTING IN OUR MEMBER
AGENCIES AS THEY MOVE FORWARD
TO DEVELOP- PURE WATER PROJECTS
ARE POSSIBLE REUSE PROJECTS- IT
REALLY AGAIN LOOKING FORWARD TO
THE STATE REGULATIONS WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY TO STREAMLINE TO GO
TO DIRECT POTABLE REUSE
PROJECTS. THANK YOU FOR
SHARING- WHAT YOUR AGENCY IS AS
DOING- IN A PROACTIVE MANNER
QUESTION FOR US TO FIND OF THE
AND THE RECENT WATER BOARD
NEEDS ASSESSMENT SHOWS A LOT OF
SMALL. WHAT DO YOU. I BELIEVE
WE SHOULD BE DOING ARE YOU
MENTIONED PRIORITIZING
REGIONAL- PARTS OF THE STATE-
TO ENSURE THAT THESE PROACTIVE
MEASURES AND INVESTMENTS GO
FIRST- DO YOU HAVE MORE
SPECIFICS THAT YOU COULD SHARE
WITH US- FOR OUR CONSIDERATION
AS WE ARE HAVING THESE THESE
THESE DISCUSSIONS AS WE AS AN
ASSEMBLY- WORKING WITH MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE PUT FORWARD
OUR- DROUGHT RESILIENCY
PACKAGE- IN THE NEXT FEW WEEKS-
THAT WOULD HELP- WITH-
COLLECTIVE EFFORTS THAT BILL
FOR THE SENATE HAS PUT FORWARD.
WOULD LOVE TO HEAR MORE
SPECIFICS ON YOUR AND IN TERMS
OF HOW WE ARE MORE INTENTIONAL
WITH- PRIORITIZING THESE
COMMUNITIES THAT YOU SPEAK OF
AND YOUR- PRESENTATION.
ABSOLUTELY GERMAN ARMY I LIKE
JUST YOU KNOW POINT OUT THAT WE
HAVE ENOUGH DATA TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT WE HAVE THE SYSTEMS
WITHOUT PROGRAM WHERE WE HAVE
THE SYSTEM THAT THEY ARE
CURRENTLY NOT PROVIDING SAFE
DRINKING WATER. MORE
IMPORTANTLY THE MOST RECENT
REPORT JUST RELEASED A REALLY
GOOD UNDERSTANDING OF WHERE WE
HAVE SYSTEM AT RISK OF NOT
HAVING SAFE DRINKING WATER SO.
WE SHOULD NOT WAIT TO DO MORE
STUDIES ON FIGURE OUT WHERE WE
HAVE THE SYSTEM CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES AT RISK OF LOSING
WATER COMPLETELY I DON'T WANT
TO BE VERY INTENTIONAL AND
TARGETED THE RESOURCE. RIGHT
NOW GET READY FOR THIS DROUGHT
INSURE THAT RESIDENTS ARE AWARE
OF THE RESOURCES THAT WE WILL
HAVE AVAILABLE FOR THEM. SO
THAT WE HAVE A VERY GOOD
QUARTER TO PLAN WE HAVE STRONG
COMMUNICATION SO THAT PEOPLE
HAVE TO SUFFER AND SCRAMBLE ON
WHO TO CALL WHEN. WELLS GO DRY.
AND IT VERY WELL ISSUE THE
WORST. WITH AN AYE AYE WANT TO
SAY THAT. AS WE CONTINUE TO
LIVE IN THE STATE WERE DROUGHT
WILL BE. THE NEW NORMAL WE NEED
TO REALLY INVEST IN DROUGHT
RESILIENT INFRASTRUCTURE. SO
THAT WE ENSURE. THAT THESE
COMMUNITIES CONSISTING WITH
STRANGERS. AND I THINK WE CAN
DO THAT. THANK YOU FOR SHARING.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT- ONE I
THEN GO TO A DAVID- YOUR REGION
HAS BEEN HIT HARD BY THE
WILDFIRE IN RECENT YEARS. WHAT
HAS THAT MEANT FOR YOUR WATER
AGENCIES ABILITY TO DELIVER THE
WATER FOR YOUR COMMUNITIES AND
FARMERS IN PARTICULAR AS- YOU
KNOW WE CONTINUE TO FACE THIS.
SITUATION SUPERVISOR- DAVID
RIGHT TO VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE QUESTION OBVIOUSLY IS
ADDED- COMPLEXITY TO THE- THE
WATER SYSTEM AND THE DEMANDS
THERE AND- LIKE I SAID- YOU
KNOW THE DROUGHT. HAS AFFECTED-
WATER SUPPLY THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTY- ED PONDS THAT ARE
SCATTERED THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY
OR A VALUABLE PLACES FOR
HELICOPTERS TO DIP THEIR
BUCKETS AND GET THE WATER FOR.
OF FIGHTING THIS FIRE SO- LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH OUR
STATE PARTNERS TO BE ABLE TO-
HAVE PROGRAMS AVAILABLE
RESILIENCY SAKE BUT ALSO FOR
FIREFIGHTING SAKE- TO BE ABLE
TO- YOU KNOW MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE PLANS WERE AVAILABLE- IN
DROUGHT YEARS IN FIRE SEASONS
OF GOING FORWARD- AND AGAIN I
LIKE I MENTIONED EARLIER- THE
WATERSHED. THE HEALTH OF THE
WATERSHED IS VITALLY IMPORTANT
TO THE HEALTH OF THE OF THE
RIVERS AND RESERVOIRS AND-
AFTER FIRE. THE GROUND BECOMES-
YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY VERY TOXIC
WITH A LOT OF RUNOFF WE JUMP ON
THOSE THINGS VERY QUICKLY BUT
YOU CAN'T CONTROL EVERYTHING
AND YOU'RE CONSTANTLY- BEING
CHALLENGED ESPECIALLY WITH THE
SIZE AND SCALE OF THE- FIRES
THAT WE'VE EXPERIENCED IN THIS
COUNTY I DO APPRECIATE THAT
QUESTION LIKE EVERYTHING IT'S
RESOURCES AND IT'S MAKING SURE
THAT YOU'RE PLANNING. OF
PLANNING. AHEAD AND HAVING
THOSE RESOURCES ON HAND. THANK
YOU SO MUCH I HAVE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS I DON'T KNOW IF ANY
OF MY COLLEAGUES. DOES WELL
BUT- WE DO WANT TO JUST
ACKNOWLEDGE AND THANK YOU ALL
OF THE PANELISTS WHO ARE.
VENTURA GET SOME GOOD TIME WITH
US ON THIS IMPORTANT SUBJECT.
AS I MENTIONED IN MY PRIOR-
PRACTICING OF A QUESTION- OUR
OBJECTIVES ARE TO- PUT TOGETHER
THE ASSEMBLY. PRIORITIES AS IT
RELATES TO WOULD BE DROUGHT.
CONTINGENCY PLAN AND- ATTEMPT
TO ALIGN. OUR OBJECTIVES WITH
OUR COUNTERPARTS IN THE- OTHER
HOUSE TO ENSURE. THAT THE
CALIFORNIA PUTS HIS BEST FOOT
FORWARD. IN A MONTH PROACTIVE
MANNER THAT WE CAN WE CLEARLY
HEARD TODAY. THAT WE'VE GOT A
LOT OF A LOT OF WORK TO DO. AND
IN THAT AREA. SEEN THAT THERE
AREN'T ANY MORE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AGAIN THANK ALL THE
PANELISTS WE'RE GOING TO. ASK
THE MODERATOR- TO. LET US KNOW.
IF AND HOW MANY- PUBLIC
COMMENTS ARE LINED UP. AT THIS
TIME. AND ACCORDING TO HOW MANY
FOLKS WE HAVE GIVEN THAT WE
HAVE. FIFTEEN MINUTES- WILL
DETERMINE IF THERE'S A ONE
MINUTE OR TWO MINUTE. LIMIT FOR
PUBLIC COMMENTS- MODERATOR WILL
YOU PLEASE- OPEN UP THE LINES.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. IT
LOOKS LIKE WE CURRENTLY HAVE
TWO IN Q. IT'LL JUST BE ONE
MOMENT FOR THE FIRST COMMENT.
THANK YOU. FIRST COMMENT IS
FROM LINE ONE THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
TURN MEMBERS JULIA HALL THE
DISSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
WATER AGENCIES THANK YOU FOR
YOUR ATTENTION TO THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE IF YOU REALLY SHORT
COMMENTS. WE DID SUBMIT A
COMMENT LETTER ON THE TOPIC TO
THE COMMITTEE AS WELL FOR
MEMBERS RUBIO THERE WAS ONE
ASPECT OF OUR COMMENTS THAT I
WANTED TO EMPHASIZE BASED ON
THE CONVERSATION TODAY. OF
COURSE THE PORTS THE
LEGISLATURE'S EFFORT TO ENACT
BOTH DROUGHT REALLY FUNDING IN
THE BUDGET PROCESS THIS YEAR TO
ADDRESS IMMEDIATE CHALLENGES.
AND A CLIMATE RESILIENT FONG
THAT INCLUDES FUNDING FOR WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT INCLUDING
IMPROVED WATER SUPPLY
RELIABILITY AT CALIFORNIA FACES
THE IMPACT OF CLIMATE CHANGE
INCLUDING DROUGHT. BOTH OF
THESE ARE CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
AS WE PREPARE FOR CURRENT THE
FOR CURRENT CONDITIONS AND MAKE
LONGER TERM INVESTMENTS REPAIR
FOR FUTURE CHALLENGES DUE TO
CLIMATE. CHANGE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OUR NEXT
COMMENT JUST FROM LINE ONE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON TO THE CHAIR OF
THE COMMITTEE MICHAEL CLAIBORNE
LEADERSHIP COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE NONPROFIT
BUSINESS OUR CANDIDATES
COACHELLA VALLEY. I'D SAY THIS
IS A TIMELY CONVERSATION AND
THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
BRINGING IT UP TODAY- DROUGHT
CONDITIONS WORK ARE WORSENING.
AND IT BECOMING EVER MORE CLEAR
THAT MORE FREQUENT AND SEVERE
DROUGHTS IS THE NEW NORMAL.
DURING THE LAST DROUGHT
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS
BLOCKED ACCESS TO DRINKING
WATER CAUGHT BY DROPPING DISHES
THE GRAVEL GROUNDWATER UPPER
POBRE PUMPING. MOSTLY BY
AGRICULTURE. WE LEARNED A LOT
DURING THE LAST DROUGHT. AND WE
ALL TO DEVELOP ADDITIONAL TOOLS
INCLUDING STATE MY THE FEEDBACK
REPORT. THE DRINKING WATER
NEEDS ASSESSMENT AT THE EIGHTY
EIGHT MANDATORY CONSOLIDATION
AT THAT THIRTY THE SAFER
PROGRAM AND PICKING UP. THE
QUESTION IS WILL WE FIND THAT
EFFECTIVELY USE THE TOOL TO
PROTECT COMMUNITIES AND
HOUSEHOLDS ACCESS TO DRINKING
WATER. FOR FUNDING WE NEED IN
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET STANGEL
FUNDING FOR DRINKING WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE THE STATE BOARD
IDENTIFIED AT THE HAS BEEN
MENTIONED FOUR POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS UNFUNDED NEED
FOR DRINKING WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE. FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDING FOR
DROUGHT RESILIENCE- THIRTY
MILLION FOR PROACTIVE DROUGHT
PLANNING. FUNDING FOR CIGNA
IMPLEMENTATION FOCUSED ON
DRINKING WATER AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. AND
FUNDING FOR CONSERVATION
INCLUDING DIRECT INSTALL
PROGRAMS. IN ADDITION WE NEED A
COORDINATED RESPONSE THAT
INCLUDES STATE WATER BOARD D.
W. R. O. YET U. S. B. A. AND
GLOBAL JURISDICTIONS TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROVIDERS AND
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES. AND
OTHERS WITH RESPECT TO TAKE MY
ONLY A STRONG AT THE LOCAL JET
SKIS. AND A QUARTER
UNFORTUNATELY MANY OF THOSE ARE
NOT VERY GOOD CERTAINLY NOT THE
ONE THAT JOAQUIN VALLEY. WE
NEED TO KNOW YOU ARE IN THE
STATE WATER BOARD TERRORISM
STRONG REGULATORY BACKSTOP TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU. PROTECT
ACCESS TO DRINKING WATER.
DURING THE LAST DROUGHT
AGRICULTURE A PLATE TWO THIRDS
OF THEIR LOCK SERVICE WATER
SUPPLY WITH ADDITIONAL
GROUNDWATER PUMPING. AND A
DIRECT RESULT HOUSEHOLD BLOCK
BRING THE WATER. THIS IS IN THE
CARE OF THE ISSUE EVEN DURING
THE LAST DROUGHT THERE RIGHT
ENOUGH WATER FOR DOMESTIC
FLIGHTS. AND AGRICULTURE IF
USED WISELY AND SUSTAINABLY.
THERE'S ALSO A NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL LEGAL TOOLS LIKE
SENATOR LINDA CONSOLIDATES BELL
AT BEFORE- THREE. WHICH WOULD
ALLOW THE STATE WATER BOARD
PROJECT PROACTIVELY FACILITATE
AND MANDATE WATER
CONSOLIDATION. OF IRAQ WATER
SYSTEMS. AND WELLS BEFORE THEY
FAILED. FINALLY THE LAST
DROUGHT THIS. IMPACT
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
PARTICULAR BUT CAN AND THE
JOAQUIN. AFFECT DROUGHT
RESPONSE SEPARATE DRINKING IS
NOT JEFF AND- TO THAT IF. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THIS COMMITTEE THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE ADMINISTRATION AS WE
NAVIGATE THIS IMPENDING
PROPERTY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH A MODERATOR ANY OTHER
CALLS IN THE QUEUE. YES WE HAVE
FOUR BORING SHE WILL WEAR
AROUND ONE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M WENDY RIVER BUSH
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CAL
DETAIL WE EDUCATE AND PROMOTE
THE DEVELOPMENT OF PRACTICE IN
SEAWATER DESALINATION WITH ANY
MANAGEMENT CALIFORNIA. ONE OF
THE KEY DROUGHT LESSONS LEARNED
IS THAT OUR STATE MUST CHECK
THE BOX ON ALL OF THE ABOVE IN
TERMS OF WATER SUPPLIES. WHILE
WATER MANAGERS WORK TOWARDS
THIS IN MORE NORMAL WATER YEARS
IT'S EVEN MORE CRITICAL WHEN WE
CROSSED OVER THE THRESHOLD INTO
DROUGHT. WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
CONSERVE AND IMPLEMENT WATER
EFFICIENCY WE NEED TO EXERCISE
MARC CONJUNCTIVE USE BETWEEN
THE ABOVE GROUND AND GROUND
WATER STORAGE. WE NEED TO
RECYCLE WATER AND YES WE ALSO
NEED TO UTILIZE BRACKISH AND
SEAWATER DESALINATION WE DON'T
HAVE THE LUXURY OF USING JUST
ONE OR TWO SOURCES OF WATER
SUPPLY WITH IN CALIFORNIA. WE
MUST HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY TO
USE THEM ALL PARTICULARLY IN A
DROUGHT. WE'RE REALLY PROUD OF
OUR MEMBERS THAT HAVE PERFORMED
AND DO YOU PERFORM THE STEADY
AND CHALLENGING WORK ON
BRACKISH AND FEEDWATER
DECELERATE CHECKED. SOMETIMES
OVER TWENTY YEARS FROM PLANNING
TO REGULATORY PERMITS THE
CONSTRUCTION OPERATION AND
DELIVERY OF DRINKING WATER WE
NEED TO KEEP PURSUING THE SALAD
ORDER TO CONTINUE TO DIVERSIFY
OUR WATER SUPPLY PORTFOLIO.
DEVELOP SECURE IT'S LOCAL IT'S
A CLIMATE CHANGE AND DROUGHT
RESILIENCE SOURCE OF NEW AND
PURE WATER SUPPLY FOR GOLDEN.
STATE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WONDER THREE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE ARE VERY
NIELSEN WITH THE GOLDEN STATE
SALMON ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
THE ENTIRE CALIFORNIA SALMON
FISHING INDUSTRY OUR INDUSTRY
IN SUPPORT OF ONE POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS IN ANNUAL-ECONOMIC ACTIVITY. TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND JOBS WITH OUR SEVEN
RUNS ARE HEALTHY UNFORTUNATELY
THAT'S NOT THE CASE TODAY AND
LIKELY WON'T BE THE CASE FOR
THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS AFTER
THE LAST DROUGHT THE PUBLIC
POLICY INSTITUTE CALIFORNIA
SENATE NATURAL RESOURCES
SUFFERED AS A SECTOR MORE THAN
ANY OTHER SECTOR. THAT INCLUDES
THE FISHING INDUSTRY BOB AND
THERE IS UNFORTUNATELY A RISK
OF SIMILARLY CATASTROPHIC
DAMAGE TO NATURAL RESOURCES IN
THE FISHING INDUSTRY DURING
THIS DROUGHT I LIKE TO THINK
JUST FOUR QUICK POINTS.
SEARCHES THAT ARE SEVEN RUN
HAVE RECOVERED FROM OUR LAST
DROP OF THE SALMON FISHING
SEASON COMMERCIAL AND
RECREATIONAL FOR THIS HERE- IS
ABOUT SIXTY FROM MOST OF THE
STATE 6265% OR MORE OF LESS
THAN A NORMAL SEASON ABOUT THE
SEASON IS DONE MORE THAN CUT IN
HALF. ALSO GOING INTO THIS YEAR
FISHING FAMILIES BUSINESSES AND
COMMUNITIES ARE FACING REAL
HARDSHIPS SECOND POINT- MISTER
DOUBLE WITH CDFW MENTION THE
TRUCKING OF JUVENILE FISH TO
INCREASE THE SURVIVAL OF
HATCHERY FISH THIS YEAR- BOB
WE'RE PLEASED TO SEE THAT
TRUCKING WE CALL OUR
ORGANIZATION CALLED FOR THE
TRUCKING WE STRONGLY SUPPORTED.
THAT ACTION IS ON LIFE SUPPORT
MEASURE THAT YOU NEEDED BECAUSE
WE'VE LET OUR MEMBERS BECOME
LEGAL FOR BABY SALMON AND OUR
INDUSTRY DEPENDS ON HEALTHY
RIVERS. BOB GOOD POINT IS
REGARDING TEMPERATURE
CONDITIONS FOR SALMON THIS YEAR
MR BG WITHIN ARE YOU SEE
MENTIONED THIS IN HIS TESTIMONY
I'M BACK IN TWENTY FOURTEEN TO
TWENTY FIFTEEN WE LOST MORE
THAN 90% OF OUR NATURAL
SPAWNING WHERE RUN AND FALL RUN
SALMON ON THE SACRAMENTO THIS
WAS SEEN AS ONE OF THE GREATEST
FAILURES DURING THE LAST
DROUGHT. WE CAN SEE THAT SAME
SORT OF LOS AGAIN THIS YEAR
MOST. THE STATE BOARD ACTS IN
THE NEXT COUPLE OF TO INCREASE
KEPT PROTECTION FOR SALMON BOWL
YESTERDAY. IN THE FINAL. THE
CURRENT SET OF STE. BOARD HELLO
STANDARDS FOR BATTLE TO SYSTEM.
TWENTY FIVE YEARS OLD AND THOSE
STANDARDS IN SIMPLE FAILED. AND
THAT FAILURE IS MORE CLEAR
DURING DRY. ON THE STATE
BORDERS BEEN WAITING NOW FOR
YEARS FOR VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS-
THAT WOULD REPLACE TRADITIONAL
STANDARDS THOSE VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENTS APPEAR NOT TO BE
FORTHCOMING. NEW STATE BOARD
STANDARDS OF ONE OF THE MOST
CRITICAL DROUGHT PREPARATION
MEASURES FOR THE ECOSYSTEM IN
THE FISHING INDUSTRY. I AND
IT'S PAST TIME FOR THE SUPPORT
OF FINALIZE AND IMPLEMENT NEW
STANDARDS. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO SPEAK TODAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
I ONE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON SURE
NUMBERS DJANGO PROVIDING
COMMENTS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA TROUT TROUT
UNLIMITED AN ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND ALL THESE
ORGANIZATIONS ARE GRATEFUL TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR HOLDING THIS
HEARING AND RECOGNIZING THE
DROUGHT CONVERGENCES AN
ACCURATE ASSESSMENT OF IF WE'RE
PREPARED IS ESSENTIAL TO
STRATEGICALLY MANAGING
INVESTMENT. BUT THERE'S ALSO A
NEED TO BE SWEPT IN MAKING
SMART INSIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS
WHERE WE IDENTIFIED THEY'RE
NEEDED ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
TRACKING PROBLEM LIMITED I
WANTED TO RAISE THAT IN
ADDITION TO FUNDING WHICH WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE FOR SHRINK
WHILE ENHANCEMENT THE COSTA
MONITORING PROGRAM AND OTHER
WATER QUALITY ACTIVITIES THAT
WE'VE OUTLINEDIN A LETTER
SUBMITTED TO THE LEGISLATURE.
THERE'S ALSO A NEED FOR CHANGES
IN STATUTE TO STREAMLINE A LOT
OF THIS WORK ON BEHALF OF
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND I
WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT THE NEED
FOR STRATEGIC INVESTMENTS TO
SUPPORT EXACTLY. TECHNOLOGY
WHICH INCLUDES AFRICA ADVANCE
STRATEGICALLY UNDER PURPOSING
AN ECLIPSE GROWERS WITH THE
TOOLS AND ASSISTANCE NECESSARY
TO SUSTAINABLY MANAGE WATER
AGAIN WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK
YOU FOR PRO PROMPTING THE
CONVERSATION IN ALLOWING US
PRIDE PRIDE COMMENTS AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES AND ENSURE THE
STATE IS PREPARED FOR AND
RESILIENCY THROUGHOUT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M
MORE THIRTY NINE. YEAH GOOD
AFTERNOON CHEN BIRDS NAME IS
CRYSTAL BALL FLETCHER. ACTIONS
OUR COMMUNICATION WITH OTHER
AND YOU HAVE BEEN I. AND
WORKING THE STATE ONE BOARD IN
THE- FOR MORE. DROPPED INTEREST
PLAN- YOU KNOW I WHAT WE'VE
HEARD. WE A CRIB A COMPANY
APPROACH TO ADDRESS FOCUS. OR
LONG TERM IMPACTS TO WATER
QUALITY WATER ACCESS AND ARE
EAGER- AND IN ORDER TO DELIVER
THE HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER AND
PROTECT EVERY. RESIDENTS RIGHT
TO CLEAN WATER WE MUST ENSURE
BOTH ONE STATE AGENCY OFFICIALS
COURTNEY PARIS FONG. AND I
PREPARE TO LIVE WATER SUPPLY
EQUIPMENT AND RESOURCES TO-
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES. ARE WHY
WE ARE THE LEGISLATURE TO SCORE
AT THE BARBECUE WHICH WILL HELP
DROUGHT. SEEING CALIFORNIA'S
MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
WILL HELP PREVENT CATASTROPHIC
WATER SHORTAGES. WATER
SHORTAGES BY IMPROVE THE LOCAL
PLANNING INCREASING DATA
COLLECTION UPDATING ORIGINALLY.
EMERGENCY RESPONSE OF. AN
IMPROVING STATEWIDE
COORDINATION. ENGINE I A PANEL
OF BURGLAR ALARM BANK I WOULD
WATER CENTER HAD GREATLY HOBDAY
ALREADY. RIGHT HE'S STILL DOING
MORE BUT WHAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW
WITH THE DATE THE NEW DELHI
PARKWAY WATERBORNE DROUGHT WITH.
AND THE STATE WATER BOARD
DOESN'T MATTER. FOR- WHAT DOES
NATION AT WAR WITH GERMANY AND-
THE NEXT DROUGHT LEVEL INTEREST
FOR MOST ONE Q. AFTER THE WAR
AND LIKE TO TRY YOU KNOW BACK
TO GROW WATER AND- HAD- PANEL I
THINK. OF THE VERY NAY. BY
WATER CRITICAL TRIAL BURKE
DURING DRY YEARS AGO SEEING
ABOUT SIXTY OF CALIFORNIA Y.
QUITE. GOT WATER. THEREFORE IS
SIMPLE THAT WE NOT. I WANTED TO
BE ABLE. TO PLEASE ACTUALLY OF
WORK YOU THINK OF BILL WILL DIE.
DROUGHT CONDITIONS- AND ONE OF
THE LONG EMISSIONS. WITH THE
TWENTY YEAR. TIME FRAME THE
CHIEF SOMETHING- SO I'LL PEOPLE
ARE YOU ARE THE WATER. AND
THERE ARE WILD OUT BY DRY- EVEN
NOW RIGHT AND WE NEED TO GET
SUPPORT OUR MOST IMPACTED. BY
END OF THE OF LOCAL. TO MANAGE
OUR- BELIEF. OF HELPING PEOPLE
YOUR ENGAGED COLD AT THE PORT
DISCUSSION TOP OF. AND WE.
NUMBER THIS IS MARK SMITH ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA WATER FROM
THE GROUND PLAN WATER DISTRICT
WANTED TO TOUCH BRIEFLY ON THE
IMPACT OF DROUGHT WILL BE
HAVING TO WILDLIFE REFUGES AND
THE PACIFIC FLYWAY. IMPACTS ON
MIGRATORY BIRDS AS YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA IS THE HEART OF THE
PACIFIC FLYWAY WHICH STRETCHES
FROM THE TIP OF ALASKA DOWN TO
SOUTH AMERICA. IN YOUR
CALIFORNIA FROM THE KLAMATH TO
THE SALTON SEA AND EVERYTHING
IN BETWEEN. THIS YEAR WILDLIFE
REFUGES ARE SLATED TO RECEIVE
LESS THAN 60% OF THEIR TOTAL
WATER SUPPLY. THE WEAPON
MANAGERS ARE HAVING A HARD TIME
WITH THE MANAGEMENT. OF THEIR
WEAPONS THAT YOU KNOW OUR
WEAPONS HAVE BEEN DISCONNECTED
FROM FLOWS AND THEY ARE MANAGE
WEAPONS WE HAVE TO MOVE THE
WATER TO THAT AND PUT THE WATER
ON THEM AND WE NEED THAT. WEBER
MANAGERS OF PRESERVING LIMITED
SUPPLIES FOR PEAK MIGRATION THE
BALL INSTEAD OF PROVIDING FOR
SPRING IRRIGATION AND SUMMER
BREEDING HABITAT. IS INABILITY
TO IRRIGATE AND PROVIDE
BREEDING HABITAT REDUCES THE
PRODUCTIVITY OF THE MARCH
INCREASE WILDLIFE HEALTH AND
BREEDING IMPACTS. GIVEN THE
LIMITED WATER SUPPLY THE
WEAPONS COMPLEXES WILL GO DRY
FOR PROLONGED PERIODS OF TIME.
AND OVERCROWDING OF MIGRATORY
WATERFOWL WILL BE GREATLY
INCREASED ON THIS DRAMATICALLY
REDUCE WHAT ONE FOUR CORRECT
YOU MAY BE AWARE THAT THE
CLAMOR. WHAT THE DRIEST IT IS
EVER BEEN THIS LAST YEAR AND WE
HAD A BOTULISM OUTBREAK THAT
KILLED TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
BIRDS THE OVERCROWDING. IT'S
JUST HORRIBLE FROM THAT
PERSPECTIVE. THIS DROUGHT WILL
BE ESPECIALLY SEVERE FOR
WILDLIFE REFUGES THAT NEED TO
RECEIVE ADEQUATE WATER SUPPLIES
ON THE SCHEDULE. TO BE THEIR
MOST PRODUCTIVE TO MILLIONS OF
MIGRATORY BIRDS THAT WILL COME
THIS YEAR REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
OR NOT WE HAVE WATER. IT'S LIKE
HAVING A GROCERY STORE WITH THE
LIGHTS ON BUT NO FOOD ON THE
SHELVES. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND ATTENTION AND TO
HOLDING THIS HEARING TODAY WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU ON THESE ISSUES. GOING
FORWARD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
HAVE NOT CRIME SINK AT THIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MY- I WANT
TO JUST TO- A KNOWLEDGE. WORK
OF ART TO CONSOLE. FOR AND PUT
THIS SO HEARING TOGETHER AND-
COORDINATING WITH ALL THE
PANELISTS THAT THIS TIME. THAT
WE WILL ADJOURN.